estce que tout le monde s
installé on reprend l'examen du projet
de loi pour contrôler l'immigration et
améliorer l'intégration j'appelle les
amendement de suppression l'arle 1
g je n'ai pas de personne pour défendre
les amendements
578 le 864
monsieurre moi si vous souz
allez monsieur valallot ce caract ré des
études
oui c'est un amendement de suppression
d'un article qui vient durcir les règles
de contrôle du caractère réel et sérieux
des études euh qui euh des étudiants
étrangers c'est un examen qui a déjà
lieu au moment de la demande de titre de
séjour étudiant qui quand on regarde les
volumes et dans une très grande majorité
sont des visas de moins d'un an ou de 1
an à 5 ans très peu de titres pluannuel
c'est la raison pour laquelle cet
article est
superfettatoire et je renvoie simplement
au respect de la loi telle qu'elle est
monsie le gendr merci monsieur le
Président cet article fait partie de la
longue série que nous examinons depuis
lundi et que le ministre de l'Intérieur
avait eu comment dire la sagesse de ne
pas inscrire dans son texte initial en
tant que représentant d'une CIR
inscription riche en établissement
d'enseignement supérieur je pourrais
évoquer ou invoquer le caractère très
illusoire de ces contrôles mais là n'est
pas l'essentielle cette dispositif
relève d'une philosophie qui voudrait
qu'il faille rendre la vie des étrangers
sur notre territoire la plus difficile
le plus d'obstacles poss possible le
plus de contrôle poss possible en un mot
leur rendre la vie la plus difficile
pour diminuer la prétendue attractivité
de notre territoire je ne partage pas
cette philosophie alors j'ai bien
compris que depuis lundi il nous était
proposé d'amender d'atténuer les
dérives de la copie du Sénat nous avons
hier rejeté la question des cautions
c'est une bonne nouvelle peut-être
allons-nous rejeter la question des
augmentations de frais de scolarité ce
serait une bonne nouvelle aussi mais je
vous dirais que le la moitié ou même le
tiers d'une mauvaise idée ne fait pas
une bonne idée ni une idée juste c'est
la raison pour laquelle je vous demande
de supprimer mer l'amendement suivant
n'est pas défendu
le alors madame Dupont le
200250 ça rend difficile la vie des gens
de donner un document par an alors
allez-y avec le micro effectivement dans
la continuité de ce qui vient d'être
indiqué euh il s'agit d'ajouter un
obstacle au parcours des étrangers dans
notre pays et notamment aux étudiants et
euh par la par le le dépôt juste
justement de cette caution Marjoline
minier
euh pardon oui Marjoline pardon
excusez-moi Marjoline mier milfer a donc
proposé cet amendement de suppression et
je souscris tout à fait au propos à
l'instant de de Gill le gendre sur
l'intention générale en définitive
sous-jacente à ces articles successif
qui vise à à renforcer le parcours
d'obstacles des étrangers dans notre
pays d'où cette suppression
je vois pas de défenseur du
1285 euh le 1307 monsieur raau merci
monsieur le Président contrôler chaque
année la carte de séjour pluriannuel des
étudiants est en contradiction avec le
principe d'annualité il s'agit de
garantir une sécurité aux étudiants pour
la durée du cursus suivi cette mesure
introduite au Sénat est inutile la loi
prévoit déjà la possibilité de retirer
la carte de séjour en cas de changement
de statut elle est aussi
contreproductive pour les services
administratif elle engendrerait en effet
une charge de travail immense alors même
que la pluriannualité des titres de
séjour vit justement alléger les
démarches aussi bien pour les
préfectures que pour les demandeurs donc
nous défendons une stabilité une
sécurisation des parcours c'est-à-dire
en octroyant de manière claire et
automatique une carte de séjour il est
donc proposé de supprimer du texte ce
contrôle
annuel monsieur Lucas merci monsieur le
Président défendu dans la mesure où nos
collègues l du et R ont dit l'essentiel
et et Valo pardon on dit l'essentiel et
plus que l'essentiel
d'ailleurs monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci Monsieur le le président
peut-être rappeler à la fois le contexte
et puis ce que propose le le Sénat Boris
Valou l'a dit il y a quelques
instants le le droit existant c'est déjà
la nécessité du caractère réel et
sérieux des études suivies par les
étudiants étr éanger que nous
accueillons donc ça n'est pas là ce que
propose le Sénat c'est c'est c'est c'est
déjà existant en revanche le Sénat
souhaite qu'il y ait une obligation
annuelle de présenter les éléments qui
constituent le caractère réel et sérieux
notamment l'assiduité cela va de soi et
à cette obligation correspondrait par
conséquent une possibilité pour le
représentant de l'État de retirer le cas
échéant le visa étudiant si ce caractère
réel est sérieux et qui aujourd'hui est
défini par circulaire qui demain selon
la proposition du Sénat serait défin par
décet n'était pas avéré donc sur ce
sujet je crois que d'Abir la
position de l'exécutif celle de la
majorité présidentielle elle est très
claire c'est de renforcer la dynamique
d'accueil
d'étranger pour étudier dans dans nos
universités je le rappelle nous l'avons
dit à plusieurs reprises c'est désormais
la le premier motif de migration France
le premier loin devant l'immigration
familiale je rappelle les chiffres
108000 visas étudiants délivrés en 2022
90000 personnes au titre de
l'immigration familiale donc 14000
seulement pour le regroupement familial
et pour ce qui concerne les migration
dite économique 50000 titres délivrés
par la France il me semble que en
contrepartie de la politique
d'hyperattractivité que mène la France
au regard des étudiants étrangers avec
un objectif vous le rappelle à 202 de
500000 titres délivrés 108000
aujourd'hui 500000 en 2027 il me semble
qu'il n'est pas totalement incohérent de
considérer que nous pourons regarder de
façon plus précise peut-être le
caractère réel et sérieux du suivi des
études je rappelle comment ça se passe
aujourd'hui lorsque l'étudiant étranger
se est dans son pays d'origine il doit
apporter tous les éléments qui
démontrent bien sûr qu'il engagera des
études supérieures en France les
critères sont d'ailleurs stricts il doit
posé vous le savez son dossier sur la
plateforme Campus France et en lien avec
les autorités consulaires de notre état
dans les pays étrangers le visa étudiant
lui est ou pas délivré le visa étudiant
lorsqu'il lui est délivré lui est
délivré généralement pour une année
d'autre un cours un cours séjour d'une
année et il y a ensuite un
renouvellement pour la plupart du temps
des cartes de séjour pluréannuel il y a
donc un contrôle très strict à l'entrée
dans le visa très strict il y a un
contrôle très strict au bout d'une année
pour vers la plurannualité il n'y a plus
aucun contrôle au moment où la carte de
séjour pluri annuelle est accordée plus
aucun contrôle un contrôle à l'entrée un
contrôle au bout d'un an plus rien après
nous considérons que nous
pouvons exiger de l'étudiant ce qui par
exemple survient lorsqu'on est boursier
en tant qu'étudiant pardon de de vous le
dire j'ai été
boursier et j'ai dû donc prouver chaque
année pendant toutes mes études aeurs
que je poursuivais bien mes études et
que il y avait de l'assiduité que je me
présentais aux examens je pense que
toutes celles et ceux qui ont été
boursier ont reconnu ont connu cette
situation bon c'est c'est exactement
cette demande là que que que fait le
Sénat moi je la trouve justifiée sur le
fond
attention ça ne sera d'ailleurs pas
comme le font les universités o vous
savez que chaque semestre l'université
transmet au CROUS pour les boursiers
transmet au bourses les les motifs
d'aduté là un décret d'application devra
définir les conditions du caractère réel
et sérieux et les éléments que
l'étudiant devra apporter ce sera la
présentation aux examens ce sera le cas
échéant le le le diplôme acquis au bout
d'une année d'étude ce n'est pas une
condition de réussite je rappelle
d'ailleurs que le code des étrangers
prévoit déjà les conditions pour
d'éventuels redoublant avec évidemment
des facilités de redouvellement du titre
car la question même de la réussite elle
doit se poser de façon égalitaire quel
que soient les étudiants étranger ou pas
étranger donc je vous propose d'aller
sur ce plan dans le sens du Sénat et
donc avis défavorable aux amendement de
suppression alors j'ai madame Diaz oui
oui c'est bon oui oui c'est bon aussi
merci monsieur le Président donc de quoi
parle cet article il demande à ce que il
y ait un contrôle une fois par an du
caractère réel et sérieux des étude
suivie par un étranger bénéficiaire
d'une carte de séjour portant la mention
étudiant donc en quoi ça consiste ça
consiste à vérifier que l'étudiant
dispose bien d'une attestation
d'inscription d'un relevé de note et qui
suit bien ses cours et ça je ne
comprends pas pourquoi vous vous vous le
refuser vous n'ignorez pas que en 2021
plus de 87000 titres de séjour portant
cette mention ont été accordé et qu'il
existe un risque manifeste de
détournement parce que cette filière est
particulièrement attractive et dans
votre amendement vous proposez une
solution irresponsable c'est celle de
régulariser tous les étudiants sans
papiers mais c'est à cause de politique
comme vous voulez mener que nos
restaurants universitaires que nos
logements étudiants sont
particulièrement saturés et donc alors
que vous prétendez alors que vous
prétendez vouloir lutter contre la
précarité étudiante en réalité vous
l'organisez monsieur
Gouffier merci monsieur le Président euh
autant groupe connaissance nous
trouvions injustifié la mise en place
d'un cautionnement ou le rehaussement
des tarifs des frais d'inscription des
études autant nous rejoignons l'avis du
rapporteur
sur le fait que cette demande de
contrôle annuel ne nous paraît pas
anormal qui plusé dans un moment où nous
allons revoir à la hausse nos objectifs
d'accueil d'étudiants étrangers aussi
nous voterons contre cette série
d'amendements de suppression madame
jeun merci monsieur le Président je
souscris tout à fait au propos du
rapporteur général je pense qu'il ne
faut pas supprimer cet amendement il est
utile d'autant que rappelons tout de
même le nombre d'étudiants accueillis
dans notre pays on ne peut pas dire que
la France manque d'attractivité ni même
qu'elle met des freins à l'accueil des
étudiants puisque en 10 an le nombre
d'étudiants dans notre pays a quasiment
doublé cela a été dit je vais quand même
rappeler que le coût moyen d'un étudiant
en France c'est plus de 13000 € et que
les frais d'inscription vous le savez
demeure assez modeste en en année de
licence c'est moins de 200 € par an on
est sur des coûts qui sont quand même
très très raisonnables dès lors que
notre pays consent un effort financier
substantiel en direction des étudiants
et des étudiants étrangers aussi il me
paraît normal que le caractère sérieux
et réel des études qui est d'ailleurs
prévu au 8e alinéa de l'article 400 11 4
du czda puisse être opéré et que si ça
n'est pas le cas le titre de séjour
puisse être
retiré merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur je suis vos
débats de près depuis le début et le en
même temps nous empêche de comprendre
votre position et votre ligne vous dites
il faut que la France soit attractive et
que les étudiants étrangers viennent
faire leurs études en France et vous
dites le contraire 30 secondes après en
disant il faut un flicage un contrôle
intensif c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
moi j'ai enseigné à l'université et on
me demandait de faire des attestations
régulièrement donc aujourd'hui les
étudiants font quand ils viennent en
France c'est pour faire des études pas
pour faire autre chose et sachez que ce
contrôle il est déjà régulier ces
étudiants ils doivent être bien
accueillis en France et pour être bien
accueillis il ne faut pas leur mettre la
suspicion au-dessus de la tête ce ne
sont pas il y a aucun risque migratoire
avec ces étudiants ou au mieux d'avoir
du person extrêmement qualifiés des
doctorants des scientifiques et des
ingénieurs alors ceux- on les garderait
peut-être monsieur
porte merci monsieur le Président
premier amendement de l'après-midi et
première convergence avec la macronie et
la droite sénatorielle puisque vous
émettez un avis défavorable à ces
amendements de suppression et on a déjà
entendu les étudiants sont un flux c'est
une vague qui va arriver incontrôlé tous
les chiffres disent le contraire mon
collègue Lucas l'a rappelé à plusieurs
reprises il rapporte plus que ce qu'il
neous coûte et quand j'entends euh les
députés du rassemblement national
utiliser comme argument qu'il n'y aurait
pas de place dans les crouses ou pas de
place euh notamment dans les logements
euh je vous invite à vous en prendre non
pas euh à ceux qui seraiit sooit disant
responsable mais s'il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui de place dans les logements
étudiants c'est la grande promesse
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 qui avait dit
je construirai 80000 logements pour les
jeunes dont 60000 pour les crouses et
qui n'a pas tenu promesse et je cite
juste Alexis Michel qui est le président
de la Conférence des directeurs des
écoles françaises d'ingénieurs qui dit
au sujet de cette proposition c'est un
nonsens les étudiants sont responsables
et et doivent déjà rendre compte de leur
présence et de et de leur absence
étranger ou non donc encore une fois
vous courez derrière la droite et
l'extrême droite et le premier rement de
cet après-midi démontre vos
convergence merci Monsieur le le
président euh nous serons défavorables à
ces amendements de suppression pour
plusieurs plusieurs raisons euh déjà
parce que on sait que l'assiduité des
étudiants boursiers français aujourd'hui
est et contrôlé d'ailleurs ça a été
rappelé hein par euh par Monsieur le le
rapporteur général et aujourd'hui tous
les jours on impose au français du
contrôle euh sur un certain nombre de
dispositifs c'est quotidien c'est des
fois parfois même de de
l'administrocratie et euh il est
incohérent de se dire et ben on fait ça
dans la vie de de tous les jours de de
nos concitoyens et on ne le fait pas ce
contrôl pour des étudiants euh des
étudiants étrangers dans le 1er a euh
l'article 1er a il y a a eu des demandes
de certains collègues sur des des
précisions sur les étudiants sur leur
durée d'étude et ben avec cet amendement
là ça permettra d'être sûr que les
étudiants qui sont présents sur notre
territoire répondent à toutes les
demandes et le dernier point je pense
qu'il est satisfait par l'article 13 de
ce PGL mais est-ce que en cas de délit
ou d'infraction il il y aurait non
renouvellement monsieur le rapporteur
général euh alors c'est Madame
Rousseau merci monsieur le Président
alors en fait quand les étudiants ont
des difficultés de renouvellement de
leur titre de séjour on demande aux
enseignants on demande aux responsables
de formation d'attester de leur présence
en cours et donc c'est déjà ce que l'on
fait on envoie tout un tas de de de
présence et de d'attestation du fait que
ils ont suivi ou pas les études mais
surtout je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur le fait que ce sont des
étudiants qui subissent beaucoup la
pression de de leur famille quand ils
arrivent en France pour suivre leurs
études et donc ce ne sont pas des des
des étudiants qui sont comme ça dans la
nature c'est au contraire ils ont une
pression familiale extrêmement forte et
par ailleurs il y en a une grande part
qui travaillent durant leurs études
puisque je rappelle que les étudiants
étrangers n'ont pas accès aux bourses
françaises de sorte que ils ont besoin
le plus souvent de travailler et de
travailler un nombre conséquent d'heure
dans la semaine donc en fait mettre
cette pression supplémentaire alors que
par c'est déjà une procédure qui est
prévue par les universités c'est encore
une fois leur mettre une pression
administrative alors que on ne leur
demande qu'une seule chose c'est de
réussir leurs études monsieur balanan
oui déjà je m'excuse d'être arrivé en
retard j'avais noté 15h donc j'ai pas pu
soutenir l'amendement de suppression euh
moi ce qui me ce qui m'embête dans
l'écriture euh pardon euh pardon ce qui
m' ce qui m'embête dans l'écriture et
c'est pour ça qu'on qu'on souhaite sa sa
suppression pour repartir sur quelque
chose de propre c'est c'est que c'est
pas très précis c'est c'est quoi le
caractère réel et sérieux des études
aujourd'hui le caractère réel et sérieux
des études ça peut être effectivement
euh l'assiduité euh euh la présentation
aux examens mais qui sait un jour par
comme c'est fixé en contrôle d'État pas
en Conseil d'État on pourrait avoir un
autre moment un autre temps et on on
sanctionnerait par exemple les élèves
qui auraient des mauvaises notes euh et
et et c'est c'est complètement fou on
peut on peut comprendre qu'une année ça
peut se rater une année une année
scolaire ou universitaire je je c'est
arrivé au meilleur de de les rater donc
moi moi c'est vraiment un sujet qui me
qui m'interpelle qu'on contrôle comme
tous les étudiants français d'ailleurs
les étudiants tous les étudiants
français sont contrôlés si vous venez
pas aux examens si vous vous présentez
pas l'année suivante vous avez parfois
du mal à vous réinscrire dans certains
dans certaines unités de de valeur donc
moi je souhaitais que ça soit supprimé
pour qu'on travaille sur quelque chose
de de plus précis et de plus protecteur
pour les étudiants
étrangers madame fossillon
oui cette la la logique de de suspicion
à l'égard des étudiants étrangers en
réalité elle va pousser à une à une
précarisation de leur situation
supplémentaire ma collègue Rousseau
disait pression cette pression cette
espèce d'p d'amoclasse que vous avez
chaque année et bien elle est une part
de de précarisation supplémentaire pour
des étudiants qui déjà effectivement ont
la pression de la famille pour réussir
ont leur pression à d'eux-mêmees pour
réussir sont obligés de de travailler
pour mener à bien leurs études et tout
ça alors même que il y a un filtrage qui
existe déjà oui il y a des attestations
qui vont être faites donc là en plus
vous vous engorgez encore un peu plus
les démarches administratives en
préfecture qui disons-le n'en ont
vraiment pas besoin actuellement et en
fait forcément en étant dans une forme
de surencherche sur le filtrage ce que
vous allez amener c'est à une sorte
d'extension et bien du de de
l'appréciation du caractère sérieux par
la préfecture la logique que vous mettez
en place c'est le fait que dans les
préfectures vous pousser dans la
pratique à une appréciation plus stricte
du caracctère S Mame pouss
vinbac s président merci monsieur je ne
suis pas Madame pouss vinbac mais je
suis près d'elle merci monsieur le
Président hier nous avons nous avons de
manière très large repoussé la
délivrance du titre de séjour avec le
dépôt d'une caution tout à l'heure n
nous discuterons également je pense que
nous convergerons au
sujet de la l'article suivant sur les
étudiants extra communautaires or là je
vois pas aujourd'hui ce qui vient
justifier les amendements de suppression
que nous sommes en train de débattre on
parle on parle uniquement de s'assurer
du caractère réel et
sérieux on parle uniquement de ça avec
une attestation d'inscription un relevé
de note je pense pas qu'il s'agisse
véritablement de quelque chose de
terrible et je ne pense pas que ça
justifie que nous soyons sur une demande
de suppression donc nous votterons
contre ces amendements de suppression et
bien je les mets au voix qui vote
pour
qui vote contre ils sont
rejetés qui défend le suivant pour les
écologistes le 794 monsieur Lucas j'ai
souvenir monsieur le Président d'un
tweet du président du groupe Renaissance
monsieur Maillard enemprint de sagesse
qui disait choose France choisissez la
France venez ici bon c'était pour les
entrepreneurs mais visiblement ça ne
s'applique pas au aux étudiantes et aux
étudiants simplement madame jeunevard
qui nous dit comme ça avec espèce
d'assurance euh avec ce que nous coûte
les étudiants internationaux même
jeunevard
euh madame jeunevard les étudiants les
dépenses publiques destinées aux
étudiants étrangers c'est 3,7 milliards
d'euros et ce qu'il rapporte c'est 5
milliards soit un bénéfice net pour
notre économie d'1,35 milliards d'euros
euh voilà donc c'est bien de de dire des
choses pour faire peur et les étudiants
font les frais là on voit bien avec
l'avis du du rapporteur une espèce de
négociation mortifère entre la droite
radicalisée et le rapporteur général
malgré les arguments de bon sens et de
sagesse de nos collègues issus de la
majorité je termine en disant que si on
appliquait les mêmes conditions
d'assiduité et de réussite aux députés
LR dans les séances plères de
l'Assemblée nationale on aurait sans
doute là aussi beaucoup de choses à dire
le 795 c'est vous aussi monur défendu
défendu
le suivant c'est le 1581 qui le
défendsur
1581 défendu défendu et le le 1308
attendez 1308 monsieur RA merci monsieur
le Président que signifie donc faire des
étude réell et sérieus à moins de voir
le mal partout chers collègues il faut
qu'on s'entende 2 minutes un étudiant
étranger ou une étudiante étrangère qui
vient en France pour ses études ne vient
pour aucune autre raison que pour faire
des études sérieuses et réelles certains
le font pour avoir un avenir qu'il
n'auraiit pas dans leur pays d'autres
parce qu'il saluent la qualité de notre
enseignement bref dans tous les cas ils
vous diront qu'il ou elle n'ont pas
d'autre choix que de réussir leurs
études dans la circulaire de 2008 qui
définit les critères de ce qu'est un
caractère réel et sérieux l'on trouve
par exemple la progression des études ou
la présence aux examens c'est d'une
certaine manière discriminatoire doit-on
juger plus grave qu'un étudiant étranger
redouble que lorsqu'il s'agit d'un
étudiant français vous l'avez expliqué
vous-même monsieur le rapporteur il y a
un instant ce serait une erreur réelle
et
sérieuse monsieur le rapporteur votre
avis sur les quatre amendements oui
merci monsieur le Président j'ai du mal
à comprendre les arguments d'un certain
nombre de nos collègues qui d'un côté
dis ça existe déjà on le fait déjà
chaque année donc ce serait pire de le
mettre dans la loi j'ai du mal à
comprendre alors je vais essayer de je
vais essayer non mais très sincèrement
il y a une contradiction alors je vais
essayer je vais essayer précisément
monsieur Boris Vallo a parfaitement
raison il y a déjà dans la loi la
nécessité d'un caractère réel et sérieux
ce qui n'existe pas dans la loi c'est
l'obligation du contrôle annulel voilà
ce qui n'existe pas Madame kou tout à
l'heure indiquit on le fait déjà les
universités et cetera oui c'est vrai à
l'issue de la première année et une fois
que là si et une fois que la carte de
séjour pluierie annuelle est accordée il
n'y a plus aucun contrôle donc s'il y a
l'absence totale de contrôle sur 3 3 4 5
années nous pensons que ça n'est pas une
question dans même temps c'est que si
nous voulons continuer cette dynamique
d'attractivité très forte sur les titres
de séjour étrangers et il est normal
d'avoir la contrepartie de contrôle plus
V ilant donc c'est une obligation c'est
une obligation et donc je répète je
répète parce que je je trouve cet
argument est sensé
lorsque un enfant de la République
lorsqu'un enfant de la République
bénéficie des bourses d'études il doit
chaque année attester de son assiduité
chaque année et tout le monde trouve ça
tout à fait normal et lorsque la France
donne un titre de séjour pour étudier
dans son pays il n'est pas du tout
anormal un quelle contrôle à l'arrivée
elle le fait qu'elle contrôle au bout
d'un an elle le fait et qu'elle contrôle
ensuite chaque année est-ce que c'est
une épée de damoclass que de demander à
l'étudiant de juste transmettre les
éléments qui attestent qu'il a travaillé
dans l'année pas qu'il a réussi pas
qu'il a forcément eu son diplôme on n
pas imposer un étudiant étranger qu'il
réussisse mieux qu'un ressortissant
nationalité française évidemment que ça
n'est pas l'objectif et je l'ai déjà dit
dans le code des étrangers la question
même du redoublement est prévu avec une
appréciation très large et ensuite pour
celles et ceux qui disent mais c'est
quoi le caractère Ré et sérieux je me
permets de répondre par conséquent à à
mon cher collègue Balanant sur le
caractère réel et sérieux c'est déjà
défini c'est déjà défin c'est la
circulaire de 2008 qui a été signée par
le ministre de l'Intérieur et à l'époque
le ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur
et donc qui décline mon cher heran
Balanant à la fois l'assiduité et la
présentation aux examens c'est la
première catégorie le contrôle de la
progression des études suivies dans un
même cursus donc c'est ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui sans caractère obligatoire
sur la la partie plurannuelle du titre
de séjour c'est aussi le contrôle le
changement d'orientation après
l'obtention d'un diplôme par s'il y a
une cohérence ça paraît tout à fait
logique le changement éventuel
d'orientation à la suite d'un échec dans
son parcours pour voir là aussi s'il y a
une cohérence dans le parcours de
l'étudiant enfin rien d'anormal et ce
qui est proposé par le Sénat c'est
l'obligation y compris pendant la
période où l'étranger bénéficiit d'une
carte de séjour pluriannuel ça me paraît
tout à fait normal et c'est de faire en
sorte que cette définition qui existe
déjà du caractère réel et sérieux ne
soit pas intégré dans une circulaire
mais dans un décret en Conseil d'État
voilà la réalité de la proposition du
Sénat moi je ne fais pas partie de ceux
qui considèrent que parce que c'est
sénatorial c'est pas bien moi je
considère que quand c'est sénatorial je
suis vigilant quand c'est sénatorial je
fais attention quand c'est sénatorial
j'analyse mais je dis pas forcément
table rase quel est l'intérêt sur cette
disposition qui paraît pour le coup de
bon
sens monsieur Lucas
merci Monsieur monsieur le le président
encore une fois moi je quel va être
l'effet dans le monde de la perception
que des millions de gens vont avoir de
nos débats c'est que la France est dans
un rabougrissement dans un repli c'est
que la France ne s'aime pas elle-même
puisqu'elle a elle a peur finalement de
de s'ouvrir et d'attirer des étudiants
internationaux c'est d'une ringardise et
d'une frilosité incroyable mais en fait
vous n'aimez pas la France vous n'aimez
pas la France pour ne pour à ce point
vouloir qu'elle n'accueille pas il se
passe actuellement dans plein
d'universités dans le monde des
campagnes de recrutement d'étudiants
internationaux extrêmement offensiv nous
perdons et nous allons perdre du terrain
avec ce genre de de débat et de
politique que vous voulez conduire qui
envoie finalement un message de
fermeture aux étudiants étrangers et
internationaux je le redis et je le
redirai encore les étudiants
internationaux ils repartent pour
l'essentiel dans leur pays d'origine ils
rapportent de l'argent dans dé plaise à
Madame jeunevard ils réussissent leurs
études et Madame rousse l'a dit
notamment parce qu'ils ont une pression
familiale plus forte et ils font
rayonner notre pays monsieur
Plerin on est d'accord oui alors mon
cher collègue je ne crois pas qu'on
ferme les portes aux étudiants
étrangers non non maisz moi j'ai été
étudiant j'étais étudié en doctorat et
normalement on fait 3 années pour avoir
un doctorat et pour avoir pour
bénéficier d'une dérogation j'en ai eu
j'en ai eu je crois se en fait il faut
justifier d'un travail sérieux voilà
c'est c'est c'est parfaitement normal je
pense que c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt une preuve de
sérieux c'est
tout monsieur Solignac
oui ça m'a pas ça m'a permis de l'avoir
quand même he les
gars monsieur balanan
oui juste
juste répondre à à Monsieur Lucas qui
qui faudrait qu'il arrête un petit peu
les les Ultra caricatures parce que je
pense que ça nuit à la qualité des
débats que nous avons
collectivement mais je je fais pas de
leçon monsieur monsieur Lucas vous vous
en faites depuis ce matin à tout le
monde et pourtant je partage une des une
partie des bon on peut parler du fond
s'il vous plaît on peut parler du fond
monsieur Lucas vous vous parlez de
France qui se rabougri et qui
n'accepterait pas les étudiants jamais
dans un mandat dans un quinquena comme
celui du précédent il y a eu autant
d'augmentation du nombre
d'étrangers étudiants les étudiants
étrangers ont été ont été accueillis on
leur a même donné des capacités
nouvelles pour étudier dans notre pays
donc moi je veux bien qu'on je veux bien
être en opposition sur le texte j'ai des
oppositions avec le texte du Sénat mais
arrêtons d'être dans la caricature tout
le temps ça nuit au débat et ça nuit à
la qualité du sujet que nous devons
traiter de pendant encore 3 semaines
monsieur
Boua merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
moi je suis stupéfait par les par les
les arguments avancés par Monsieur Lucas
depuis depuis lundi ceux qui ne sont pas
d'AC d'accord avec lui n'imerait pas la
France mais au contraire moi j'ai envie
de vous dire qu'un pays qui se fait
respecter un pays qui fait respecter les
études qui sont prodiguées sur son sol
est un pays un pays qui saime je prends
l'exemple combien d'étudiants français
veulent tous les ans aller au Canada
c'est extraordinairement compliqué quand
on est français d'aller étudier au
Canada et parce que c'est compliqué il y
a de plus en plus d'étudiants qui envie
d'y aller parce que ce qui est compliqué
a parfois un peu plus de valeur que ce
qui est simple que ce qui n'a pas de
prix et cette société où rien ne
coûterait rien où tout serait toujours
ouvert que vous proposez monsieur Lucas
au contraire je crois que c'est vous je
crois que c'est vous qui avez un
problème de rapport avec notre pays en
tout cas vot le son de morale permanente
depuis l'undi commence à être je crois
assez fatigante pour l'ensemble de cette
commission de cette commission vous avez
le droit d'être en désaccord moi je suis
parfaitement en désaccord avec ce que
vous proposez depuis le début ça ne
m'empêche pas de respecter ce que vous
dites et je crois que vos sons de moral
sont vraiment fatigantes pour tout le
monde alors Monsieur gilet monsieur
Solignac je vous donnerai la parole
après mais je vous ai appelé tout à
l'heure vous AZ pas pris la parole oui
monsieur gilet après monsieur sol oui
monsiesieur le président très très
rapidement et et très calmement mais
pourquoi la gauche sénerve-t-elle ainsi
et pourquoi est-elle autant dans la
caricature que la France soit attractive
pour les étudiants mais finalement on
s'en félicite tous tant mieux d'ailleurs
elle serait peut-être encore plus
efficace enfin plus attractive en
luttant contre la fraude parce que en
réalité ce qu'il y a là c'est que on
veut lutter contre la fraude éventuelle
c'est tout point barre alors pourquoi la
gauche veut-elle lutter contre la lutte
contre la fraude moi je le comprends pas
c'est du bon sens alors certains veulent
peut-être l'anarchie nous on veut du
contrôle et est-ce qu'il y a des abus
oui il y en a est-ce qu'il y en a
énormément il y en a peut-être pas
énormément mais il y en a et dès
l'instant où il y a de la fraude il doit
y avoir et bien du contrôle il faut
lutter contre la fraude et ensuite vous
vous disiez qu'on était incapable de
citer un seul exemple finalement de de
de fraude suite à un titre de séjour
étudiant moi je vais vous en citer un
qui prouve bien qu'il y en a un cas très
connu d'abiabé inculpé d'avoir tué l'Ola
arrivé en France en 2016 avec un visa
étudiant avant de glisser dans
l'illégalité et de faire l'objet
d'uneqtf monsieur
Solignac merci monsieur le Président bon
personne est DUP c'est c'est d'abord le
texte du Sénat qu'on examine ici et et
j'ai la faiblesse de penser que si cette
disposition ne figurait pas dans le
texte initial c'est parce qu'en fait
vous ne la partagiez pas je pense que
vous ne la partagez toujours pas mais
pour les raisons qu'on comprend vous
êtes obligé de de la conserver moi je
suis assez étonné de voir à quel point
euh vous êtes une machine à fabriquer de
la bureaucratie et d'ailleurs je
m'étonne de constater que ni les
républicains ni le rassemblement
national ne s'aperçoit de cela avec
cette disposition vous allez créer du
recours du contentieux de l'embolie dans
les préfectures et moi je voudrais
savoir avec quel moyen vous allez
procéder à ce type de contrôle voilà
vous êtes vous êtes en fait en
perpétuelle contradiction vous êtes en
en grand écart permanent monsieur le
rapporteur général j'ai la faiblesse de
penser ça nengage que moi que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec cette
disposition là mais comme vous êtes un
bon débatteur vous allez quand même la
défendre je mets au voix l'amendement
794 qui vote pour ça qui vote contre
rejeté le 795
pour contre rejeté le 1500 181
pour
contre rejeté et le dernier le 138
pour contre rejeté également le 117
monsieur Pouget oui merci Président je
vais faire le 117 et le 171 en même
temps pour revenir sur le débat je ne
comprends pas pourquoi la gauche est
toujours méfiante envers des contrôles
ou envers le fait de de faire de faire
faire attention à ce que à ce qui se
passe est-ce que vous vous posez la
question lorsqu'un étudiant français va
à l'étranger et bénéficie d'un accueil
ou bénéficier d' d'un dispositif il est
contrôlé c'est normal et c'est normal
qu'on contrôle la véracité de son cursus
et bien il n'y a rien d'anormal à ce que
l'on fasse pareil dans notre pays ça me
semble ça me semble du du du bon sens
d'autant plus qu'on sait très bien et
vous l'avez rappelé mon rapporteur que
la les titres de séjour pour étudiants
sont le le stock le plus important et
même si c'est pas la la majorité il y a
un certain nombre de cas de fraude et on
sait que certains utilisent ces moyens
pour rester sur le sur le territoire
donc il est normal qu'on se donte des
outils pour empêcher et pour lutter
contre cette fraude moi je vous propose
deux amendements qui sont des
amendements de date de limité à l'âge de
30 ans et de 35 ans pour s'assurer que à
partir d'un certain âge euh euh si on
est plus dans un cursus d'études on
puisse retirer ces cartes ces cartes de
séjour un petit exemple moi j'ai un de
mes FS qui a qui a bénéficié d'un
programme Erasmus dans des pays
européens mais dans le casre d'un
dispositif Erasmus tous les 3 mois vous
êtes contrôlé parce qu'il y a des fonds
européens vous êtes accueillis dans
différents pays et c'est tout à fait
normal et et et on on le vit pas comme
une brimade de devoir justifier que le
cursus se déroule
merci alors monsieur le rapporteur ces
deux amendements oui je je je suis
défavorable parce que dans dans des cas
par exemple de
reconversion ou ou de de de formation
complémentaire à sa formation initiale
de la part d'un ressortissant qui serait
dans son pays d'origine ou encore dans
le cas de la poursuite d'études très
longues je pense en particulier à des
chercheurs doctorants et qui peuvent
dépasser l'âge de 30 ans je je je je
crois connaître des amis personnels qui
sont allés au-delà des 30 ans
pour pour présenter leur thè de de de
droit public par exemple non je je crois
que c'est pas une bonne solution il me
semble que la question c'est
la barrière à l'âge avancé c'est plutôt
le meilleur contrôle systématique annuel
et cette obligation qui nous est proposé
par le Sénat me semble déjà complètement
correspondre à la cible donc défavorable
pour cette raison aux deux amendements
monsieur po monsieur Lucas merci
monsieur le Président c'est savoureux
d'entendre à l'air qui du sur le plan
économique nous dit toujours il faut
libérer les énergies il y a trop de
contraintes et trop de contrôle qui
pèseent sur le monde de l'entreprise et
d'ailleurs tous les toutes les offrandes
fiscales qui sont faites ne doivent
souffrir d'aucune contrepartie d'aucune
forme de contrôle et là et là on nous
explique qu'il faut une espèce de de de
palion de de pulsion compulsive pour le
contrôle et la traque des étudiants
étrangers je trouve qu'il y a là une
contradiction assez savoureuse et je ne
m'étendrait pas sur les les leçons de
rapport à la fraude de la part de ceux
qui ont soutenu François Fillon dans sa
campagne
présidentielle monsieur balanon oui
juste pour dire ça ça ça marche pas ce
cet amendement euh et le le rapporteur
l'a dit nous nous avons un un chercheur
qui a commencé ses études dans un pays
étranger et qui vient finaliser dans le
cadre d'un accord et d'un programme de
recherche dont on dont on serait fier il
vient finir son doctorat en France il va
vraisemblablement dépasser les 30 ans
donc ça voudrait dire que pour le plus
haut des chercheurs ceux qui vont
devenir docteurs ceux qui vont
participer à la création de savoir et de
connaissance dans nos universités on
pourrait pas les les recevoir parce
qu'ils auraient dépassé 30 ans j'ai
toujours j'ai jamais compris la limite
d'âge pour les écoles il y a des
reconversions il y a parfois des
parcours de vie on a parfois envie de
changer peut-être que certains d'entre
nous en finissant notre mandat on aura
envie de reprendre des études reprendre
un doctorat et donc je suis défavorable
et c'est parfois nécessaire pour qu'on
se remette à niveau c'est et donc en
mathématique moi par exemple oui
j'aurais besoin de remise à niveau donc
des à C nous voterons contre pardon
j'espère que vous serez moins bruillant
dans les amphithéâtres le 117 qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejeté le 171 pour
contre
rejeté le 445 qui le défend au groupe
rassemblement national oui c'est moi
monsieur le Président merci l'amendement
de ma collègue Martinez consiste à
considérer que deux redoublements par
cycle d'études remettent en fait en
cause le caractère sérieux des études
pour un étranger un cycle d'études c'est
pour une licence 3 ans un Master 2 ans
on peut comprendre qu'on rate une année
mais l'objectif c'est quand même
d'assister au cours et d'en tirer des
connaissances qui sont sanctionnés par
des diplômes l'objectif de cet
amendement c'est évidemment d'éviter des
abus et des personnes qui ne suivent pas
euh réellement les cours personnellement
j'ai été étudiant à l'étranger quand on
bénéficie de subvention publi pour aller
étudier à l'étranger on est quand même
relativement contrôlé de la même façon à
l'université j'ai pu côtoyer un certain
nombre d'étudiants étrangers dont un
certain nombre faisaient leurs études
qu'on voyait quotidiennement et puis il
y en avait aussi un certain nombre qui
n'assistaiit jamais au cours il y a donc
des abus dans ce
domaine monsieur le rapporteur
oui la la la réalité c'est que ces
éléments sont déjà regardés la
circulaire de 2008 dont je parlais il y
a quelques instants et qui définit déjà
le caractère réel et sérieux du suivi
des études permet le redoublement parce
que chacun a le droit à l'échec c'est
une évidence donc la circulaire est très
précise sur ces éléments je je ne vois
pas ce qu'ajouterait euh votre votre
dispositif qui plus est dans la loi très
restrictif et qui ne tiendrait pas
compte d'un certain nombre de parcours
de vie donc
défavoraable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour contre rejeté le 608 monsieur
Castellani
oui merci monsieur le Président on sait
que le le code prévoit que soit contrôlé
le caractère réel et sérieux de
l'étudiant apprécié au regard des
éléments des éléments produits par les
les établissements de formation alors
notre amendement précise simplement ces
éléments
d'appréciation que que sont en les
citant que sont l'assiduité et la
présentation aux examens ce qui est
quand même la base minimale pour un
étudiant donc c'est c'est un amendement
qui n'est pas une révolution en soi
Monsieur le Rapporteur
oui je je je réfléchis au regard des
propos tenus tout à l'heure par notre
collègue heran balanon sur la nécessité
peut-être de de mieux préciser mieux
définir y compris peut-être dans la loi
le caractère réel sérieux je trouve que
ce que vous proposez plutôt plutôt
intéressant faut-il peut-être y
retravailler d'ailleurs pour la séance
mais un favorable pour l'instant et je
vous encourage à ce qu'on puisse y
retravailler pour la séance mais le
prendre tout de suite se permettrait de
régler les questions posées notamment
par Monsieur balanan monsieur
valallot si on pouvait éviter comme
législateur les lois
bavardes ce serait quand même assez
utile d'autant que chaque établissement
à ses propres règles d'asséuté a circul
entre les travaux dirigés et les cours
d'amphithéâtre j'aimerais bien savoir si
nous sommes tous allés avec adité au
cours d'enfi qui n'était pas obligatoire
moi oui madame Rousseau
moi merci monsieur le Président donc en
fait cet amendement vise à supprimer les
alinéas 5 à 8 et on est toujours dans le
même débat dans cette commission
c'est-à-dire
l'idée c'est c'est la je viens d'aller
voter en séance et donc VO
bien donc je mets au voit l'amendement
de Monsieur Castellani qui vote
pour
contre il est
adopté le 1309 là vous pouvez y aller
Mame alors qu'est-ce qu' le défend le
1309 alors mon dossier n'est pas dans
l'ordre donc c'est le 176 effectivement
ah ben
voilà nous som pour une fois en phase
bon alors donc cette cet amendement vise
à supprimer les alinéas 5 à 8 et euh le
l'objet en fait de ces alinéas c'est
toujours la même chose c'est-à-dire
c'est de qu'il y ait une espèce de
soupçon universel sur tous les étudiants
étrangers qui consiste à penser qu'ils
sont là pour profiter et pour frauder
qu'en fait ils sont pas vraiment là pour
les études qu'ils sont là pour faire
tout à fait autre chose et euh et en
fait je enfin la réalité des étudiants
étrangers dans les universités
françaises c'est plus qu'ils sont perdus
au milieu de cursus qui sont des fois
compliqués pour les étudiants français
déjà mais alors pour les étudiants qui
viennent de l'étranger et qui
connaissent pas forcément notre système
universitaire c'est encore pire et en
fait là à force de contrôle à force de
les obliger à ne à réussir immédiatement
à force de ne pas leur donner les
conditions économiques et de logement
pour qu'ils réussissent et bien ce qu'on
fait c'est que on les met dans un éto
qui à la fin je vous le dit et et et non
seulement inhumain mais affecte leur
santé et ça on l'a vu de mille et une
manière tous ceux qui qui fréquentent
les universités ont V ont vu de mil et
une manière des étudiants déclinés dans
leur santé mentale et physique parce
qu'ils n'arrivaient plus à faire face à
toutes les
contraintes alors pardon monsieur
rapporteur j'ai Monsieur R qui a un
amendement
identique merci monsieur le Président je
je je rejoins les propos de ma collègue
Sandrine rousseon on est loin ici d'une
amélioration de l'intégration comme le
prône le le titre de ce projet de loi
tout au contraire cet article prend le
chemin de l'insécurité constante en
ouvrant le retrait de la carte de séjour
étudiante pour non respect du caractère
réel et sérieux des études une notion
floue qui peut conduire à des
évaluations arbitraires alors que nous
parlons de personnes humaines de leur
statut qui fait qu'elles sont autorisées
à poursuivre leur vie ou bien qu' les
conduit à être expulsé cette disposition
est superflue parce qu'il existe déjà la
possibilité du retrait si l'étudiant ne
remplit plus les conditions d'obtention
de la carte chaque étudiante chaque
étudiante devrait avoir le droit à une
carte de séjour de plein droit lors de
son cursus de formation
pour ne pas être constamment dans une
incertitude sur sa situation et pouvoir
pleinement se consacrer à ses études
sans le fameux soupçon soupçon
universels quiévoqué madame roussou à
l'instant monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable alors madame
châelin merci Monsieur le le Président
mes collègues ont depuis le début de de
ce débat rappelé l'impact que ce type de
mesure avait sur les étudiants moi je
vais vous dire qu'à force de soupçon
vous êtes vous êtes en train de créer un
système cavcayen qui ça a été dit va
mettre ses étudiants dans une précarité
juridique et émotionnelle extrêmement
forte qui va impacter leurs études mais
aussi qui va aller étudier ces rapports
dans un dans un moment où on a plus de
fonctionnaires ou très peu de
fonctionnaires quelle charge de travail
vous allez remettre sur eux encore et de
nouveau non mais si c'est ça parce qu'en
fait à force de vous avez du soupçon du
soupçon donc il faut du contrôle du
contrôle qui contrôle quel impact ça sur
les personnes qui contrôlent de devoir
const àer vérifier et aller prouver que
l'étude est réelle en fait vous c'est un
système qui est maltraitant pour tout le
monde que vous en train de dessiner avec
cet articre comme les autres mais mais
vraiment je pense que vous ne vous
rendez pas compte de l'insécurité que
vous faites porter et sur les personnes
étrangère mais aussi sur l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires qui sont amenés à être
finalement à fliquer les gens alors que
ce n'est pas ça raisons pour lesquelle
ils font se métier oui merci monsieur le
Président juste si on peut éviter de de
caricaturer ce qui est demandé c'est pas
euh inhumain on a euh la France s'en
orgueilli d'accueillir plus de 100000
étudiants étrangers par an euh ce que
demande euh ce que propose cette cet
article c'est de faire en sorte que il
puisse délivrer par euh un relevé
d'inscription par un relevé de note par
une attestation d'inscription de du
caractère sérieux de la étude c'est pas
inhumain que demander ça c'est demander
à tous les étudiants boursiers par
exemple comme l'a Rapp rappelé le le
rapporteur général on peut juste éviter
de caricaturer ce serait utile au débat
je pense bien je mets donc au voix les
amendements identiques qui vote
pour contre rejeté le suivant madame
borde
oui merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à rendre systématique le
retrait du titre de séjour des étudiants
qui ne justifient pas du caractère réel
et sérieux de leurs études alors je ne
me place pas sur le terrain de savoir
s'il est utile pour la France ou pas
d'avoir des étudiants étranger je pense
que la question ne se pose pas c'est
utile effectivement pour la France
d'avoir des étudiants étrangers c'est
utile pour les étudiants français
d'aller étudier à l'étranger par contre
je me place sur le terrain de l'équité
et uniquement de l'équité entre les
étudiants étrangers et les étudiants
français comme cela a été dit par
monsieur le rapporteur me semble-t-il
lorsque un étudiant français ne justifie
pas du caractère réel et sérieux de ses
études et bien s'il est boursier il P
hipso facto la bourse qui lui est
dévolue à Ch pour lui également de
rembourser une partie pourquoi pourquoi
les étudiants étrangers qui ne
justifieraient pas du caractère réel et
sérieux de leurs études seraiit mieux
traité que les étudiants français il
faut rendre effectivement ce retrait
totalement automatique sous peine de
créer deux régimes sur notre territoire
madame
Chatelin merci monsieur le Président je
crois
qu'on on arrive au cœur du débat on a
deux modèles de société qui qui
s'affrontent on a d'un côté tous ceux
qui veulent continuer à contrôler
effectivement on le voit c'està dire
vous voulez cont contrôler les étudiants
boursiers français au cas où que ça soit
des fraudeurs il faut contrôler les
étudiants étrangers au cas où que
finalement ils ne fassent rien vous êtes
dans une société du contrôle et du
soupçon nous à l'inverse nous pensons
effectivement que pour les connaître que
les étudiants boursiers travaillent et
travaillent énormément et d'ailleurs
généralement ils travaillent dans leurs
études et ils ont un boulot à côté et
nous décidions de leur faire confiance
parce qu'on pense que c'est la confiance
c'est la sécurité qu'on peut amener aux
personnes qui leur permettra ensuite de
construire leur vie notamment au plus
jeunes et donc le choix il est très
simple aujourd'hui c'est soit vous
voulez du flicage et du contrôle soit
vous voulez de la confiance et de
l'émancipation pour nous le choix est
clair c'est confiance et émancipation
monsieur rapporteur j'ai vous demander
votre avis oui mais ça me permettra
défavorable mais ça me permettra de
répondre à la présidente Chatelin qui
n'était pas là au début de nos échanges
et j'aimerais juste lui rappeler un que
le caractère réel et sérieux des études
est déjà dans la loi ça ce n'est pas une
innovation du Sénat de que le Sénat
introduit une obligation et je vous
expliqué à quel moment je rappelle ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure madame
Chatelin lorsqu'un étudiant est à
l'étranger et veut venir en France pour
étudier il doit prouver par tous les
moyens et c'est même extrêmement
exigeant c'est la plateforme confus
France en particulier qu'il va bien
étudier en France on lui donne un titre
de séjour d'une année au bout d'une
année on le contrôle de façon très
vigilante on lui accorde généralement
une carte de sgion plus annuel de 3 4 à
5 ans en fonction de la durée probable
de ces études et à ce moment-là il n'y a
plus de contrôle aucun contrôle et nous
estimons que la contrepartie de la
dynamique d'attractivité très forte que
nous assumons sur les visas étudiantsit
de doit faire en sorte que ce contrôle
puisse se faire annuellement il devra
simplement prouver son assiduité et
notamment la présentation des examens et
ça conforte d'ailleurs l'amendement que
j'ai adopté que j'ai auquel j'ai été
favorable pardon de Monsieur castilani
il y a quelques instants donc pas de
grands mot s'il vous plaît madame la
Présidente je pense que c'est inutile
vous allez très loin dans votre analyse
monsieur
gilet oui Mons monsieur le
Président la confiance n'exclut pas le
contrôle une collègue qui qui disait il
faut il faut avoir confiance maisf un
moment donné ça r à rien quoi dans ce
CASL dans ce cas-là on déclare
l'anarchie aussi donc voilà encore une
fois encore une fois est-ce qu'il y a
est-ce qu'il y a des fraudes oui il y en
a est-ce que une majorité d'étudiants
étrangers qui viennent en France
comporte bien et respecte les règles oui
évidemment mais encore heureux
d'ailleurs mais encore une fois je vous
ai pris un exemple tout à l'heure de la
fameuse dabiaab qui qui est inculpé pour
avoir tué la petite Lola qui est arrivé
sur le sol français en faisant
soi-disant un cap restauration la
réalité c'est quoi c'est qu'elle a fait
tout sauf un cap restauration et puis en
en parlant je cherchais sur des groupes
sur les réseaux sociaux je vois des
groupes d'échange entre étudiants
étrangers qui se donnent des combines
pour pouvoir mieux frauder parce que la
réalité il faut l'expliquer c'est qu'on
a des des des étudiants qui viennent
vraiment faire des études et puis on a
ceux qui viennent qui déclarent faire
des études et qui en réalité se servent
de ce titre de séjour pour être
illégalement sur le territoire national
c'est ça la ré vot sur cet amendement
447 qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejeté le suivant
qui le
défend allez-y merci monsieur le
Président la France a une tradition qui
consiste à former des étudiants en
provenance d'autres nations afin de
transmettre un savoir et des
connaissances à de jeunes étrangers qui
pourront les utiliser à leur retour dans
leur pays d'origine nous sommes prêts à
transmettre ce savoir universitaire mais
en échange ces personnes ont une
obligation morale celle de respecter nos
lois nous pouvons accepter des étudiants
étrangers mais nous ne pouvons pas
accepter des délinquants étrangers c'est
pour cela que cet amendement propose que
la carte de séjour pluriannuelle portant
la mention étudiants soit retiré à ceux
d'entre eux qui ne respecteraient pas
nos lois et qui feraient l'objet à ce
titre d'une condam tion définitive pour
un crime ou un délit puni d'au moins 2
ans d'emprisonnement je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur il va de soi que
c'est déjà le cas madame la députée et
avec l'article 9 d'ailleurs nous
renforcerons cette possibilité
défavorable monsieur Lucas si monsieur
le Président je vous trouve extrêmement
laxiste chers collègues du rassemblement
national à la limite de l'angélisme vous
nous présentez le fait de respecter de
devoir respecter les lois comme une
contrepartie au fait de pouvoir venir
étudier en France mais sur le territoire
de la République tout le monde doit
respecter la loi et le respect de la loi
n'est pas conditionné à un quelconque
contrat ou engagement tout le monde doit
respecter la loi c'estàd pour ça que
nous faisons ici la loi et que nous
décidons d' un certain nombre de
sanctions qui sont prévues pour son
irrespect encore une fois je trouve ce
discours de stigmatisation des étudiants
étranger particulièrement choquant je
vous le dis notamment quand on sait
encore une fois regarde tout ce qui a
été dit qu'il réussissent plus qu'il
travaille un étudiant étranger sur deux
déclare avoir travaillé pendant ses
études que ce sont souvent euh des des
gens qui sont poussés par leur famille
tout le monde ne peut pas étudier à
l'étranger et vous là vous faites espèce
de grand charabia de stigmatisation qui
franchement vire à la à la au choses les
plus farfelues qu'on peut entendre je
mets au voix qui vote pour qui vote
contre
rejeté le suivant le
460 Monsieur B merci monsieur le
Président c'est l'amendement de de mon
collègue Guignot qui vise en fait à
retirer les cartes de séjour plurn
portant la mention étudiant pour les les
étrangers qui font l'objet d'une
exclusion de l'établissement public
d'enseignement supérieur ça semble tout
à fait logique ces personnes sont venu
étudier mais les conditions si elles ne
sont plus elles ne sont plus respectées
si elles ne sont plus d'actualité
doivent être vu et c'est pour ça que il
leur faut il faut retirer ces cartes de
ces jours monsieur le rapporteur
satisfait défavorable Mad
fon
merci Monsieur le le président
simplement puisqu'il y en a beaucoup qui
font des parallèles avec les élèves
boursiers et ce qu'ils doivent
transmettre ce qui se passe pour les
élèves boursiers c'est que les c'est les
formations elles-mêmes qui transmettent
les documents à l'intérieur même de
l'Université pour pouvoir juger de la
présence et du caractère assidu on va
dire de la formation et donc on est
c'est dans la même institution que ce
fait que se fait ce ce jugement cette
appréciation on n'est pas du tout sur la
même chose là qui qui transmet c'est
l'université ou l'étudiant qui transmet
à une préfecture qui elle qui n'a pas de
fonction c'est pas l'inspection
académique quoi la préfecture qui est
sensé juger et apprécier du caractère
sérieux d'un étudiant vous voyez bien
que le parallèle est quand même à mon
avis très
bancal je mets au voix qui vote
pour contre rejeté je mets au voix
l'article 1er G qui vote
pour qui votes contre et
adopté l'amendement suivant le monsieur
le rapporteur oui je je serai bref il
s'agit de la disposition introduite par
le Sénat consistant à majorer les droits
universitaires pour les visas pour les
étudiants
étranger nous estimons j'estime que
cette mesure est tout à fait contraire à
l'objectif qui le note de de forte
dynamique sur ce point mais je ne serai
pas plus long pour laisser les autres
orateurs sur les amendements de
suppression exprimer leur point de vue
j'ai un amendement de suppression de
cette majoration des droits étudiants
pour les étudiants étrangers également
que je défends monsieur valallot le
865 oui défendu madame fusillon le 1154
défendu monsieur balanan le 1286 oui
défendu également monsieur RA le
13112 allez-y Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président le mardi 7 novembre la droite
fait adopter un amendement pour inscrire
dans la loi la majoration des frais
d'inscription universitaire pour les
étrangers extracommunautaires tel que
défin par le bien mal nommé plan
bienvenue en France cela ne faisait
jusqu'alors que l'objet d'un décret en
faisant dans cela le Sénat souhaite
contraindre les universités appliquer
cette mesure à laquelle nombre d'entre
elles continuent de résister qui
contrevient au principe d'autonomie des
universités rappelons qu'aujourd'hui 30
universités n'appliquent pas le principe
des frais d'inscription différenciés 18
ne les appliquent que partiellement le
groupe écologiste demande la suppression
de cette disposition éique nous
rappelons aussi notre opposition au plan
bienvenu en France qui a d'ailleurs
provoqué une chute de l'influence de la
France nous avons reculé au 6e rang des
pays d'accueil alors qu'en 2018 nous
étions au 3e
rang monsieur Lucas le 1461 merci
Monsieur le le Président voà c'est c'est
un article qui va à l'encontre des
objectifs d'attractivité étudiantes qui
ont été évoqué par les uns et par les
autres et mon collègue Jean-Claude dit
c'est aussi par ailleurs euh une
atteinte portée à l'autonomie des
universités et à leur bon fonctionnement
euh dans ce qu'elles appliquent ou
n'appliquent pas donc vous rajoutez là
une étape bureaucratique qui n'est pas
propre à libérer les énergies et à dire
aux étudiantes et aux étudiants
bienvenue en France encore une fois il
faudra mettre en adéquation vos slogans
et vos pratiques ici à toutes et à
tous monsieur Gouffier Valante le 1547
défendu madame Martin le 569 madame
torignia merci Monsieur le le président
bon je vais aller dans le même sens
évidemment que mes collègues pour cet
amendement de
suppression une suppression parce que on
est en France le pays des des droits de
l'homme le pays de liberté égalité
fraternité et l'arrêté qui avait été
donc déjà inscrit en 2019 pour augmenter
les droits d'inscription pour les
étudiants étrangers allit déjà en
contesens à notre devise républicaine là
il s'agit de l'inscrire dans la loi
c'est vraiment faire offense à notre
devise républicaine de considérer les
étudiants étrangers comme non égaux aux
étudiants français
monsieur le rapporteur non mais
simplement une précision Monsieur R
pardon mais vous avez dit des choses qui
sont inexactes la France aujourd'hui est
le 4e pays au monde le 4e elle n'a pas
régressé elle n'est pas la 6e il est le
4e pays au monde le plus attractif pour
les univ pour les étudiants étrangers le
4e au monde et c'est le premier pays non
anglophone le plus attractif pour les
étudiants et c'est d'ailleurs dans la
dynamique que nous avons impulsé depuis
2017 en ayant atteint un niveau inégalé
à ce jour de visa étudiants pour nos
pour les étrangers mon
saintou merci monsieur le Président
écoutez moi je m'étonne parce que nous
avons des débats sur la francophonie
nous avons Desbat des débats sur les
relations que nous devons avoir avec nos
partenaires africains et nous avons des
débats sur l'idée de rayonnement et
aujourd'hui on arrive et on nous propose
d'augmenter les droits
d'inscription
d'augmenter là en l'occurrence
l'amendement consiste à supprimer mais
la décision a bien été prise par la
droite de l'augmenter donc et vous et
d'ailleurs les macronistes ont choisi de
les augmenter ces droits d'inscription
aux universités dans le mandat précédent
donc excusez-moi le sujet quand même qui
se pose c'est de savoir dans quelle
mesure nous sommes prêts à faire des
efforts à accueillir le plus grand
nombre possible d'étudiants savoir
pourquoi et quel est le genre de
partenariat que nous voulons avoir avec
des pays qui ne sont pas rempli de
d'enfant de milliardaires si si votre
idée de la grandeur de la France c'est
que nous devons pouvoir accueillir les
enfants des riches alors je crois que
vous êtes à côté la réalité c'est que il
est dans l'intérêt de la France que nous
puissions accueillir les meilleurs
élèves dans toutes les conditions tous
les étudiants et dans les meilleures
conditions oui je je viens d'entendre
quelque chose qui est complètement
faux pendant le précédent quinena on a
certainement pas augmenté les frais
d'inscription on a largement baissé
l'entrée à l'université les les frais
d'entrée à l'université pour les
étudiants on a supprimé la mutuelle
souvenez combien ça coûtait la mutuelle
pour les étudiants ça coûtait très très
cher et donc oui mais moi je vous avez
parlé est-ce que est-ce que je vous
interromps quand vous parlez non jamais
donc laissez-moi vous vous répondre vous
vous dites et vous démontrez
effectivement que vous avez parfaitement
tort alors pour votre vignette Instagram
vous vous me prierez de me coller juste
après pour rétablir le fait que nous
avons baissé les prê d'entrere à
l'université pendant le mandat
précédent monsieur Lucas je suis pas
rencuné parce que vous avez interrompu
monsieur Balanant alors allez-y très
rapidement mais je ne doute pas qu'il
sera m'interrompre également quand il le
jugera nécessaire monsieur le Président
sa critique est toujours constructive
simplement simplement pour dire que je
regrette un peu le silence du ministre
mais je je me dis que ce serait utile
comment quand nous examinerons ces thème
lors de la séance nous ayons au banc la
ministre des Affaires étrangères la
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la Recherche parce que les décisions
que nous sommes en train de prendre ont
une influence sur l'influence justement
de notre pays son rayonnement et sur la
vitalité de notre modèle universitaire
et lui aussi de son rayonnement je pense
que les ententes seraiit préciux on
n'est pas sur une question sécuritaire
on n même pas sur une question
d'immigration on est sur une question de
rayonnement à l'international de notre
pays et sur une question universitaire
et de recherche très importante je mets
au voix ces amendements de suppression
qui votent
pour qui votent contre ils sont adoptés
donc il suppriment l'article le premier
h madame gaz
l'examen défendu monsieur le
rapporteur oui défavorable parce que
c'est au contraire je voudrais m'y
arrêter un instant si vous le permettez
c'est au contraire une disposition
extrêmement importante et très
intéressante qui est proposée par par le
Sénat c'est le dispositif dit
d'instruction à
360°gr qui fait suite d'ailleurs à un
rapport du Conseil d'État de mars 2020
un rapport d'information du Conseil
d'État aussi d'ailleurs de
2022 et qui s'appuie je vous le rappelle
sur le dispositif d'expérimentation
prévue dans notre Constitution à
l'article 37-1 il s'agit d'examiner dès
la première demande de de titre de
séjour l'ensemble des motifs de
délivrance l'ensemble des motifs de
délivrance possible d'un titre de séjour
c'est donc un examen du droit au séjour
en réalité plutôt que du droit à un
titre de séjour je pense que c'est une
avancée extrêmement importante avec une
contrepartie c'est que la recevabilité
de toute nouvell demande soit
conditionné à la présentation de faits
ou d'éléments nouveaux parce qu'il faut
bien sûr considérer que le parcours de
l'individu peut tout à fait évoluer et
j'ajoute que le Sénat prévoit
disposition là aussi très intéressante
la nécessité du consentement de de
l'individu si l'on devait changer le
motif du titre de séjour c'est-à-dire
qu' ne soit pas le motif qu'il est
initialement demandé donc pour toutes
ces raisons à à quelques modifications
prês que je préciserai dans quelques
instants je suis extrêmement favorable à
cet article et défavorable à toutes
celles et ceux qui souhaiteraient le
supprimer monsieur le ministre ou merci
monsieur le Président salure les les
parlementa parce que j'ai pas pris la
parole depuis le début de votre
commission juste pour dire
qu'effectivement je suis également
extrêmement favorable à cet ajout du
président buffet qui s'insp directement
de son rapport sénatorial qui lui-même
se s'inspire du rapport Stal du du
Conseil d'État l'une des difficultés que
nous avons c'est qu'il y a énormément de
tites de séjour dans notre pays à peu
près 180 à quelques unités près ces 180
titres de séjour créent une complexité
bien sûr pour les personnes qui
demandent un titre de séjour bien
évidemment pour se repérer dans le dédal
des dispositions qui peuvent les
concerner pour les agents préfectur
eux-mêm qui doivent connaître dans les
préfectures peut-être qui n'ont pas
forcément la chance d'avoir énormément
de monde énormément de de critères qui
correspond au titre de séjour et puis
crée aussi malheureusement une
difficulté pour les services de l'État
puisque lorsque quelqu'un dépose une
demande de titre de séjour et qui lui
est refusé il peut faire un recours sur
ce titre de séjour mais il peut aussi
redemander un titre de séjour sur un
autre motif retardant ainsi d'autant
l'application d'une mesure de conduite à
la fronti si ça devait être le cas
l'imagination du du rapport buffet qui
je rappelle a été adopté à l'unanimité
des sénateurs lors du précédent mandat
sénatorial c'est de faire que le service
public soit rendu de manière plus
efficace quand quelqu'un dépose un titre
de séjour le la préfecture s'il refuse
le titre de séjour parce qu'il
correspond pas au critères voulu par le
législateur doit faire le travail à 360°
regarder l'intégralité des autres titres
de de séjour possible et ainsi lorsque
le nom est nom c'est un nom définitif et
donc on gagne énormément de temps
évidemment pour les préfectures et pour
bien sûr les reconduites la frontière
puisque dans beaucoup d'arrêter de
reconduire reconduite qui peuvent être
mis ils sont parfois pas appliqués parce
que justement l'étranger a fait une
autre demande de séjour complexifiant
ainsi l'alication de notre notre droit
donc c'est vraiment important je
rappelle que c'est une disposition qui
est expérimentale comme dit le
rapporteur général parce qu'elle est
très complexe sans doute pour le
changement général de la méthode que
doivent avoir les les préfectures dans
dans deux grande région ça c'est un
point très très important et et je pense
que cette ça fait partie de ces
dispositions modernes de ce projet de
loi rajouté il est vrai par le Sénat
travaillé auparavant d'ailleurs le
président de la commission des lois en
été informé et qui nous permettra aussi
de gagner énormément de temps dans les
préfectures et correspondra à la réforme
de préfectures que nous souhaitons
Madame Dupont
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre sur ce sujet vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir que le département de
ménellloire a expérimenté ce cette euh h
option expérimenter justement ce ce 360°
hein le fait de euh regarder pour une
situation et une demande données euh la
possibilité d'attribuer un titre de
séjour parmi euh l'ensemble des titres
possibles et si je ne suis pas contre
l'idée que vous proposez euh j'alerte
néanmoins sur euh le le caractère
décevant hein de l'expérimentation en
méloire compte tenu euh des
de la systématisation qui engendre une
lourdeur administrative pour les
services déjà très encombrés
c'est-à-dire
qu'étudier l'option pour enfin
l'ensemble des options ça demande des
moyens humains importants donc quels
moyens humains vous comptez prévoir pour
rendre effective une telle vision à
360°gr et je pense
que autant sur un premier titre c'est
utile et pertinent mais sur sur les
renouvellements je vois pas trop
l'intérêt de ce 360 de Madame
fon euh merci Monsieur le le Président
je pour notre groupe nous avons
également des des doutes sur cette
instruction à à 360 degrés si elle peut
paraître effectivement séduisante
surtout je dirais pour celles et ceux
qui présentent leur dossier avec l'idée
que il va pas falloir revenir plusieurs
fois que il faut pas à chaque fois à
chaque nouvelle demande refournir de de
nouvelles pièces en réalité a aussi
l'idée que pour la première présentation
faut un nombre de pièces visiblement
plus important que pour une demande très
précise donc déjà il y a une question
sur euh vous demandez vous demandez un
titre sur le travail par exemple et vous
allez est-ce que vous allez devoir
fournir des choses sur toute votre vie
sur des des choses qui normalement ne
sont pas demandées dans le cadre d'un
autre titre ça c'est la première chose
et je rejoins l'idée que pour les agents
de préfecture ça demande quand même une
expertise très transversale pour les
agents qui n'est pas réelle aujourd'hui
au vu des personnels en préfecture dont
beaucoup de contractuel avec un turnover
permanent donc et et l'idée que on ne
pourrait pas représenter de nouveau un
dossier à moins d'éléments nouveaux
comment sont jugés ces éléments nouveaux
tout ça nous fait craindre en réalité
toutes ces questions pour la réalité
demandeurs oui merci monsieur le
Président euh simplement une
intervention pour dire que on apporte
notre soutien en fait à cette
proposition du sénateur buffet puis à
l'amendement du rapporteur général
l'évaluation à 360 vous l'avez dit c'est
euh une proposition qui permet en fait
d'examiner le droit au séjour dans son
intégralité euh 180 titres auxquels sont
confrontés le demandeur et nous on y
voit donc un triple intérêt à la fois
pour le demandeur lui-même pour
l'instruction de ces droits on y voit
aussi un intérêt pour les agents de
l'État qui instruisent ces dossiers et
puis dans on y voit évidemment l'intérêt
aussi de l'application des mesures
d'éloignement dans le cas où le droit au
séjour ne ne pourrait pas être confirmé
merci alors je mets au voix C pardon
monsieur min vous voulez répondre juste
pour répondre à Madame Dupont d'abord je
pense que dans le Maloir c'était pas
tout à fait la même chose que ça
s'appuyait pas sur la nef vous le savez
bien entreetemps il y a eu la nef 60 %
aujourd'hui sont dématérialisés je pense
que c'est déjà assez différent et à ma
connaissance Ctait quelques dizaines de
cas qui ont permis à l'expérimentation
en méoire qui est intéressante en soit
parce que vous avez parfaitement raison
de dire qu'il faut à la fois former je
rejoins madame fon les agents et puis il
faut y mettre davantage de moyens c'est
l'objet de la réforme des préfectures
que je vous présente dès que le
président de la commission des lois le
souhaite plus plus de façon plus plus
complète mais d'abord je constate que
nous ne faisons pas partout c'est trois
plateformes régionales Normandie
Occitanie PACA avec deux façons
d'expérimenter différemment plus un
ultraarin puisque je crois qu' Madame
yousoufa et Monsieur servard on pourrait
peut-être retenir monsieur le rapporteur
général une plateforme en outreem parce
qu'il faut regarder sans les choses avec
la préfecture sans doute que Mayotte est
la mieux placée mais on pourra toujours
en discuter qui permet de de pouvoir euh
répondre à à la question que vous posez
donc je pense que le gouvernement adopte
si j'ose dire la proposition de Monsieur
buffet avec de meilleures conditions que
lorsqu'on l' expérimenté à base
législatif légale en faisant en
s'appuyant sur laanf et surtout en
expérimentant dans trois régions avec
les moyens supplémentaires que vous
m'avez accordé au PLF sur les agents de
préfecture donc cette fois on vote
l'amendement qui vote
pour qui vote
contrez il faut que vous votiez qui vote
pour qui vote contre
il est rejeté le 7 le 1723 monsieur le
rapporteur rapporteur oui pardonnez-moi
je je vérifier la portée de cet
amendement parce qu'il y en a plusieurs
quatre au total c'est il s'agit de
toujours dans le caractère expérimental
de cette disposition d'instruction à
360° en fait de l'élargir à l'ensemble
des tytes de séjour l'objectif c'est
c'est c'est bien de couvrir les 187
titres de séjour et je note d'ailleurs
au passage que au fond ce que propose le
président buffet c'est de palier la
sédimentation des 187 titres de séjour
qui est une question à laquelle il
faudra tôt ou tard que l'on que l'on
s'attache que l'on s'attaque monsieur le
ministre d'ailleurs vous aviez proposé
que des parlementaires en mission
puissent au Sénat s'attacher à à faire
la part de ce qui mériterait d'être
clarifié parmi ces 187 titres et donc là
il s'ag de les couvrir entièrement dans
le cadre de cette expérimentation madame
obono alors qui défend l'amendement de
la France insoumise monsieur Fernandez
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
les pratiques actuelles d'instruction
des demandes de titre de séjour sont
unanimement décrites comme
insatisfaisantes et donc cette
expérimentmentation d'instruction à 360
degrés des demandes de titre de séjour
pourrait aller dans le bon sens à deux
conditions selon nous d'abord nous ne
pouvons en approuver la philosophie que
s'ils sont intégrés tous les titres de
séjour une personne demandant un titre
de séjour au motif de regroupement
regroupement familial par exemple peut
en même temps être victime de traite
d'êtres humains et l'autorité
administrative pourrait alors lui
permettre d'accéder à un titre de séjour
en conséquence et ensuite le rapport
remis à la fin de cette expérimentation
par le Gouvernement au Parlement devrait
prendre en compte la qualité de
l'accueil qui s'en est suivi pour les
étrangers dont les demandes auront ainsi
été examiné le nombre de demandes de
titre de séjour et le recours
contentieux introduit ne peuvent suffire
à estimer si l'expérimentation apporté
ses fruits il convient d'ajouter une
analyse qualitative de la suite du
parcours des étrangers dans le
labyrinthe administratif de l'accès à un
titre de séjour monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable monsieur
balanon juste une remarque sur sur ce
sujet qui qui me préoccupe depuis le
début qu'on qu'on examine ce titre
premier
1a c'est un titre qui est donc le fruit
de d'amendement et de du travail des
sénateurs très bien je je le respecte
mais contrairement à tout le reste du
texte et contrairement à un texte de
cette importance il n'y a aucune étude
d'impact et AUC et et surtout aucun
aucun avis du Conseil d'État et sur ces
questions là je trouve ça assez dommage
et c'est juste une réflexion et je sais
que vous vous vous on sort un peu du
débat mais pourquoi les sénateurs
auraient le droit de légiférer de cette
façon et que nous nous aurions nous
n'avons pas le droit de le faire puisque
chez nous il y a une appréciation
stricte de l'article 45 je je voulais le
dire depuis un moment et je profite de
cet amendement qui me semble opportun
pour le redire alors peut-être avant de
donner la parole à Monsieur le Ministre
il y a eu un rapport du Conseil d'État
le rapport Stal sur le sujet qui fait
objet d'étude d'impact enfin pour pour
pour le coup et pour le coup comme il
s'agit bien de délivrance de titre de
séjour l'amendement a un lien ce n'est
pas le cas de tous les ajouts du Sénat
mais cet amendement là il a un lien avec
le texte monsieur le
ministre bien peut-être répondre à la
question de Monsieur le Député Fernandez
on est bien d'accord que tous les titres
sont convenu dans l'expérimentation donc
il y a pas certains titres et pas les
autres voilà donc et deuxièmement je
crois qu'il y a une précision du
rapporteur général tout à l'heure qui
permettra de répondre à à votre
interrogation sur les suitees donc je
pense que votre vos deux questions se
trouvent réponse très clairement juste
remarquer parce que j'ai pas fait le
lien tout à l'heure parce que j'ai pas
vu qu'il y avait un vote je vrais juste
dire au groupes rassem national que j'ai
du mal à comprendre le un moment de
suppression alors je pense que peut-être
que le débat montrer qu'ils avaient
peut-être fait une erreur en proposant
la suppression puisque ils nont même pas
défendu vous proposez de supprimer une
expérimentation qui permet de répondre
plus vite aux étrangers et d'appliquer
plus fort les eqtf voilà donc je pense
qu'il faut que on soit aussi plus
cohérent pouz pas à la fois demander
qu'on applique plus rapidement le droit
et que par ailleurs on applique plus
fortement taux de qtf et refuser au
gouvernement les dispositions qui
apparaissent de bon sens évidente et et
et CLA donc vous auriez peut-être pu
retirer cet amendement de suppression
sauf à considérer que vous êtes
également contre cette disposition qui
va évidemment largement simplifier la
vie de nos agents de préfecture et et
l'application de ces ut madameor
oui merci monsieur le Président bon on
ne peut être que d'accord
avec cet idéal finalement ainsi
poursuivi qui est de dire on demande un
titre de séjour l'autorité examine
toutes les possibilités offertes et vous
délivre le titre de séjour qui
correspond le mieux à vos situations et
et puise de cette façon le sujet c'est
ce qui est recherché moi j'ai simplement
un regret du point de vue du législateur
pour la fabrique de la loi c'est que
comme le disait d'ailleurs mon collègue
Balanant c'est que l'étude d'impact on
ne l'a pas on ne mesure pas comment cela
va fonctionner moi ma question elle est
la suivante est-ce qu'il y aura une
plateforme avec des algorithmes comment
vont faire les les les les agents de
préfecture pour
pouvoir mettre en œuvre cette cette C
cet examen à 360°r ça c'est ma première
question ma deuxième question c'est que
je pense que c'est une expérimentation
en cela je trouve que c'est intéressant
ement pour expérimentation quand on dit
expérimentation on dit bilan et sur le
bilan je pense qu'il faut qu'on le
prévoit dans la loi il faut qu'on sache
quand comment avec qui le bil sera fait
par rapport à cette expérimentation
monsieur le
rapporteur mais si vous voulez que l'on
précise madame la député le la nature du
du bilan peut on peut le faire pour la
pour la séance mais c'est un dispositif
quand même qui a fait l'objet de deux
rapport du Conseil d'État 2020 2022 plus
le rapport buffet et bien sûr
l'expérimentation au bout de 3 ans
permettra d'obtenir un bilan peut-être
qu'il faut qu'on rédige mieux le contenu
même du rapport mais je je je note à
quel point ce ce dispositif peut
apporter un plus considérable le
ministre l'a dit à la fois l'instruction
à 360°gr l'administration numérique des
étrangers en France ce sont deux
dispositifs qui doivent répondre
d'ailleurs à des questions que vous avez
beaucoup posé sur l'article 1er a à
travers les de demande de rapport sur
l'engorgement des préfectures madame
fossillon l'indiqué il y a quelques
instants sur la nécessité pour les
ressortissants de faire des
allés-retours préfecture pour des
demandes et des demandes supplémentaires
qui à la fois ralentissent et ne sont
pas protectrices pour ce qui les
concerne les procédures de de réponse
donc je crois qu'on qu'on peut
s'entendre sur une rédaction
supplémentaire si vous le souhaitez
madame la députée pour pour la séance je
me voie l'amendement du rapporteur qui
vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté il
fait tomber le le suivant le 1600 le 610
pardon
monsieurelen merci monsieur le Président
déjà dire que notre groupe est est très
favorable à cet article premier hche et
qu'en effet cette
expérimentation instruction à 360 peut
présenter de de réel intérêt et sur le
long terme sans doute faire gagner
gagner énormément de temps l'amendement
du de mon collègue de notre collègue
Olivier serva est simplement
que dans cette expérimentation donc dans
les départements dans lequel il sera
expérimenté il y ait un territoire à
minima un territoire ultramarin et à la
limite j'aimerais le compléter en disant
que s'il pvait y avoir lesvoges aussi ça
pourrait être relativement intéressant
et je vous en remercie par avance madame
yousoufa alors lesvau je met surtout
d'abord
maotte alors Liot c'est les territoires
ultramarins donc effectivement nos amis
cors mais aussi euh Saint-Pierre et
miclon la réunion les Antilles et
mayottes et les territoires insulaires o
en effet vous l'aurez quand même compris
depuis le début de mes interventions une
une réalité migratoire très particulière
si on ne parle que du groupe lot le
territoire de Saint-Pierre et miiclion
n'a pas assez d'immigration et cherche
de la main d'œuvre le territoire des
Antilles connaî lui une migration de
proximité qui est différente de de celle
de maottes où nous avons plus de la
moitié de la population est étrangère
donc j'espère que nous pourrons mettre
compte tenu du défi migratoire
extrêmement
important et considérable à maotte
inclure mon département dans cette
expérimentation je vous remercie mon
rapporteur oui je je préfère la
rédaction du du 610 auquel je donnerai
un avis favorable plutôt que le 832 qui
préjuge du territoire ultramarin qui
serait qui serait choisi donc
défavorable pour le
merci monsieur le Président évidemment
un avis favorable à l'amendement 610 que
si on veut avoir une expérimentation
globale avec un avis un avis intéressant
il faut qu'il y a à minimum un
département ultramarin et je suis obligé
de reconnaître que l'amendement 832 va
dans le bon sens si on veut être sûr que
cette expentation fonctionne si ça
fonctionne à may à Mayot qui est
malheureusement tellement concerné par
cette problématique de l'immigration
illégale alors on peut considérer que ça
fonctionnera partout ailleurs je sais
pas en terme de moyen ce que ça
représente c'est pour ça que je m'engage
pas trop sur la question mais c'est vrai
qu'amendement de notre collègue
Youssoufa me semble intéressant sur
cette question là Monsieur le Ministre
alors peut-être qu' sé je pr un
sous-amendement enfin un amendement qui
qui clarifiera les choses peut-être dire
au moins un territoire ultramarin parce
qu'on pense évidemment maot on peut
aussi penser à la Guyane qui connait une
immigration différente de celle de
maotte mais aussi nombreuse même si
évidemment c'est pas la même proportion
donc je veux prendre mon engagement ici
deappliquer si nous le pouvons et je
pense qu'on a les moyens désoris dans la
préfecture qui vont être ajoutés
d'ailleurs à Mayotte on a doublé les
effectifs des étrangers à maotte pour
faire face à la demande donc on pour
tout à fait le faire dans la continuité
il y a 10 effectifs en plus qui sont
prévus à la la préfecture de maotte
comme je l'ai déjà dit et donc on
pourrait imaginer aussi la guyan donc je
proposerai au moins un territoire comme
ça on pourra appliquer de sujets alors
sur cet amendement 610 qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté il
fait tomber le suivant monsieur le
rapporteur vos deux amendements 1729
1730 en discussion présentation commune
oui présentation commune ce sont deux
deux rédactionnels pardon alors qui vote
pour le premier qui vote contre adopté
même vote pour le deè adopté également
madame fossillon le 48
oui dans dans cette phase encore un peu
floue nous pensons qu'il faut supprimer
en fait la la limitation du nombre de
demandes de titre de séjour même si j'ai
bien compris que l'objectif était
celui-là mais mais je trouve que la
proposition est encore un peu B un petit
peu flou euh notamment sur j'ai une
question par exemple monsieur le
rapporteur ou ou monsieur le
ministre sur les possibilités de
requalification des demandes formulé et
qui serait une requalification je vais
dire moins protectrice je pense par
exemple à la personne qui fait une
demande au titre Vie privée vie
familiale et qui pourrait se retrouver
au regard des des pièces fournies avec
un titre mention salarié ou travailleur
temporaire est-ce que ça c'est une
possibilité qui existe même si
normalement la pratique n'est pas n'est
pas légale mais on a vu qu'elle pouvait
elle pouvait arriver d'autant que vous
le savez le fait que les gens parfois ne
présentent pas on va dire le le la bonne
demande de titre c'est généralement des
enquêtes ont été faites dessus sur le
fait que quelque part ils ont pas les
bonnes informations au départ pour
pouvoir déposer la la bonne demande de
titre merci monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez deux amendements qui qui sont
complémentaires vous pourz donner votre
avis sur celui de Madame fossillon oui
défavorable sur celui de Madame
fossillon d'abord parce que je pense que
l'expérimentation doit permettre
d'établir toutes les toutes les
conditions même si précisément j'en j'en
précise certaines d'entre elles dans les
amendements qui suivent je rappelle que
si un un titre de séjour un motif de de
titre de séjour devait être différent de
celui qui a été sollicité en premier
lieu par le ressortissant alors il
faudrait obtenir son accord c'est la
ligne 4 du dispositif qui est proposé à
titre expérimental et puis je propose
des éléments qui euh clarifient les
éléments nouveaux précisément qui
devront être présentés par le
ressortissant si la demande initiale est
rejetée nous avons aujourd'hui le
ministre l'a dit euh en réponse à une
remarque il y a quelques instant des
difficultés sur euh euh l'éloignement
c'est-à-dire qu'à partir d'une personne
où euh à partir du moment où une
personne fait l'objet d'une qtf et que à
ce moment elle présente des éléments
nouveaux dans une stratégie très
clairement dilatoire pour euh euh ne pas
subir d'une certaine façon l'éloignement
alors ça bloque toute possibilité
d'éloignement et ça bloque la procédure
et je souhaite aussi que l'on puisse
clarifier dans le cadre de
l'expérimentation ce
dispositif bien donc alors je mets au
voix l'amendement de Madame fossillon
408 qui vote pour qui vote contre rejeté
le suivant du rapporteur le 1731 qui
vote
pour qui vote contre adopté et le 1732
du rapporteur qui vote pour qui vote
contre adopté également le 1603 qui le
défend madame
Martin bonjour à tout le monde alors
attendez évidemment je m'emmèle les
crayons bonjour à tous merci de me
donner la
parole il nous semble que ce qui doit
aussi prévaloir dans cette affaire
d'évaluation c'est un peu à la mode
d'ailleurs à 360° bref ça doit être
aussi la qualité de l'accueil et le
respect de la dignité des personnes
parce qu'on sent bien que la ligne
gouvernementale qui est gagné du temps
pour gagner du temps par exemple via la
dématérialisation qui fabrique des
Spiers ou les raccourscissement de délai
par exemple sur l'instruction des
demandes d'asile mais on y reviendra le
moment venu ne peut en
soi constituer la seule la seule le seul
élément d'évaluation ainsi par cet
amendement nous introduisons une
dimension plus qualitative qui est liée
à la situation des personnes elles-mêmes
qui ne sont pas des dossiers mais qui
sont bel et bien des personnes en chair
et en os
ou défavorable
auond pourquoi
défavorable défavorable mais au fond le
le rapport répond en formulant les
choses différemment à l'alinéa 7 à votre
question en allant regarder bien sûr
les effets de l'expérimentation
notamment sur les recours contentieux
qui a été introduits sur la qualité des
procédures qui en résulteront y compris
pour les ressortissants concernés donc
tu
favorable donc je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejeté l'article
1er H qui vote
pour qui vot contre il est
adopté le après le prier h le 432
monsieur di Philippo merci monsieur le
Président le but de cet amendement est
de prévoir une contribution financière
pour chaque étranger à l'instruction des
demandes de de titre selon des comme un
droit de timbre selon des modalités qui
serait prévu par décret effectivement on
assiste souvent à la multiplication des
dépôts de différentes demandes ça un
coût en temps et un coup financier à la
fois pour les services de l'État les
services de nos préfectures qui qui est
très très important et qui va croissant
et donc il me paraît légitime que au
moins dans une mesure plus ou moins
symbolique de quelques dizaines d'euros
et bien la personne qui demande
l'instruction du dossier en assume une
partie du
coup défavorable je mets au voix qui
vote pour contre rejeté le
1465 monsieur Lucas défendu monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur
défavorable je mets au voix qui vote
pour contre rejeté le 1049 monsieur
Lucas défendu monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur défavorable pour
contre rejeté le 1091 et le 1088 1091
madame Abad peut-être une présentation
commune peut-être pas comme vous voulez
défendu alors 1088 défendu et 1091
défendu
aussi allez-y allez-y ça y ça me revient
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
petit peu la même idée que j'avais
défendu lundi sur les très grands
départements on aurait besoin de de plus
de points de contact possible pour
déposer les dossiers il y en avait un où
j'avais l'idée peut-être que les points
France servic puissent être utiles et
l'autre que les sous-préfectures
puissent vraiment être guichet d'accueil
de dépôt de de dossierers monsieur le
rapporteur oui ce sont de de demandes
identiques formulé différemment la la la
grande question et la difficulté c'est
que la la le traitement du titre de
séjour j de la demande est une
compétence préfectorale France service
ça n'est pas une autorité ça n'est pas
une institution dépendant de l'autorité
administrative qui pose vraiment des des
difficultés de cohérence qui m'amène à
vous demander soit un retrait soit un
avis
défavorable
madamead
alors retirer les deux alors le 998
monsieur Lucas merci Monsieur le
président pour faire plaisir à ma
collègue ellisa Martin je vais le
défendre celui-ci cet amendement du
groupe écologiste veut faciliter les
démarches administratives de
régularisation des
étrangers en ne permettant plus à
l'administration de retarder une
régularisation par une forme d'inertie
dèslors en fixant un délai de de 4 mois
pour examiner les demandes de titre de
séjour délai sanctionné par une
acceptation implicite la loi vient
clairement borner dans le temps la phase
d'examen des demandes de titre de séjour
afin de favoriser une bonne
administration de l'examen de ces
demandes monsie le rapporteur
défavorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejeté le 999
monsieur Lucas j'ai pas défendu monsieur
le rapporteur défavorable je le mets au
voix qui vote pour contre rejeté au
premier i monsieur le
rapporteur oui merci Monsieur le le
Président il s'agit de la d'un
amendement de suppression portant sur
l'article qui lui-même supprimé euh au
terme des débats du Sénat l'aide
médicale d'État je vous propose que nous
renoncions au dispositifs du Sénat
d'abord parce que je je crois que les
médical d'État sans sans préjuger des
discussions qui pourraient se dérouler
non seulement aujourd'hui mais dans les
semaines et les mois à venir ce n'est
pas simplement une question qui relève
de la santé des individus c'est
évidemment essentiel mais c'est aussi
une question de santé
collective et je pense que d'ailleurs 3
ans après la pandémie que nous avons
tous traversé parfois avec de grandes
difficultés nous avons tous mesuré que
la santé des uns c'est la santé des
autres et que l'aide médicale d'État
permet de répondre à cet enjeu qui
encore une fois est un enjeu qui est
forcément collectif des questions sont
parfois posées sur l'aide médicale
d'État la question aujourd'hui n'est pas
de fermer le débat parce que quand un
dispositif bénéficie à 350000 personnes
à peu près il est normal que nous soyons
en tant que législateur vigilant
attentif à son mode de fonctionnement à
son mode d'accès euh au euh à la
possibilité des bénéficiaires de
vraiment en bénéficier quand nous savons
que tout le monde d'en bénéficie pas
alors qu'il pourrait tout à fait y avoir
droit vous connaissez dans quel
calendrier nous nous euh nous nous
situons un rapport sera rendu le 4
décembre prochain le rapport qui est en
cours de préparation à la fois par le
préfet stéphanimi et par Claude des 20
il apportera un certain nombre de
conclusions d'ailleurs je je vous
indique que ce rapport nous aurons en
tout cas
l'occasion en tant que rapporteur je
parle sous le contrôle de de mes
collègues corrapporteurs du texte de
d'auditionner les
corédacteurs mercredi prochain je crois
à 17h si l'horaire est est bien confirmé
pour qu'ils puissent nous présenter
leurs propres conclusions indivo si si
j'ose dire donc je nirai pas plus loin
dans l'argumentation le débat va se
faire sur un sujet extrêmement important
et qui a fait l'objet à juste titre de
très grand nom de commentaires ces
dernières semaines mais à ce stade c'est
un amendement par conséquent de
suppression de l'article 1er
i j'ai aussi j'ai aussi déposé un
amendement de suppression de la
suppression de de laame d'abord je pense
que ça n'a rien à faire ni dans ce texte
ni dans aucun autre de laame oui ce que
j'ai dit et donc et donc je vous demande
de vous rallier à la position du
rapporteur à la mienne et je crois à
celle de très nombreux collègues
monsieur
Castellani
merci monsieur le Président oui je serai
dans la même ligne la suppression de
laame n'éliminerait pas le besoin de se
soigner et aggraverait hsof facto la
pression sur les services
d'urgence ne serait pas non plus
d'ailleurs il faut le dire sans soulever
quelques problèmes
sanitaires en terme de donc de de santé
publique mais l'essentiel n'est pas là
moi je veux pas aborder les choses sous
cet angle là moi ce que je veux
simplement poser une question c'est la
suivante comment ne pas soigner comment
ne pas soigner comment laisser un être
humain se débattre seul avec la maladie
voilà la question est là et c'est la
justification profonde de notre
amendement merci Madame buffet le
suivant
oui monsieur le Président l'ame n'est
pas il ne doit pas être un instrument de
de politique migratoire c'est avant tout
un outil de de santé publique la mise en
place d'un unee réduction du panier des
soins est contre-productive elle
retarderait les les prises en charge et
conduirait à aggravation des pathologies
ce qui est à la fois un problème éthique
et économique cela reviendrait infé plus
cher donc je propose également de
supprimer cet amendement alors le
suivant n'est pas défendu le
621 monsieur madame
Martin euh merci de me donner la parole
bon d'ors et déjà il y a un certain
nombre d'arguments qui ont été donnés
nous ajoutons à à à ceci le fait d'abord
que nous considérons qu'il y a là un en
je d'humanité et un enjeu de santé
publique et qui peut pas être l'objet
d'une instrumentalisation politique
telle qu'il est peut-être se rappeler
euh si besoin était que des cas de
fraude qui ont pu être identifiés
étaient au nombre de 38 que finalement
le coût de cette
ame est extrêmement faible ça représente
0,4 % des quelques 204 milliards d'euros
de dépenses en matière de soins en
France et puis peut-être regarde regardz
ce qu'on fait les voisins l'Espagne
avait supprimé laame pour pour les mêmes
raisons
malsaines que celles qui ont présidé à
cet ajout du côté du Sénat et 2 ans
après ils ont renoncé et ils ont remis
en œuvre la me y compris parce qu'ils
avveit constaté une augmentation très
importante de la mortalité du côté des
exilés donc nous saluons cette démarche
qui vise à supprimer la m on n pas sal
oui merci heureux d'entendre aujourd'hui
que beaucoup se sont RALI à l'idé qu'il
ne fallait pas supprimer
laame il y aura un rapport j'entends pas
forcément le même message entre le
rapporteur général qui invite à une
réflexion à venir et le président de la
commission qui dit qu'il n'y a il n'y a
pas de débat et évidemment il y a de
quoi être troublé puisque au Sénat la
majorité présidentielle a voté la
proposition de suppression du Sénat et
que le gouvernement a émis un avis de
sagesse considérant finalement euh dans
la meilleure des hypothèses qu' n'a pas
d'avis sur le bien fondé du maintien ou
de la suppression de l'Ame donc nous
continuons nous de défendre l'ame parce
que la supprimé c'est dangereux
médicalement c'est absurde
économiquement et c'est indigne
moralement le 1118 n'est pas
défendu le 1137 Monsieur
petavi Merci monsieur le Président le
groupe écologiste ne peut que s'opposer
à cette article responsable d'une grave
remise en cause du droit fondamental à
l'accès à la santé pour toutes et tous
c'est cette restriction sans précédent
de laame est en totale contradiction
avec ce que nous a pourtant enseigné
l'épidémie de covid-19 les maladies et
les virus ne s'arrête pas aux portes de
la nationalité ou du titre de séjour
conditionner l'accès au soins à l'un de
ces critères en plus de faire preuve
d'un déni manifeste d'humanité relève
d'une totale inconscience sanitaire car
l'ame n'est ni une faveur ni de la
charité mais bel et bien une nécessité
et un droit pour préserver la santé et
l'intégralité de la population en
éloignant davantage la population qui
devrait bénéficier de laame vous
retardez davantage leur prise en charge
médicale et prenez le risque d'une
aggravation des pathologies existantes
ce n'est pas notre constat mais celui de
l'intégralité des médecins du personnel
soignant et du propre ministre de la
Santé madame fusillon le
1155 merci Monsieur le le Président
c'est franchement terrifié que j'ai vu
les les débats du
Sénat poussant nombre de sénateurs et de
sénatrices à vouloir supprimer limiter
euh l'aide médicale l'a l'aide médicale
pour pour les étrangers de voir que le
gouvernement invoquit un avis de de
sagesse c'est-à-dire libre de voter
cette cette suppression et donc les
sénateurs de droite les sénateurs y
compris de de de la majorité se sont
jetés sur cet amendement pour dire leur
faveur avoir l'aide médicale pour les
étrangers supprimé c'est proprement
scandaleux tout tout montre que nous
avons besoin de de cette ame à la fois
je dirais en terme moral éthique
humaniste mais évidemment en terme de de
santé publique en terme économique et
qu'elle ne peut être en aucun cas un
instrument de politique migratoire en
aucun cas l'ame ne peut être un
instrument de politique migratoire le
suivant je ne vois pas de défenseur 1924
le
1249 madame
pon merci Monsieur le présid Président
chers collègues le présent amendement
signé par les commissaires renaissance
de la commission des affaires sociales
vise à rétablir l'aide médicale d'État
que la droite sénatoriale a transformé
en aide médicale d'urgence d'abord nous
considérons que la disposition
introduite par les sénateurs n'a pas de
lien avec les objectifs poursuivis par
le présent projet de loi et constitue à
ce titre un cavalier législatif qui nous
faut donc écarter en effet en permettant
une protection santé aux étrangers en
situation irrégulière présent sur le
territoire français la me relève avant
tout d'un enu d'un enjeu de santé
publique et qu'il convient donc de
traiter comme tel supprimer laame c'est
prendre le risque d'augmenter le
renoncement aux soins de population déjà
précaire de dégrader leur état de santé
mais aussi celui de la population
française tout entière supprimer laame
c'est aussi renforcer le risque de
propagation de maladies infectieuses et
des retards de diagnostic entraînant
alors des prises en charg plus coûteuses
supprimer laame c'est également renvoyer
automatiquement les étrangers en
situation irrégulière vers les services
d'urgence qui qui connaissent déjà une
pression importante pour l'ensemble de
ces raisons les commissaires Renaissance
défendent cet amendement de suppression
de l'article 1er i madame
chassagol voilà merci merci monsieur le
Président je vais pas être très
originale c'est donc un amendement de
suppression pour trois raisons tout
d'abord parce que c'est un cavalier
législatif ensuite parce que il y a un
risque pour la santé publique pour
éviter le développement de maladies mais
aussi pour les malades et notre hôpital
avec des personnes dont les situations
se seraient aggravé faute de soins enfin
il n'y a pas d'appel d'air via la me le
nonreours est massif jusqu'à 50 % selon
le rapport d'étape de Patrick stéepanini
et Claude evvin missionné par la
première ministre sur la question et
nous avons d'ailleurs pu le constater
avec le président de la commission des
lois lorsque nous nous sommes rendus au
centre de rétention administrative de
vincenes en échangeant avec des médecins
qui nous expliquaient qu'il y avait une
forte méconnaissance du dispositif de la
part des personnes retenues madame
descots 1260
monsieur monsieur Mandon le 1288 merci
monsieur le Président le Sénat a pêché
une fois de plus par esprit de système
comme j'avais eu l'occasion de l'évoquer
lors de mon intervention liminaire
avantier au début de nos travaux sur ce
texte on ne peut que se
prononcer sur la question de laame en
écartant comme l'a fait le Sénat
l'aspect humanitaire d'un revers de main
et finalement sous-estimé les
importantes questions de santé publique
qui sendent cette mesure indispensable
donc c'est pourquoi notre groupe
démocrate souhaite la suppression de
l'article pour autant il y a là un sujet
de réflexion important qui justifie
d'ailleurs la mission confiée à Monsieur
evvin et stéphanini dont nous attendons
les
conclusions définitives s'il y a lieu
sera toujours temps de prendre des
dispositions d'aménagement du système
existant qui paraît
convenable je vous remercie le 1409
n'est pas défendu le 1425 Madame
Dupont merci monsieur le Président alors
l'aide médicale d'État elle est scruté
de près de nombreux rapports des
évaluations extrêmement nombreuses font
l'actualité et y compris ici à
l'Assemblée nationale elle a ét elle a
déjà été resserrée en 2019 ce n'est pas
sans difficulté d'ailleurs dans l'accès
aux soins des étrangers en situation
irrégulière dans notre pays les médecins
sont nombreux et professionnels de santé
nombreux à à nous dire toute
l'importance de cette politique de santé
publique pour les étrangers mais aussi
pour les français puisque le caractère
contagieux de certaines pathologies doit
nous amener collectivement à prendre
soin de tous ceux qui sont présents sur
notre territoire reporter l'accès aux
soins c'est-à-dire retarder l'accès aux
soins en resserrant l'aide médicale
d'État et en la supprimant et bien c'est
aussi un problème de santé pour les
personnes concernées mais un problème de
santé c'est publ et un coût également
pour nos finances publiques parce qu'on
sait bien que si on est dans le curatif
et moins dans le préventif et bien
souvent la prise en charge est beaucoup
plus coûteuse donc c'est un non sens en
terme de santé c'est un non sens en
terme financiers égalementci alors je
repêche le 1260 pour lequel je n'avais
pas vu monsieur
wilté merci monsieur le Président j'ai
comme beaucoup été dit je vais être
assez rapide jeai un accord
avecfossillon sur le fait que ça ne peut
pas être un élément de politique
migratoire que que de faire d'analyser
des variations sur la me c'est un non
sens sanitaire ça a été très largement
développé c'est aussi une bombe à
retardement pour notre service public de
santé parce qu'évidemment ça viendrait
enganger l'ensemble des l'ensemble
des des urgences et puis encore une fois
c'est juste un cavalier législatif on a
des règles ce serait bien que le Sénat
dans sa grande sagesse puisse les
respecter
aussi je crois qu'il n'est pas
défendu le 1548 monsieur Gouffier
Valante oui merci monsieur le Président
cet article introduit par les sénateurs
de manière cavalière a fait grandement
parler depuis son adoption au Sénat
notre groupe Renaissance souhaite
exprimer avec la plus grande clarté et
fermeté son opposition à la suppression
de laame telle qu'elle est proposée par
le Sénat laame qui ne représente que 0,5
% de nos dépenses de santé repose sur un
principe fondamental protéger la
population en évitant la propagation de
maladies infectieuses et protéger notre
système de de santé en prévenant en
particulier une sur sollicitation des
services des urgences elle est donc
essentielle aussi bien sur le plan
humain sanitaire que financier nous
voterons pour ces amendements de
suppression alors monsieur le
rapporteur non je n'ai pas de remarque
supplémentair à faire je crois que tout
a été dit je voudrais simplement
répondre peut-être à à Monsieur Boris
valallot qui essayait monsieur le
Président de nous séparer euh n
peut-être même de nous opposer c'est
cétait un peu grossier d'ailleurs ça se
voyait en tout cas ça s'entendait mon
cher collègue mon cher collègue Vallot
je vais vous donner quelques éléments
quelques éléments
d'appréciation sur des éléments
possibles de de réflexion dans les dans
les années à venir dans les mois à venir
que sais-je les semaines puisqu'on aura
un rapport d'abord 1 lorsque l'ame a été
réformée elle l'a été dans une dans un
projet loi de finance et de financement
et pas dans un texte d'immigration et là
nous serons d'accord et au ban c'était
d'ailleurs la min ministre de la Santé
de l'époque on peut s'interroger sur la
durée d'entrée dans le dispositif 3 mois
C'est long en réalité s'il y a des
question de santé publique c'est très
long c'est très très long on peut
s'interroger même sur la liste des soins
concernés est-elle complète est-elle
complète il y a peut-être des choses à
retirer peut-être des choses à ajouter
d'ailleurs peut-être donc c'est c'est ça
les éléments d'appréciation du
législateur consiste à dire il est
indispensable que l'aide médical d'État
soit maintenue dans notre pays j'ai
indiqué les raisons pour lesquelles je
j'y croyais très fort vous l'avez aussi
je pense tous fait ça n'interdit pas que
nous puissions regarder par exemple
cette question de l'entrée dans le
dispositif s'il y a vraiment des
questions de santé publique s'il y a des
problèmes de prophylaxie s'il y a des
problèmes de vaccination s'il y a des
difficultés de pathologie particulièr 3
mois c'est très long par exemple et donc
c'est un élément d'appréciation parmi
d'autres monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le Président je également de
corriger monsieur valallo s'il me le
permet le groupe RDP n'a pas voté pour
l'amendement sénatorial déposé par les
centristes et par le groupe LR il a voté
au contraire l'amendement de suppression
de la disposition par le Sénat c'est un
point très important parce que vous avez
dit que les les sénateurs qui relevaient
du travail sénatoriel pour la majorité
parlementaire de l'Assemblée avait
soutenu cet amendement ce qui n'est pas
vrai voilà le sur le sur le fond d'abord
ça a été très bien dit par monsieur le
rapporteur général et par beaucoup de
d'orateurs ici c'est un cavaler
législatif évident il relève pas du code
des des étrangers chacun sait que par
ailleurs en cette priode budgétaire
c'est dans le les cadres des textes
budgétaires que l'on parle de laame
c'est d'autant plus particulier que il y
a des débats budgétaires en ce moment et
le gouvernement a toujours dit qu'
n'avait pas souhaité mettre de
disposition comme celle-là dans le texte
initial et qu'il s'agissait en effet si
on avait été tenu sans doute au débat de
l'Assemblée nationale en première
lecture que il e été jugé irrecevable il
le sera il s'agit donc pas de mentir au
aux Français quel que soit ce qu'on
pense de laame de sa transformation
puisqueà coup le Conseil constitutionnel
va censurer ce ce cavalier donc autant
effectivement être le plus sincère le
plus sincère possible ce qui n'est pas
le cas du titre de séjour étranger
malade qui lui éta un titre de séjour et
qui avait le droit de figurer évidemment
dans le texte de loi que que que nous
présentons deuxièmement je veux redire
que lundi matin je recevrai avec
Aurélien Rousseau monsieur Stéphanie
monsieurin qui rendront leur rapport
conformément à la déclaration de Madame
la Premier ministre ce rapport sera
rendu public et vous l'avez dit
vous-même monsieur le Président je sais
que vous allez les auditionner monsieur
rapportur général ce qui montre que le
gouvernement n'a rien à cacher sur le
constat que peut faire ce ce rapport par
stéphanini je crois est très bien connu
par les députés qui viennent de de la
droite de cet
hémicycle secrétaire général du
ministère d'immigration grand préfet par
de fois directeur de campagne d'un
candidat à la présidentielle et Monsieur
Évin je crois lui-même ministre de la
Santé d' RS également connu de ceux qui
viennent de la gauche cette mission et
je crois savoir qu'il n'y a pas de
divergenence entre eux sur le constat et
sur d'éventuelles proposition cette
mission sera donc rendue publique avant
le débat pardon de l'Assemblée nationale
sur le texte immigration même si
effectivement des dispositions doivent
pas être modifiées dans le texte
immigration il peut être modifié dans
d'autres textes d'abord les textes
budgétaires ou des textes de santé
puisque la première ministre elle-même
s'est exprimé ainsi aux questions
d'actualité s'il y avait des des
conclusions tenir je vlais dire
peut-être deux choses très rapides
puisque ça a été évoqué rapidement sur
le fond je ne suis pas certain de mon
expérience de minise l'intérieur que ce
soit la question du panier de soins qui
soit la difficulté la plus importante
dans la compréhension de la me dans sa
modification je pense que le montant du
coûp de la me d'ailleurs je regarde un
député élu à Mayotte qui réclame elle
laame à Mayotte non pas pour des raisons
d'appel d'air migratoire on pourrait
l'appeler comme ça mais pour des raisons
de franchise de combien d'étrangers en
situation irrégulière et qu'est-ce que
ça coûte à la sécurité sociale puisque
l'ame c'est aussi une question comptable
en premier lieu puisque quand vous avez
pas d'ame bah ça se voit dans les
comptes de la CC et donc du coup il y a
pas de compensation par l'État et donc
évidemment laame a d'abord été imaginé
pas simplement être un dispositif de
santé publique puisque les médecins
soignent les personnes qui se présentent
devant eux avec les conséquences qu'il y
a sur les urgences et l'hôpital public
mais de de de vérité sur les chiffres
évidemment que cela coûte et ce qui
permet d'avoir ce ce débassin et
démocratique alors que si on supprime
laame on supprime le thermomètre et donc
on a sans doute encore plus de de
fantasmes et si le montant de cette ame
est forte c'est pas parce que il y a
davantage de coût pour le système de
soins par unité de personnes mais bien
parce qu'il y a plus d'immigrés en
situation irrégulière qui est sur notre
sol donc laame n'est que le thermomètre
du nombre de personnes irrégulières qui
ne repartent pas de notre territoire et
donc le but de pourre faire diminuer
laame si on voulait avoir ce but là et
c'est le but que peut avoir tout bon
gestionnaire public c'est moin si moins
de personnes en situation étrangère
irrégulière sur notre territoire c'est
le but du projet de loi le but du projet
de loi c'est de limiter l'immigration
irrégulière au maximum afin en effet de
lutter contre ce qui peut permettre de
les garder trop longtemps sur le
territoire national et notamment la
lenteur des procédures administratives
en un mot si vous voulez faire diminuer
la me n'hésitez pas à adopter des
articles des titres 3 4 et 5 de ce
projet de loi qui est la simplification
drastique des procédures parce que sinon
c'est le chat qui se qui se mort la
queue et c'est un point très très
important évidemment ici à à souligner
2è sujet euh je veux souligner
l'extrêmes difficultés évidemment de ce
sujet puisque 25 % des bénéficiaires d'
me sont des enfants 25 % et et
deuxièmement je veux aussi euh euh pour
peut-être balancer ce propos dire que
plus de 50 % des bénéficiaires de la me
euh ont euh plus de 3 ans de présence
sur le territoire national et là je ve
rejoinds le rapporteur général le fait
que l'ame soit à 100 % pour des gens qui
sont là depuis euh plus de 3 mois et en
fait depuis plus de 9 mois si on regarde
l'intégralité de la couverture de la me
est assez paradoxal puisqu'il faudrait
sans doute que laame soit complète au
premier jour de leur arrivée sur le
territoire national sans doute pour
pouvoir accompagner toutes les
pathologies que nous évoquions et pour
pas emboliser les services d'urgenence
et que évidemment quand on rentrera dans
une période où la personne doit repartir
du territoire national après avoir
épuisé tous les recours surtout si on
adopte les titres 3 4 et 5 pour être
beaucoup plus efficace sa question se
pose de savoir si ce n'est pas une
faillite notre système de gestion
d'immigration que plus de 50 % soit
depuis plus de 3 ans la répon est oui
c'est pour ça que nous présentons ce
projet de loi donc sur le fond comme sur
la forme je crois que cette discussion
est sans doute intéressante moi je je
pense pas qu'il y a de sujet tabou en
tant que tel il beaucoup de dispositions
européennes correspondent à une forme
d'ame j'entends souvent dire que la
France sera la seule avec l'Espagne à le
porter c'est pas tout à fait vrai nous
avons demandé pour le bénéfice de la
mission de Monsieur Evan monsieur
Stéphani des comparaisons
internationales à toutes nos ambassades
et d'ailleurs je proposerai qu'on annexe
les contre-rendus diplomatiques et on
verra qu'il y a beaucoup de critères
différent que ça correspond à beaucoup
de réalités différentes ce qui est
certain c'est que ce travail sera
forcément un peu complexe et qu'il
pourra avoir le jour si la première
ministre l' décide ainsi à la suite de
la remise de ce rapport indépendamment
du texte immigration voilà en quelques
mots puisque c'est lundi matin que sera
remis ce rapport il sera rendu public
dans la foulée et je su très heureux que
monsieurin et Monsieur Stéphani accepté
cette difficile mission puisquil
rendront compte de leur mission devant
vous monsieur gilet
oui monsieur le Président chers
collègues je crois que quand on parle
d'ame il faut rappeler quelques points à
commencé que un tiers des Français ont
déjà renoncé à des soins faute de moyens
qu'un sur de déclare piné à se soigner
que le gouvernement d'ailleurs ces
dernières années a continué à diminuer
le remboursement des soins pour les
Français pendant ce tempsl le nombre de
bénéficiaires de la me lui il augmente
vous l'avez dit monsieur le ministre il
augmente forcément à proportion de
l'augmentation de l'immigration qui
touche le pays 82 % d'augmentation ces
10 dernières années c'est considérable
pour 2024 la me coûtera 1,2 milliard
d'euros au français c'est un régime
d'ailleurs qui est une exception en
Europe et si je me félicite qu'au Sénat
et bien il y ait eu la suppression de la
me au profit de la création d'une aide
médicale d'urgence comme le propose
Marine Le Pen depuis de très nombreuses
années je regrette qu'ici la majorité y
compris la gauche évid
et bien réintroduis ou tente en tout cas
de réintroduire ce dispositif tout à
l'heure tout à l'heure un de nos
collègues disait comment ne pas soigner
quelqu'un qui est
malade monsieur Lucas merci monsieur le
Président rapidement collègue du
rassemblement national adore les
sondages alors j'en ai un sous les yeux
très sérieux d'uninstitut 74 % des
Français sont pour le maintien de l'aide
médicale d'État singulièrement quand ils
sont bien informés euh dessus voilà donc
on peut pas utiliser les sondages
d'opinion quand ça vous arrange et ne
pas les utiliser quand il vous
desservent l'aide médicale d'État c'est
0,5 % du budget de la Sécurité sociale
donc de quoi parlez-vous chers collègues
vous parlez de la goutte d'eau dans
l'océan et et vous réquisitionnez pour
ça des heur de débat ici l'aide médicale
d'État c'est le strict minimum monsieur
le ministre de l'interne n'avons pas
exactement compris votre avis en tout
cas je me réjouis d'entendre la sagesse
de nos collègues de la majorité qui
veulent revenir sur cette disposition
une sagesse manqu au gouvernement dans
l'examen du texte au Sénat puisqu'il a
donné lui son avis de sagesse qui n'a
jamais aussi mal porté son nom et que le
groupe des sénateurs macronistes a voté
pour ce texte et donc et donc pour la
suppression de l'aide médicale d'État je
me réjouis si nous revenons dans le B
sens même si je suis aussi inquiet des
propos du rapporteur sur la
suite merci monsieur le Président qu'il
est doux plaisant agréable d'entendre
chanter les louanges de l'Ame c'est
merveilleux
c'est c'est touchant c'est juste parce
que c'est un problème sanitaire et puis
là où ça s'arrête votre angl mort
habituel c'est ah pas d'ame à Mayotte
pas de d'amendement sur laame à Mayotte
pas de rapport Evin ou stéphanini lundi
avec quoi que ce soit sur la à Mayotte
ou la possibilité de la mettre à Mayotte
donc comme ça on va maintenir l'angle
mort et puis on va on va laisser notre
seul
hôpital continuer à traiter un patient
sur de étranger qui ne paye pas ne
contribue pas ne paye rien de manière
dérogatoire moi je n'ai qu'un seul mot
bravo Madame
mard merci monsieur le Président bah
bien évidemment je crois qu'il y a
personne ici qui demande la suppression
pur et simple de l'ame et personne ne
laissera sans soin un clandestin qui
souffre de la tuberculose ou une femme
enceinte sur le point d'accoucher
d'ailleurs c'est bien ce qui est prévu
dans l'écriture du Sénat qui prévoit la
transformation de l'Ame en Amu euh on
sait que l'aide médicale d'État
bénéficie aujourd'hui environ 350000
personnes environ euh elle ouvre droit à
la prise en charge à 100 % des soins
avec dispense d'AV d'avance de frais et
ces bénéficiaires ne sont pas soumis au
dispositif du médecin traitement donc
traitant donc le parcours de soins
coordonné alors parmi les soins qui sont
prévus par la me c'est pas un mythe on
va les aborder il y a effectivement les
rhinoplasties les Anau gastriques et les
interventions pour oreilles décoller
vous avouerez comme situation d'urgence
on trouve mieux alors beaucoup d'entre
vous explique que la migration pour
soins est un mythe au profit que le taux
prétexte que le taux de non recours à
laame pourrait atteindre 49 % mais je je
vous avoue que c'est le principe même
qui choque car certains français quand
ils sont en situation financière
difficile rogne en premier lieu sur leur
dépenses de santé et monsieur le
ministre vous avez parlé c'est bah oui
c'est une minute pour tout le monde
merci monsieur le Président moi aussi je
salue cet avis de de sagesse et ce
retour à la sagesse je regrette qu'il
n'ait pas eu lieu sur les autres
amendements où il y avait des questions
de santé publique depuis le début de nos
débats euh mais qui peut croire quand
j'entends des députés d'extrême droite
que les gens vont traverser la
Méditerranée en regardant ce qui est
laame et se dire je vais me faire
recoller l'oreille et venir en France ça
n'existe pas aujourd'hui les gens ne
regardent pas ce coffre la me avant de
traverser la Méditerranée et vous
évoquez souvent le fait qu'il y ait un
appel d'air qu'il y ait des fraudes je
donne un chiffre 2018 le nombre de
fraudes à la me c'est 38
c'est 500000 € j'aurais aimé que des
collègues sur ces bans soient plus
offensifs pour mettre un coup d'arrêt à
la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale qui
elle fait les poches de nos concitoyens
et casse les services publics plutôt que
de s'attaquer au plus fragiles de ce
pays madame louvagie merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
voudrais réagir sur un propos quand vous
nous indiquez que la me relève de la loi
de finan et que ça mérite d'être examiné
dans l'hémicycle l'article 493 ne nous a
pas permis d'examiner cette mission dans
l'hémicycle un premier point pour réagir
sur le caractère contagieux qui est
quelquefois évoqué je voudrais redire
que le rapport de 2019 de l'IGF et
liigas qui cite le dispositif français
comme étant le plus généreux d'Europe et
qu'il compare à H pays européens dans
ces h pays dans la majorité il n'a pas
été constaté d'épidémie de risque de
contagieux et de coût beaucoup plus
importants le deuxième point pour
contrer euh le le fait qu'il est
difficile de définir les soins urg je
voudrais rappeler que le décret du 30
octobre 2020 a permis de définir un
certain nombre d'actes 16 prestations et
deux actes exactement soumis à un délai
de carence de 9 mois entre l'admission à
l'AME à la réalisation des actes c'est
donc dire qu'il est possible de définir
la nature des soins urgents et le
troisième point que je voudrais aborder
c'est de dire que comment peut-on
aujourd'hui comprendre que nous ne
pouvons pas écarter des
interventions tel le type recollement
d'oreilles décollées gastroplastie ou
intervention lié à l'obésité ceci n'est
plus compris par nos concitoyens
Monsieur
marcangéi Merci monsieur le Président
l'honnêteté me commande de dire que ce
n'est pas euh une position de groupe que
je défends mais une position personnelle
puisque le groupe Horizon est apparenté
et est traversé par des courants qui
parfois ne sont
pas équivalent et compatible sur la
question de l'ame et de sa
transformation en Amu euh d'abord le
positionnement de cette ce changement
dans le texte je considère à titre
personnel effectivement que ce n'est pas
dans le cadre du texte immigration que
nous avons à discuter de l'Ame quand en
discutit cela a été rappelé par Monsieur
monsieur le rapporteur général un
rapport sera rendu par monsieurs evvin
et et stéphanini dans les semaines qui
viennent les jours qui viennent et je
demande et monsieur le ministre vient de
nous le confirmer je demande à ce que
rapidement la première ministre fixe les
conditions de ce débat de manière claire
pourquoi pas à l'occasion d'une loi de
finance rectificative pour que nous
puissions avoir ce débat sereinement de
manière posée détacher du texte
immigration qui est aujourd'hui nous
amène à travailler ensemble et peut-être
aussi de manière je dirais un peu plus
réaliste puisque j'entends beaucoup
d'approximations sur la question donc je
voterai à titre personnel l'amendement
de suppression je mets au voix
l'amendement de suppression de l'article
1er I qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté il
supprime l'article
prer non non il faut qu'on avance un
peu le premier j alors le 180 monsieur
Lucas merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président cet amendement il vise à
supprimer la disposition introduite au
Sénat sous la dicté de Madame pcris pour
finalement régler ses comptes avec le
tribunal administratif qui l'avait
empêché de pratiquer dans les transports
en commun francilien une mesure
discriminatoire euh en
privant les étrangers en situation
irrégulière des réductions tarif
tarifaires pour l'usage des transports
en commun ce qui est une mesquinerie
absolue et et un scandale qui avait
d'ailleurs été sanctionné par la par la
justice voilà bon et bien nous proposons
de de supprimer cette cette
disposition alors le suivant monsieur
carbrat non madame Martin
pardon bon on est dans la dans la
poursuite de ce dont nous
discutons
maintenant et donc là il s'agit de de de
réduire les capacités d'accès aux soins
des
étrangers encore une fois sur les
questions de transport pardon
excusez-moi encore une fois on est bien
dans cette logique de de rendre la vie
des étrangers infernales et en creux il
y a toujours cette opposition que l'on
mettrait entre les étrangers qui
profiteraient d'un système auquel les
Français eux-mêmes ne pourraient pas
avoir accès et d'une certaine manière
c'est ça aussi qui explique l'ire tout à
fait fondé du côté des représentants de
Mayotte c'est l'expression de cette
forme de mise en concurrence extrêmement
malsine et il est vrai que
indépendamment de la question de la
place des étrangers dans le pays la
question d'un d'une égalité réelle sur
l'ensemble du territoire se pose
cruellement euh pour pour les habitants
là en l'occurrence de Mayotte mais
malheureusement ça va auelà de Mayot
monsieur vot
euh merci monsieur le Président oui
cette cette disposition est tout
simplement cynique mesquine c'est
effectivement l'amendement pcres elle
est cynique parce que d'abord je je
rappelle que cette réduction tarifaire
elle est elle est de droit elle est
inscrite dans le dans le code des
transports et
que il n'y a pas lieu de de ne pas
l'appliquer mais elle elle est cynique
parce que elle n'aura que pour seul
objectif d'éloigner les étrangers de de
soins médicaux et et par ailleurs de
produire euh des usagers qui seront
contraints de prendre des transports
sans titre et qui permettront ensuite
d'alimenter les débats qui consistent à
dire que évidemment les étrangers sont
de pas tenter fraudeur voilà donc il y a
lieu de supprimer cet article évidemment
monsieur le genant merci monsieur le
Président défendu pour des raisons
identiques à celles que j'avais exprimé
à propos de article sur les les
contrôles des étudiants deux deux
précisions pour répondre à ce que j'ai
pu entendre tout à l'heure je ne suis
pas opposé aux articles du Sénat parce
qu'ils viennent du Sénat je suis opposé
aux articles du Sénat quand il
déséquilibr de façon majeure les
équilibres du texte initial du
gouvernement or comme vous le savez en
cette matière comme en beaucoup d'autres
mais particulièrement sur la question
migratoire nous ne pouvons pas apprécier
la portée politique du texte uniquement
dispositif après dispositif il peut y
avoir des dispositif qui
individuellement se justifie mais dont
la somme bouscule gravement les
équilibres politiques portés par ce
texte c'est la raison aussi pour
laquelle je souhaite la suppression de
cet article madame fossillon
oui c'est c'est effectivement un un un
article particulièrement je sais pas
mesquin oui
mythteux en voulant exclure des des
conditions tarifaires plus favorables
les étrangers en situation irrégulière
alors qu'aujourd'hu nous sommes bien sur
des conditions de ressources et qu'il
faut pouvoir les conserver honnêtement
qui pense que en mettant des tarifs plus
onéreux pour les étrangers ils vont fuir
le territoire français personne personne
ne pense que parce que vous allez payer
votre ticket 2 € ou votre votre
abendnement que 75 ou 90 vous allez
partir du territoire français non c'est
donc bien pour exclure les personnes
étrangères d'un droit de circuler à
l'intérieur du territ
c'est pour les exclure de tout ça et
pour les mettre en situation d'avoir
aussi plus d'amende et pouvoir encore
pouvoir faire un trait d'égalité entre
délinquance et
étranger
ch merci monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement de suppression également de
cet article je comprends l'intention des
sénateurs qui était de dire qu'après
tout des personnes qui sontite situation
irrégulière ne devrait pas bénéficier de
certains avantages sauf qu'à mon sens la
question est mal posée si déjà on
accepte d'empêcher de circuler des
personnes selon leur situation
administrative la question c'est sinon
comment font-ils sinon celui qui part
travailler pour faire fonctionner un
restaurant parisien alors qu'il est
encore sentide de séjour celle qui est
enceinte et doit se rendre à la
maternité celui qui est en attente d'un
rendez-vous en préfecture parce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut parfois attendre
jusqu'à 1 an pour en obtenir un comment
font-ils en tout cas ils ne vont pas
acheter un pass Navigo s'ils sont en
Île-de-France plein tarif parce que pour
pour beaucoup la situation va être celle
de la fraude dans les transports en
commun par conséquent puisque nous
devons mieux accueillir les personnes
que l'on peut ou doit accueillir refuser
de circuler pour un motif administratif
ce n'est pas réellement accueillir
correctement par ailleurs il y a une
question juridique qui se pose
puisqueune décision similaire à
l'article ajouté par les sénateurs prise
par la la région il defance en février
2016 a été annulé par le tribunal
administratif en 2018 pour caractère
discriminatoire 292 n'est pas défendu
Madame Dupont le
1426 merci il s'agit là d'un amendement
de suppression
également on le sait les personnes en
situation irrégulière dans notre pays
sont particulièrement
vulnérables ces tarifs adaptés
aujourd'hui tel que le prévoit le le
code des transports permettent de leur
permettre de se déplacer par exemple
pour aller à l'école pour aller en
préfecture pour se soigner et cetera et
cetera et j'ai le sentiment que la
suppression de ces réductions tarifaires
s'apparente à une forme de trac
potentiel des personnes en situation
irrégulière quand j'additionne
l'ensemble des mesures qui ont ainsi été
introduites moi c'est le sentiment
général qui me vient à l'esprit un
tableau impressionniste de
stigmatisation systématique des
étrangers donc je suis profondément
désaccord avec cette proposition émanant
du
Sénat monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci Monsieur le le Président je
crois que chacun ici
est d'accord pour considérer que
bénéficier d'une tarification sociale
pour se rendre à l'hôpital lorsque l'on
est par exemple une femme enceinte ou
parce que l'on souffre d'une palotologie
particulière c'est une évidence je pense
que c'est quelque chose que l'on doit
pouvoir maintenir lorsque l'on est en
situation de vulnérabilité de façon
générale il serait inconcevable que nous
bloquions la possibilité pour la
personne de bénéficier d'une
tarification spécifique de la même façon
que nous allons je l'espère voter un
article 4 bis pour lequel je proposerai
quelques aménagements et donc il n'est
pas exclu que les personnes concernées
par l'article 4 bis en situation
irrégulière qui demande leur
régularisation a besoin d'aller à la
préfecture n'est pas exclu il y a des
rendez-vous préfectoraux il y a des
rendez-vous juridictionnels et donc je
pense que cet aspect vous le souligner
cher collègue Clara chassagol cet aspect
doit absolument être maintenu ce qui
fait débat me semble-t-il ce qui fait
débat c'est l'obligation faite aux
AOT d'appliquer systématiquement la
tarification sociale à la seule
condition de ressources l'obligation pas
simplement une possibilité qui serait
ouverte aux
AOT sur ce point moi je pense que l'on
peut accepter la proposition faite par
le Sénat d'intégrer la condition de
régularité dans la tarification sociale
et donc en l'état je vous proposerai de
maintenir l'article tel qu'il a été
proposé par le
Sénat pour la séance je vous proposis
parce que cela nécessite à la fois des
consultations sur la faisabilité sur les
données techniques sur le renvoi à un
décret d'application qui nécessairement
sera complexe et quel serait son délai
d'application je vous proposai que l'on
maintienne ce que j'ai indiqué dès
l'entamme de mon intervention
c'est-à-dire moi je souhaite que l'on
maintienne la tarification sociale pour
les personnes en situation de
vulnérabilité je souhaite que l'on
maintienne la tarification sociale pour
que le ressortissant de nationalité
étrangère puisse se rendre à son
rendez-vous préfectoral ou puisse
aborder la question des procédures
juridictionnelles dont il ferait par
exemple l'objet voilà la situation que
nous propose le Sénat voilà la solution
que je vous proposerai pour la séance et
donc voilà la position que je vous
propose à cet instant monsieur
Lucas bon pour changer je vais je vais
parodier Michel Sardou ça parlera à
certains d'entre vous dans un voyage en
Absurdie où je pensais à Sarkozi j'ai
imaginé sans complexe qu'un matin on
avait élu pcrress et qu'on vivait
l'étranger drame de perdre notre âme
des années 2020 moins humaniste qu'un
chirakien ayant réussi l'amalgame de
l'inutilité et des larmes â des années
2020 moins humaniste que le ministre
d'armanin sachant voter et c'est le
drame ce qui va produire un beau vacar
mettre des députés aux idées noires
démagogies comme autrefois les
politicars être caporal de le Penny
préféré l'audiovisuel de Christine Kelly
emprunte jusqu'au fond des yeux d'une
idéologie et
adieu monsieur
marcangelli il y a des gens qui ont raté
leur vocation monsieur le
Président la Chasson française perd
beaucoup nous allons nous voter contre
ces amendements de suppression nous ne
voyons vraiment en aucun cas en aucun
cas on a souffert s'il vous plaît
souffrez de nous entendre on a on n pas
vocation je le pense à accepter que une
personne dans situation irrégulière
bénéficie d'un tarif préférentiel donc
c'est c'est tout simplement le bon sens
nos compatriotes ne comprennent pas ce
type de mesure donc nous voterons contre
les amendements de suppression madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président donc
dans cet amendement l'anupè c'est une
partie des macronistes vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec le fait que les
clandestins n'ai pas accès à des
réductions d'au moins 50 % dans les
transports ça veut dire que vous voulez
que les clandestins c'estd qu's sont des
personnes arrivées illégalement sur le
territoire national ou qui s'y
maintiennent malgré par exemple une qtf
bénéficie de réduction dans les
transports en commun bon une fois une
fois de plus vous faites la promotion de
l'illégalité une fois de plus vous
donnez des droits à des personnes qui
n'ont rien à faire là et cette situation
crée une injustice sociale à l'égard des
Français dont le rythme est métro boulot
dodo et qui eux payent pleinôt leur
titre de transport grâce notamment à
Madame pcres qui a annoncé qu'elle
allait augmenter cette année encore le
pas Navigo donc moi je trouve que c'est
regrettable de sur crois quand on sait
que 63 % des agressions sexuelles
commises dans les transports en commun
d'Île-de- France sont le fait d'étranger
donc cette prime à l'illégalité est
particulièrement indécente oui
effectivement monsieur le rapporteur ça
n'a aucun rapport monsieur
porte merci monsieur le Président je
regrette que l'avis de sagesse du
rapporteur sur l'amendement précédent
sur la
suppression de la disposition du Sénat
ne soit pas venu aussi sur celui-là
finalement les idées de la droite
radicalisée sont vite revenu à la tête
de du rapporteur il faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont ce n'est pas un
tarif préférentiel c'est une
tarification sociale ce qui n'est
absolument pas la même chose et je
partage ce qui a été dit par la collègue
du pont c'est il va y avoir une chasse
derrière aux étrangers et la police qui
va faire la chasse dans les transports
va organiser la trque de ces personnesl
c'est pas sérieux et le seul objectif de
Valérie pcrè c'est de pourrir la vie de
ces gens-là au contraire il faut leur
permettre pour des raisons qui ont été
évoquées de se déplacer pour des
rendez-vous médicaux pour aller chercher
du travail pour des rendez-vous en
préfecture de pouvoir prendre les
transports et comme l'a très bien dit ma
collègue fossillon demain vous viendrez
nous montrer des statistiques en disant
que ces gens-là sont surreprésentés dans
les infractions vous créez les
conditions de les mettre en infraction
par votre politique
antisociale madame Ménard merci monsieur
le Président mais il y a un terme qui
est revenu dans dans la défense des
amendements de suppression qui m'a un
peu choqué je vous avoue c'est le terme
mesquin demander à n'importe quel
français ou de demander à n'importe quel
étranger en situation régulière sil
trouve normal qu' qu'un clandestin en
France puisse bénéficier de tarifs sur
les transports je crois pas que vous
aurez beaucoup de réponses positives et
je voudrais dire que en fait cette
réduction de tarif de transport ça
s'apparente à une forme de de prime à
l'illégalité une fois encore et on peut
et on peut aller plus loin parce que ça
peut effectivement aussi s'apparenter à
un déid à la circulation d'étrangers en
situation irrégulière en en vertu de
l'article
l622-1 du code de l'entrée et du séjour
des étrangers du droit d'asile donc
évidemment moi je voterai contre les
amendement de suppression je vous
remercie ça coûte de P cher sera censuré
monsieur di
Philippo merci monsieur le Président
effectivement c'est très dur de de
supporter un certain nombre de
caricatures sur la présentation des
situations à gauche c'est vertu à mettre
sur le même plan ce que serait des
réfugiés situation légal est-ce que sont
maintenant des personnes présentes
irrégulièrement en France qui ont violé
nos lois pour se pour se maintenant sur
quand j'entends que ces personnes là
doivent aller travailler je me demande
bien comment elles peuvent aller
travailler puisquelles n'ont pas de
titre de de séjour de la même manière
que tout à l'heure la Muus n'était pas
une volonté de pu soigner personne mais
de remettre en cause le panier de soins
qui a très bien été décrit dans ses
excès par ma collègue madame madame
louvagi donc à un moment maintenant il
faut juste rétablir certaines certaines
valeurs je reprends tout à fait à mon
compte l'expression de Madame Ménard
concernant la prime à la clandestinité
une personne française qui va travailler
parce qu'elle a trop de revenus ne peut
pas bénéficier de réduction comment elle
peut comprendre qu'une personne qui
viole nos lois elle bénéficie d'une
réduction de 50 % il faut à un moment
donné remettre les pieds sur terre
monsieur
Valot plusieurs choses d'abord il y a
jusquà ce moment de l'examen du texte il
y a pas de de délit de séjour irrégulier
première chose pour répondre à mon
collègue deuxième chose je crois qu'il
est impératif de voter cette suppression
avec la perspective bientôt d'un billet
à 4 € pour se déplacer à Paris pendant
la période des Jeux Olympiques et
dernière chose la proposition du
rapporteur général pardon mais c'est
comme disait fouco c'est ubur rond de
cuir c'est le grotesque bureaucratique
c'estàd la chose
absolument impossible à mettre en œuvre
donc vous pouvez faire preuve
d'imagination et de fantaisie
administrative ça ne marchera
pas monsieur Gouffier Valante
oui merci monsieur le Président ce sujet
n'est pas nouveau je vais pas vous le
cacher c'est un sujet qui fait débat
depuis plusieurs années au sein de notre
groupe en mar marche et aujourd'hui
Renaissance un sujet qui avait déjà fait
débat lors de la loi de 2018 lors de la
loi d'orientation des mobilités lors des
différents budgets monsieur le
rapporteur général vous nous proposez de
travailler à un compromis d'une certaine
manière et à un aménagement que vous
aviez déjà proposé lors de la loi l'OM
que nous avions alors repoussé euh nous
préférons cette solution que vous
avancez aujourd'hui à une suppression
pure et sèche de ce dispositif aussi
nous voterons contre ces amendements de
suppression mais en vous demandant de
bien vouloir reparler d'ici la séance
pour voir sur quel dispositif exact nous
pourrions aboutir je vous remercie et
enfin monsieur le
rapporteur la difficulté du dispositif
actuel je le répète c'est l'automaticité
c'est l'obligation à la fois pour la
pour la AOT Île de France on parle
d'île-de-fance en fait ce sont toutes
les AOT de de France vous dites monsieur
Vallot on pourra pas ajouter des
conditions si nous mettons la régularité
comme condition et que nous ajoutons
qu'au-delà de la ressource il faut
regarder la situation individuelle
notamment j'aiindiiquer la santé encore
que les déplacements sanitaires je
l'indique dans le cadre de l'aide
médicale d'État sont déjà pris en charge
au titre des actes médicaux non urgents
qui peut dont on peut bénéficier au bout
de 9 ans de 9 mois pardon mais je pense
que nous pouvons resserrer le dispositif
pour tenir compte de la réalité de
chacune de ces personnes en renonçant à
l'obligation pour aé à la seule
condition de ressources d'attribuer une
tarification sociale je crois que c'est
une disposition
équilibrée bien je mets au voix ces
amendements de suppression qui votent
pour
attendez qui vote contre qui vot contre
baiss les main contre vot
contre
rejeté ménè le 33
oui c'est c'est un amendement
rédactionnel mais je j'en profite pour
revenir parce qu'il y a un argument qui
a été beaucoup détaillé pendant pendant
la discussion sur ces amendements de
suppression c'est vous empêchez les gens
de circuler vous empêchez les étrangers
de circuler mais personne empêche les
étrangers de circuler avec cette ce
dispositif simplement on leur demande de
payer leur leur leur leur billet comme
n'importe qui et de et et et et et de
pouvoir justement circuler comme
n'importe qui mais encore une fois
demander autour de vous au à nos
compatriotes ou aux étrangers en
situation régulère régulière personne ne
comprend pourquoi un étranger clandestin
en France devrait et pourrait bénéficier
de de tarifs privilégiés de tarifs
réduits je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur
défavorable monsieur de la porte oui en
fait chers collègues il faudrait juste
remettre en enfin vous remettre en tête
ce qui est en train de se passer là en
gros on est en train de dire quand on a
laame c'est-à-dire en gros quand on
gagne moins de 800 € par mois on a accès
à un tarif social sur le réseau
î-de-fance c'est quand on gagne quand on
est à moins de 777 € on peut bénéficier
de la solidarité gratuité du réseau
île-de-fance ça c'est les plafonds mais
non mais c'est c'est juste deux choses
qui sont différentes mais parce que en
fait on a des plaons de ressources qui
sont équivalents c'est juste ça que je
veux dire et en fait c'est pas faut
arrêter de dire que c'est open bar et
cetera il y a déjà en fait un certain
nombre de conditions et deuxièmement là
c'est ce que vous êtes en train de faire
c'est de voulez inventer une usine à gaz
pour rajouter des conditions au
conditions au conditions et vous allez
restreindre de la mobilité de personnes
qui n'ont déjà pas finalement de
ressources financières suffisantes donc
vous êtes en train de faire un truc
inapplicable simplement pour faire un
cadeau à la droite et à l'extrême droite
et on voit bien qui vous défend merci
Monsieur Lucas merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur chers
collègues vous déraillez complètement je
dis pas ça parce qu'on parle de
transport mais enfin quand même quand
même je je je je le redis cette
mesquinerie absurde monsieur de la
pororte vient vient donner également des
raisons enfin une politique tarifaire
elle est fondée sur les ressources elle
est pas fondée sur les papiers sur la
nation et cetera franchement j'ai de la
peine chers collègues de la majorité
j'ai de la peine pour vous parce que je
crois qu'il y a quand même des
convictions qu'on pourrait partager je
pense que vous avez été élu à deux
reprises pour faire barrage à l'extrême
droite pour empêcher que s'applique dans
ce pays les idées noséabondes de Madame
leupen ou de la droite radicalisée de
madame pcrè qui a fait 4 % l'élection
présidentielle et là vous vous alignez
derrière le programme de Madame pcerè
enfin quand même ceux qui nous regardent
doivent comprendre ce qui est en train
de se jouer c'estd que en le le
rapporteur général et le ministre CDE en
ras campagne à toutes les revendications
de la droite radicalisée de l'extrême
droite sur toute pratiquement depuis le
début de ce texte vous nous dites allez
peut-être bien qui peut-être bieni
pe-être bienoui il y a jamais peut-être
bien que non donc en réalité vous êtes
en train de céder complètement et c'est
en fait madame PCR et Madame Le Pen qui
font le texte de la loi immigration les
Français doivent le savoir bon je mets
au voix cet amendement qui vote pour qui
vote contre il est rejeté le 844 madame
Youssoufa merci monsieur le Président
alors cet amendement a pour objectif de
définir de manière plus stricte
l'élégibilité
au tarif de solidarité dans les
transports en
commun c'est une pierre dans votre
jardin il y a quasiment pas de transport
en commun à
Mayotte voilà je c'est ma contribution
au débat c'est juste pour expliquer que
quand on a rien aller se dire qu'on va
parier sur la solidarité générale alors
qu'il y a zéro dépenses pour les
transports en public les transports
publics à Mayotte est-ce qu'on peut nous
épargner de nous dire il vaudrait mieux
accueillir encore plus voilà là j'essaie
juste de vous aler sur le fait que
mettre des critères c'est évidemment ça
nous paraît quand même on le constate
tous les jours à Mayotte une question de
principe et puis d'équité parce que au
final si vous avez un territoire qui est
très po dans lequel vous dites il faut
donner plus à ceux qui ont moins bah ça
érode le consentement à l'impôt parce
qu'il y a quasiment plus de service
public disponible je vous remercie alors
monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable parce que là nous
avons un débat sur un resserrement du
dispositif pour les conditions de V
habilité pour l'accès aux procédures
administrative et juridictionnelle mais
là la la limite que vous mettez serait
tout à fait exclusive par conséquent
défavorable alors je mets au voix qui
vote pour qui vote contre il est rejeté
l'article 1ier J qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté on va
faire une suspension de quelques minutes
dont tout le monde a bien besoin
merci alors on va pouvoir reprendre
je laisse monsieur cast s'installer
parce que c'est lui qui va défendre le
616 moi je
Suppr Castell pour le
616 je trou ça
bien
monsieur monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
excusez-moi bon c'est un amendement de
notre collègue
neigeline qui propose de d'exclure les
les Anglais les Britanniques qui
possèdent une résidence secondaire en
France du dispositif général merci c'est
dommage madame alors madame R n'est pas
là alors Monsieur Mandon allez-y oui
merci monsieur le président
oui cet article on peut le constater
fait un sort très particulier et une
catégorie bien précise
d'étrangers les Britanniques s'il nous
reste proche nous gardons en tête qu'ils
sont ressortissants d'un pays qui a fait
un choix celui de s'éloigner
volontairement de l'Union européenne on
comprend bien les raisons qui ont permis
à certains sénateurs de convaincre le
Sénat de faire cette
faveur en même temps n nous interrogons
tout de même sur la place de cet
article dans un projet de loi aux enjeux
autrement plus importants et sachant que
d'ailleurs après le brexit il y a des
dispositions qui avaient été prises
c'est pourquoi nous considérons qu'il y
a lieu de supprimer
l'article monsieur le rapporteur vos
avis votre avis alors mon avis je je
retire mon propre amendement qui proposa
une réécriture et je suis beaucoup plus
convaincu par les amendements de
suppression auquel je donne un avis
favorable
bien j'ai pas d'autres intervenant
madame mard pardon excusez-moi je vous
avais oublié allez-y madame Ménard vous
m'avez oublié merci monsieur le
Président
non je pense que la raison enfin pour
tous ceux qui ont des citoyens
britanniques dans leur circonscription
on la connaît tous c'est
probablement pour décharger les services
de la préfecture de de ces demandes en
fait incessantes des citoyens
britanniques qui et pas n'importe quel
citoyen britannique puisque c'est
précisé dans le dans l'article qui ont
une résidence secondaire en France donc
c'est pas c'est pas juste les citoyens
britanniques en général c'est ceux qui
ont une résidence secondaire en France
effectivement qui sont obligés qui se
voient obligés de de renouveler leur
demande de de titre de séjour très
régulièrement puisqu pour la plupart
passe plus de 6 mois de l'année en
France et queils ne peuvent pas le faire
sans devoir repartir au Royaume-Uni et
donc voilà je pense que c'est les les
sénateurs dans leur sagesse on ont
probablement jugé bon qu'il fallait
soulager les services des préfectures
qui qui passent beaucoup de temps à à à
régulariser ces titre de séjour qui sont
pas très problématiques en so merci
Monsieur Lucas merci monsieur le
Président en fait pour être un étranger
qui bénéficie de la bienveillance de
l'extrême droite et la droite
radicalisée il faut avoir une résidence
secondaire en fait avec les riches vous
êtes nos bordurs totalement nos bordeur
non c'est c'est intéressant à à analyser
et enfin alors madame jeev oui merci
monsieur le Président moi je crois qu'il
ne faut pas supprimer il ne faut pas
supprimer cet article de quoi
parlons-nous depuis le brexit les
séjours des citoyens britanniques dans
l'Union européenne ne peuvent plus
dépasser 90 jours sur une période de 180
jours ceux qui désirent effectuer un
long séjour en France doivent désormais
solliciter un permis de séjour ou un
visa procédure longue et complexes et
ces difficultés vous en conviendraz
trouvve leur racine dans la décision
souveraine du Royaume-Uni de quitter
l'Union européenne il n'en demeure pas
moins que beaucoup de ressortissants
partis anglais britanniques participent
activement au dynamisme de l'économie
locale dans nos territoires et sont
soumis au même titre que tous les
habitants à l'imposition faussière ainsi
au regard des liens uniques qui unissent
nos deux pays et de l'importance de ce
public dans l'économie française cet
amendement souhaite par dérogation
alléger les modalités d'entrée sur le
territoire français des citoyens
britanniques propri de résidence
secondaire en France alors l'amendement
de suppression qui a reçu un avis
favorable du rapporteur qui vote
pour qui vote
contre il est al attendez qui vote
contre et donc il sont
adoptés
alors on passe à l'article 1er l
monsieur le
[Musique]
rapporteur monsieur rapporteur
allez-y-y merci Monsieur le le Président
nous nous
abordons l'article 1er
l ajouté par le Sénat à l'issue de ces
débats en séance et qui consiste à
intégrer un délit de séjour irrégulier
dans le code des étrangers je je
voudrais vous dire mes mes doutes et la
raison pour laquelle j'ai proposé cet
amendement de de
suppression jusque en 2012 il existait
en effet un délu de séjours irrégulier
qui était accompagné de de de peine
d'emprisonnement ce que interdit nos
engagements conventionnel et nous avons
été d'ailleurs à l'époque sanctionné et
donc la loi lo du 31 décembre 2012 est
revenu sur le dispositif passé je je
note que il
s'agissait pour donner la la la chaîne
pénale qui existait alors à la fois
l'interpellation aboutissait à des
gardes à vue avec de grandes difficultés
opérationnelles très nettes et une
criminalisation qui une judicialisation
pardon qui posait un certain nombre de
de difficultés le Sénat évidemment tient
totalement compte des appréciations
portées à l'époque puisque il n'ajoute
pas de peine d'emprisonnement et parce
que s'il y avait interpellation du
ressortissant concerné ce ne serait pas
ensuite dans le cas d'une garde à vue
que les éléments d'identité de séjour
seraiit vérifié dans le cadre de la
retenue pour vérification de séjour de
4h mais il me semble que on peut douter
de l'efficacité du dispositif proposé
sur la forme et sur le fond par le Sénat
raison pour laquelle je vous propose
cette suppression alors j'ai aussi
déposé un amendement de suppression du
délit de séjouré régulier pour les
raisons de nonconformité au droit
européens que le rapporteur vient de
mentionner je crois aussi l'inefficacité
du dispositif comme il vient d'être dit
sur la surcharge des services des
services de police pour finalement une
infraction qui ne devrait pas être
caractérisée et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous propose à l'instar du
rapporteur sa suppression monsieur Lucas
écoutez il est il est défendu je vais
être dans une démarche convergente avec
la vôtre et celle du rapporteur pour une
fois pour que nous supprimions ensemble
cette cet article madame buffet oui
monsieur le Président oui la suppression
du délit de séjour irrégulier qui
permettait de placer lesevenants en
garde à vue est allé de pare avec la
création d'une retenue administrative
qui permettait de vérifier la régularité
du séjour cette dernière s s'est avérée
bien plus efficace que les gardes- à vu
puisque sous le quinquena de Nicolas
Sarkozi du temps du délit de séjour
irrégulier environ 70000 interpellations
ont eu lieu ce chiffre s monté a environ
90000 retenus sous le quinquena de
François Hollande et a atteint environ
120000 retenus sous le quinquena
d'Emmanuel Macron il n'apparaît donc pas
judicieux de rétablir un délit de séjour
irrégulier proposons-nous aussi de
supprimer cet
article monsieur qui do défend
l'amendement de la France insoumise
madame Martin monsieur fernandz
ou il y a d'ors et déjà un certain
nombre de choses qui ont été dites même
si la France sabite à être en
noncformité avec les principes de la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
d'ailleurs je je redis hein qu'un
certain nombre parmi vous d'ailleurs
souhaiteraiit en sortir on atteint des
sommets bref moi finalement ce qui me
choque le plus là-dedans c'est que le
ministre daranin a donné un avis
favorable au Sénat pour le retour du
déli de séjour irrégulier voilà et tout
est dit Monsieur monsieur Solignac
oui aussi rapidement que mes collègues
je rappelais que effectivement le délit
de séjour irrégulier a été supprimé par
le par le droit européen et qu'il
s'agissait de la mise en œuvre d'une
directive votée sreur de ma part par le
PPE au Parlement européen euh et que
enfin pour terminer personne ne se pose
la question de la mise en œuvre de ce
délit de séjour irrégulier cette mise en
œuvre serait illusoire inutile infondé
d'où la nécessité de supprimer cet
article Monsieur Le Gendre très bien
défendu par par vous-même et par le le
rapporteur pas pas
mieux alors je n'ai pas de membre du
groupe
GDR euh madame
chassagnol merci un amendement de
suppression donc de l'article et de ce
délit déjà supprimé en 2012 grâce à la
directive européenne de 2008 qui
recommande aux États-membres de
privilégier les mesures d'éloignement
aux peines d'emprisonnement alors
l'astuce des sénateurs a été de
sanctionner seulement par une amende de
3750 €. je comprends cette intention
regarde l'irrégularité du séjour de
certaines personnes de rappeler la loi
par une peine d'amende mais on risque
excusez-moi de l'expression de faire un
coup d'épé dans l'eau car beaucoup de
personnes en situation irrégulière sont
de ce fait aussi insolvable ce qui me
préoccupe aussi c'est que certaines
personnes peuvent se trouver dans une
situation administrative d'irrégularité
de séjour sans qu'elles soit en cause
par exemple avec la fin d'un titre dans
l'attente d'un renouvellement avec
l'absence d'un rendez-vous possible en
préfecture ou encore avec des retards
dans l'obtention de documents
administratifs qui peuvent pénaliser les
personnes qui devraient de/3ro payer une
amende ce qui semble particulièrement
injuste alors je n'ai pas de défenseur
pour le
1263 et pour le
suivant monsieur Mandon peut-être
monsieur
balanan défendu Monsieur balanan et
Madame Dupont pour le 1425 7 défendu
également je rejoins les les arguments
du rapporteur merci alors monsieur le
rapporteur je suis naturellement
favorable aux amendements de suppression
en ayant déposé un moi-même monsieur le
ministre
oui merci monsieur le Président je moi
je veux dire mon mon soutien à la
disposition votée par le Sénat même si
je pense qu'elle n'est pas
révolutionnaire ni dans son acceptation
si elle devait être votée ni dans son
refus d'abord historiquement je pense
qu'il est important de rappeler en effet
que le S dé de séjour a été supprimé par
une loi de décembre 2012 elle fait suite
à une directive européenne en effet
adoptée et promu par le par le PPE et
pour des raisons évidemment sans doute
d'efficacité et pas simplement de
conformité à à la CEDH on aura
l'occasion d' d'y revenir ce qui est
tout à fait vrai cependant qui n'est
jamais dit c'est que d'autres délit de
séjour irrégulier existe dans le droit
ce qui permet aux policiers de faire
leur travail le délis d'entrée
irrégulière à une frontière extérieure
d'illeurs à Schengen y compris en
outreem le délit de maintien irrégulier
sur le territoire et le délit de retour
non autorisé sur le territoire français
ce qui est intéressant de savoir c'est
que si on a si le président Hollande et
la majorité d'Alor a supprimé le délit
de séjour irrégulier il a maintenu le
délit de maintien irrégulier sur le
territoire ce qui permet aux policiers
d'intervenir et de pouvoir avoir
lorsqu'il y a uneqtf qui n'est pas
respecté une peine d'un an
d'emprisonnement et 3750 € d'amende et
le placement en garde à vue donc c'est
c'est quand j'entends les discours qui
disent que le retour de ce délit de
séjour reviendrait à criminaliser ou à
délictualiser le le droit des étrangers
en en France c'est déjà le cas puisqu'il
y a ce délit de séjour de maintien sur
le territoire national euh il y a des
comparaisons internationales he la
Belgique et l'Espagne par deux fois
d'ailleurs des gouvernements socialistes
ont remis un délit de de séjour
irrégulier qui correspond à peu près à
ce qu'a fait le Sénat c'est-à-dire pas
de condamnation de prison ni euh ferm
surciis mais des amendes alors pourquoi
ces amendes sont importantes
elles sont importantes parce que elles
permettent de faire des choses un petit
peu plus supplémentaires que ce que
permet de faire en effet la retenue qui
est efficace et moi je voudrais dire que
le
dispositif le dispositif qui a été
imaginé en 2012 et montre son efficacité
puisque si je prends les chiffres entre
2007 et 2012 il y a eu à peu près 80000
interpellations en moyenne par les
services de police entre 2012 et 2017
c'estàdire sous le gouvernement de
Monsieur Hollande 92000
d'interpellations en moyenne par les
services de police est des retenus et
plus de 120000 depuis 2017 donc le fait
de pas avoir ce délit de séjour il est
vrai madame la députée n'empêche pas la
police de faire des retenues et de
pouvoir pouvoir renvoyer les personnes
dans leur pays mais le délit qui
n'existe plus euh permet plusieurs
choses d'abord de permettre au aux juges
je pense que ça peut être sensible
notamment sur l'IDE gauche de
l'hémicycle au juges de prendre la
décision de justice pour éloigner la
personne du territoire irrégulier et pas
simplement au juges AD administratif de
regarder ce qu'a fait le préfet donc là
le juge judiciaire se mêle de la
présence sur le territoire national
alors que à présent peut-être que c'est
un petit peu moins protecteur pour
l'étranger seul pouir administratif
fonctionne avec le juge administratif
deuxièmement ça permet je pense que ça
c'est aussi un point important de
pouvoir rentrer une partie des personnes
que nous rechercherions notamment des
personnes qui soupçonné d'avoir commis
des actes délictuels ou criminels dans
le Faed le fichier automatisé des des
empreintes digitales désormais les
personnes quiqtf sont dans le FPR euh ça
a été jugé euh évidemment compatible
avec le droit suite à une instruction
que j'ai prise moi-même en en 2000 le
Conseil d'État a rendu un avis favorable
malgré les les attaques que cette
instruction a pu subir mais on peut pas
mettre les personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui suspectées euh par dans
certain nombre de fichiers de police sur
des de travail qu'auraient fait des
personnes irrégulières dans la
criminalité dans le fait et puis surtout
troisièmement et je pense que ça c'est
le plus important ça permet de faire
lorsque nous pouvons mettre mettre
quelqu'un en garde à vue pour délit de
séjour irrégulier c'est ce que il était
possible de faire avant 2012 des
fouilles et des perquisitions qui
permettent notamment de retrouver des
papier d'identité alors c'est assez
corrigé par un amendement qu'on a fait
adopter au Sénat par ailleurs il est
vrai monsieur le rapporteur général on a
eu cette discussion lorsque la personne
est mise ou allit être mis en crin
puisque c'est ce qu'on demandera
directement au JLD désormais si vous
confirmez l'article nouveau que nous
avons créé au Sénat mais comme le débat
au Sénat a eu lieu d'abord sur le dé
séjour et ensuite sur la capacité du JLD
à pouvoir avoir des des pouvoirs étendus
sur ses perquisitions et ses fouilles
pour trouver l'identité des personnes ce
n'était pas très cohérent avec le texte
du début sénatorial donc je veux dire
monsieur le rapporteur génal que je
comprends les les difficultés et
notamment la difficulté qui consiste à
mettre plus de contraintte au travail
que font les policiers parce qu'il est
tout à fait vrai que si on crée ce délit
ils auront davantage de de travail à
faire et notamment de rédaction de
procès verbaux et de transmission à la
justice alors qu'il vrai que le pouvoir
administratif de la retenue est en fait
plus rapide et sans doute plus efficace
qui explique les Ch d'interpellation je
propose qu'on ait ce débat peut-être un
peu plus profond dans l'hémicycle et
avec quelques exemples de démonstration
et peut-être l'entouré de conditions de
garantie si jamais l'hémicycle devait
favoriser une nouvelle écriture que
celle proposée par le par le Sénat donc
je crois qu'à la fois ce délit de séjour
qui ne prévoit pas des peines de prison
se fait dans d'autres pays conformément
au droit européens et à la CEDH et que
il est vrai que la retenue per de faire
ce travail mais ne permet pas de faire
tout le travail que sans doute une
dureté plus forte contre l'immigration
irrégulière mériterait madame mard
oui merci merci monsieur le Président en
fait quand vous interrogez les agents de
la PAF la police de l'IR et des
frontières c'est ce qui revient le plus
souvent c'est ce qui c'est ce qui a
rendu en fait le le la suppression de du
du délit de séjour irrégulier en 2012
c'est ce qui a rendu leur travail euh
plus compliqué depuis depuis donc un peu
plus de 10 ans maintenant
euh moi je je je trouve que ce qui est
intéressant dans la dans la rédaction du
Sénat c'est la c'est l'amende évidemment
mais c'est surtout la peine
complémentaire de 3 ans d'interdiction
du territoire français sans compter
évidemment l'inscription au fichier que
vous avez mentionné monsieur le ministre
notamment notamment le Faed et puis pour
terminer je retirerai moi mes deux
amendements qui arrivent juste après
puisque leur adoption ne serait pas
conforme à la directive européenne de
2008 je vous remercie monsieur Gouffier
oui merci Monsieur le le président
euh n voici sur un sujet qui là aussi
fait débat au sein de notre groupe mais
même si nous avons entendu au propos
monsieur le ministre euh nous allons
rejoindre plutôt les propos de notre
président de commission et de notre
rapporteur général qui effectivement
pointe un la question de non conformité
au droit européen 2 les questions
d'inefficacité du dispositif voir de
risque qu'il pourrait faire peser sur
nos services de police aussi nous
voterons ces amendements de
suppression madame Rousseau mais en fait
ce dont il s'agit là c'est de ni plus ni
moins qu'une forme de harcèlement une
maltraitance administrative permanente
sur les personnes migrantes et
étrangères en France et en
fait là on est dans dans dans quelque
chose qui est au-delà des droits humains
et on peut vouloir réguler une une
immigration en France on n' pas le droit
de ne pas traiter les personnes
dignement et et de les épargner d'une
forme de maltraitance administrative
donc encore une fois chaque article de
cette loi est porteur chaque article de
cette loi est porteur donc où est-ce que
cela s'arrêtera nous soutiendrons
évidemment l'amendement de
suppression monsieur pont oui merci
monsieur le Président ce délit de séjour
de séjour irrégulier va toucher tous les
migrants sur la la côte d'Opal qui sont
en attente de passer donc en Angleterre
donc c'est pour moi une double peine
pour eux ils vont payer le passeur ils
vont payer le l'amende donc c'est pas
une façon de régler le problème madame
jeunevard merci monsieur le Président
quand on a entre 700 et 900000 personnes
en situation irrégulière naturellement
il faut maintenir ce délit de séjour
irrégulier c'est pour nous un marqueur
essentiel et nous voulons dire que nous
sommes très très attachés à la
restauration et au maintien de la
disposition adoptée au Sénat euh qui
vise à rétablir le délit de séjour
irrégulier alors vous avez invoqué le
caractère non conventionnel de ce délit
de séjour irrégulier mais quand on
regarde l' viis de la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne c'est beaucoup moins
clair que cela euh la cgue n'a pas
écarté la possibilité pour un État
membre de l'UE de concer ver un délit de
séjour irrégulier et de le réprimer par
une de le sanctionner par une amende
pouvant être remplacé par une peine
d'expulsion ou d'assignation en
résidence sous réserve que cette
dernière soit encadrée de la garantie
que son exécution puisse prendre fin dès
que le transfert physique de l'intéressé
hors de l'État membre soit possible donc
c'est un peu facile un peu rapide
d'invooquer le caractère noncentionnel
de cette disposition en
réalité merci
madame
Diaz
15 pas
compris pas c'est bon pasper merci
monsieur le Président alors c'est
toujours drôle de voir la droite essayer
de rétablir un dispositif qu'elle a
elle-même contribué à supprimer au
Parlement européen quoi qu'il en soit au
rassemblement national nous sommes
favorables au rétablissement du délit de
séjour irrégulier accompagné d'une
amende d'une peine d'emprisonnement
d'une peine complémentaire
d'interdiction du territoire français
qui devra inévitablement être suivi
d'une expulsion du territoire national
c'est aussi surprenant de voir qu'à
l'approche des élections européennes une
partie de l'anupes n'a pas suffisamment
de mots pour critiquer l'Union
européenne et quand il s'agit d'invoquer
une soi-disant inconventionnalité se
satisfait tout à fait des règles
idéologiques de l'Union européenne donc
puisque que face à cette situation on
invoque une
hypothétique inadéquation avec les
règles européennes et bien c'est
l'occasion pour nous de nous rappeler
que pour que les Français reprennent en
main la maîtrise de la politique
migratoire il faut un référendum sur la
question prend votre avil oui merci
Monsieur le le Président si évidemment
on on salue le fait de voir de nombreux
amendement pour supprimer ce délit ce
rétablissement d'un délit pour séjour
irrégulier euh je le dis vous avez aussi
euh une part de responsabilité
importante memrees de de la majorité
dans euh nombre d'articles qui en fait
sont des fabriques de clandestinité et
ça on le retrouve tout le long du texte
de fabriquer euh de nouveaux euh
clandestin de mettre des gens dans des
situations euh irrégulières alors euh
euh effectivement ce ce délit de séjour
irrégulier enfin à la fois il est euh
extrêmement cruel pour toutes les
personnes qui se retrouvent dans cette
situation à alors qu'ils aspirent à la
régularité mais je veux dire aussi à
quelques collègues qui seraient
peut-être qui auraiit été tenté de de ce
délit que imaginez des personnes qui
certes sont en séjour irrégulier sur le
territoire mais qui se retrouvent
victime d'agression victime de viol vous
les placez dans quelles conditions pour
pouvoir aller près de la police en
confiance porter plainte je mets donc au
vois les amendements de suppression non
non c'est bon j'ai non non j'ai monsieur
de la porte làelle n'est pas de droit et
il y a h intervenants donc ça suffit
non alors elle n'est pas elle elle n'est
pas de droit donc je vais la donner au
président marangelli mais après on
passera au vote Monsieur
marcangelli Merci monsieur le Président
le groupe horizon et apparenté votera
contre ces amendements de suppression en
effet la rédaction proposée par nos
collègues sénateurs ne vise pas à
rétablir le délit de séjour irrégulier
tel qu'il a été supprimé par la loi du
31 décembre 2012 ce dispositif est en
tout point conforme à la jurisprudence
de la CGU et son interprétation de la
directive de 2008 n sommes convaincus
qu'une personne restant sur notre
territoire à l'expiration de son visa
commet une infraction et celle-ci mérite
d'être sanctionné par une pte d'amende
et ce conformément à nos engagements
conventionnels donc maintenant on va
voter qui vote pour les amendements de
suppression qui vote
contre ils sont adoptés
oui ils sont adoptés
oui bis si si si c'est c'est le grand
sport national de contester depuis lundi
donc le 100 le 1158 de Monsieur
riman vous le défendez ou pas
oua ouais tout
fait
euh nous un article de de suppression un
amendement de suppression de de cet
article qui durcit les sanctions qui
sont applicable aux reconnaissan
frauduleuse de DEAT de paternité cet
article s fixe à 75000 € le montant de
l'amende qui est encouru par l'auteur
d'une reconnaissance frauduleuse nous
nous nous voulons la suppression de cet
article d'affichage qui vise à
stigmatiser les personnes étrangères et
s'inscrit nous le trouvons dans un
mouvement inquiétant pénalisation
croissante des
étrangers
alorsadame
Martin
Martin alors là aussi on est dans
pardon là aussi on est dans
l'accumulation comment dire de de tout
ce qui pourrait être reprocher à à un
individu on est dans tous les fantasmes
voilà je vais y arriver on est dans tous
les fantasmes
euh qui qui susciterait l'idée selon
laquelle on passe par tel et tel chemin
évidemment illégal évidemment trompeur
évidemment mensonger donc là en
l'occurrence c'est l'affaire de cette
paternité qui serait frauduleuse bon on
pourrait ça ouvre des tas de choses hein
dans nos esprits sur des situations de
ménage tout à fait français et tout à
fait bref fréquentable sans doute aux
yeux du du ministre de l'intérieur mais
évidemment j'arrête là immédiatement
cette cet écart bon bref quoi c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous demandons la
suppression je pense qu'il faut arrêter
de traiter le sujet des migration par
les angles les plus petits les plus
mesquins et considérer que tout ce qui
est de l'ordre quand même de l'exception
doit être considéré comme une règle
monsieur
Vallot lo bavard des dispositifs
inutiles
monsieur le rapporteur défavorable
monsieur le ministre
oui alors madame Youssouf monsieur
Kard madame Yousouf monsieur cardine ne
sont pas là mais il pourrait en vous
écoutant vous dire que je sais que vous
n'écoutez pas madame Martin maisvez
aucune considération
pour pour nos compatriotes Maoré parce
queil faut vraiment avoir jamais mis les
pieds à Mayotte il faut vraiment avoir
jamais eu à gérer une quelconque
question de fraude migratoire pour pas
s'apercevoir que ce dispositif est
extrêmement important parce que je vous
rappelle que notamment en ce qui
concerne Mayot qui fait face non c'est
pas affligeant madame Martin il faut
juste respecter les Maur Martin vous
avez eu la parole vousavez plus est-ce
que j'entends ce que j'entends c'est
surtout quelqu'un qui de ses certitudes
regarde des gens très loin en ayant la
main sur le cœur mais sans jamais
partager la contrainte et la difficulté
qui peut vivre plus de la moitié des
reconduites aux frontières de France se
déroule sur l'Î de donc c'est pas un
petit sujet ce n'est pas un petit sujet
je vous signale que à Mayotte pour être
régularisé il faut que l'un des deux
parents soit régulier ou français un
étranger régulier ou français l'un des
deux parents depuis 3 mois avant la
naissance de l'enfant ce qui fait naître
évidemment des fraudes documentaires et
des fraudes à la reconnaissance de
personnalité très nombreuses des
milliers madame Martin chaque année et
la police judiciaire non mais des
milliers madame Martin vous pouvez
parler sujet que vous ne connaissez pas
avec le mépris que vous avez
manifestement pour les mauris donc pour
les Français je voulais vous redire
madame Martin que la police judiciaire
de la République fait 50 50
interpellations 50 interpellations de la
dernière affaire sur les fraudes de
paternité qui permettent malheureusement
d'avoir un trafic et avec des pères qui
ont reconnu jusqu'à 120 enfants dans les
5 années qui ont qui ont précédé alors
soit effectivement ils sont oui mais
vous pouvez on peut rigoler voilà c'est
la vérité des faits voilà donc c'est
donc c'est donc c'est donc madame Martin
il faut que vous puissiez sortir un peu
de votre certitude un peu moins
d'idéologie un peu plus de pratique si
on veut lutter contre l'immigration
irrégulière et notamment le fait que des
personnes françaises ou des personnes
régulières fent de faux certificats de
paternité alors il faut continuer comme
ça donc je souscris pleinement
évidemment à ces disposition elle n'a
rien de risible elle est extrêmement
importante sur le territoire de la
République mais singulièrement à Mayotte
Mayotte est un département français nos
compatriotes Maoré ont besoin de qu'on
les aide c'est une disposition
extrêmement forte et je me refuse de les
voir moquer alors qu'ils vivent dans des
conditions très difficiles sur une
magnifique terre
française alors Monsieur di Philippo
merci monsieur le Président c'est quand
même incroyable que effectivement
l'idéologie de l'extrême gauche l'amène
à traiter avec dérision des faits avéré
des statistiques officielles présenté
fort justement par Monsieur le Ministre
à l'instant dans votre monde il n'existe
pas euh de mariage blanc il n'existe pas
de reconnaissance frauduleuse de
paternité tout ça vous le balayez et
vous n'imaginez pas à quel point vous
pouvez aggraver la situation de nos
capacités d'intégration qui sont
saturées dans les traitants de cette de
cette façon-là euh le et je pense que
vous savez rétablir des règles justes
rétablir des RG règles ferme c'est juste
favoriser l'intégration de ceux qui
respectent pleinement les règles de la
République et vous vous êtes simplement
dans un processus je ne sais pas j'ai
envie de dire quelque part anarchiste
qui vise à balayer toutes les règles à
balayer toutes les frontières et vous
n'imaginez pas à quel point c'est contre
les immigrés eux-mêmes que vous
jouez monsieur
[Musique]
vou moi je voudrais simplement qu' qui
nous soit précisé on quoi de passer de
15000 à 75000
€ aurait en effet un effet et dans et
dans quelle mesure cet effet
produirait il y a pas d'étude d'impact
donc est-ce que vous avez des chiffres
des éléments qui nous permettent de dire
qu'il y aurait comme on dit une
élasticité qui réduirait de façon
drastique les choses madame Martin non
mais je je je reprends mon propos je
redis et je l'assume que cette loi est
fondée non pas sur l'idée selon laquelle
il faudrait organiser
l'migration et l'accueil des exilés mais
elle est fondée dans des logites oui je
le maintiens xénophobe qui superpose
l'image de l'étranger à l'image du
délinquant et toute la loi est organisée
autour d'un certain nombre de faits qui
bien sûr peuvent avoir leur réalité
puisque je viens dire qu'il y a pas dans
ces cas-là que cela se produit mais qui
ne s'axe que sur les situations
particulières parlant de la crise de
l'accueil dans le pays ça ça aurait
quand même sans doute plus de sens sans
parler du caractère d'inefficacité ça
n'est pas en augmentant des amendes
qu'on réduit lesffet ça c'est non
seulement de la xénophobie mais en plus
de la
démagogie madame
yousoufa alors en l'occurrence pour
parler de la réalité que je peux
connaître la laïcité exige qu'on cesse
de croire à l'Immaculée Conception donc
en fait il faut être deux pour faire des
enfants donc il y a nécessairement un
papa quelque part donc à Mayotte comme
on voit des com arrivé par bateau on
imagine mal qu'elles ont fait qu'elles
ont fait un aller-retour pour aller
trouver un papa à maotte repartir au
Comor et puis revenir accoucher qu'en
fait nécessairement c'est un faux papa
qui est à Mayotte mais qui se fait en
moyenne entre 3000 et 5000 €. je
rappelle quand même que la la la
reconnaissance de paternité frauduleuse
ça ouvre des droits et que à Mayotte on
est maintenant avec des des enfants et
des femmes qui arrivent en disant j'ai
le certificat de mariage on sait que
c'est un faux papier mais on est e la
propriété les terres et les droits de
succession quand le bonhomme C fait son
dî en douce est décédé et là on voit
apparaître 10 20 héritiers qui on qui
ont payé 2000 ou 3000 € voilà la réalité
du
terrainpression Monsieur
mendz Merci monsieur le Président je
voulais revenir un peu sur les propos
qu'on entend je crois qu'il y a une
vraie mésentente l'objectif de ce texte
de loi chers collègues c'est quand même
de faire en sorte que on puisse limiter
toutes les tous les risques toutes les
filières exploitées par certains
passeurs c'est de lutter justement
contre la traite humaine vous devriez
être avec nous sur ce sujet-l vous
l'avez reconnu vous-même vous dites il y
a une minorité de personnes et alors si
cette partilà ne vise qu'une minorité de
personnes faisant en sorte que cette
minorité là ne puisse plus agir non plus
on est dans la protection des êtres
humains dans la protection des enfants
et de la femme en faisant cela on vient
de vous dire justement en parlant de
Mayotte que ça met en difficulté des
enfants des femmes quand on est
féministe on défend aussi ce genre de de
combat aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas
vous mélangez tous les sujets il n'y a
pas de xénophobie il n'y a pas de
racisme il y a lutter contre des dérives
de certaines lois qui existaient sur
l'asile et sur l'immigration pour mieux
accueillir pour mieux protéger et mieux
intégrer les Français et ça on en
parlera plus tard et on est ouvert à la
discussion avec vous et enfin Madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président alors
on parle ici donc nos collègues de la
nup c'est une partie de la majorité
veulent supprimer l'augmentation des
sanctions dans le cadre d'une
reconnaissance frauduleuse de
paternité les les arguments invoqués par
laanupes sont tout à fait lunaires on
nous dit ben en gros ils sont dans une
grande précarité donc ils ne pourront
pas payer bon ça c'est de la fatalité et
après ils nous disent oui mais s'ils en
sont arrivés là c'est parce qu'ils sont
en détresse psychologique ça c'est une
excuse qui n'est pas recevable on ne
peut pas légitimer la fraude et de par
votre amendement vous ne dissuadez pas
la commission d'infraction pire vous
l'encourage c'est irresponsable et même
je dirais j'irai plus loin je dirais que
c'est abject parce que vous soutenez
qu'on se serve d'un enfant pour obtenir
un titre de sa jour on peut apparenter
ça à un trafic d'êtres humains et en
matière d'humanisme pour nos collègues
de laanupes on repassera alors je vais
donner la parole au ministre mais il y a
aucun collègue de la majorité qui a
soutenu la suppression de ce dispositif
madame Diaz monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le Président je dirais
d'ailleurs à madame la députée du
rassemblement national que c'est un
amendement du groupe RDPI de Monsieur
beits et de de deux sénateurs Maoré qui
siègent le groupe RDPI c'est-à-dire
Renaissance au Sénat dont on doit à cet
article donc ne dites pas n'importe quoi
en effet si l'anupes veut le supprimer
c'est la majorité qui le veut cet
article dire peut-être à à Monsieur
valallot qu'aujourd'hui je B pour donner
quelques chiffres 20 % des cas de fraude
reconnus par les tribunaux en France en
général sont liés à des fraudes à la
paternité et 60 % dans le cas exact de
Mayotte en particulier c'estàdire que
non seulement on voit 20 % de fraude 1
5e qui sont à la FR la pernité c'est
déjà beaucoup mais c'est évidemment
extrêmement important pour les raisons
que j'ai évoqué à Mayotte et 3/4 des
refus de séjour pris par les préfet sont
liés à la fraude confirmé par les
tribunaux donc on voit bien que quand le
préfet refuse un titre de séjour il le
fait essentiellement pour documents
frauduleux et dont on sait qu'un 5e
c'est donc effectivement des sujets liés
à la perernité alors le problème c'est
que moin 15 % des dossiers en pénal
appliquent la condition d'emprisonnement
donc effectivement l'article
l8231 du code qui existe aujourd'hui qui
est puni de 5 ans d'emprisonnement et
15000 € d'amende et peu efficace
puisqu'on y met les amendes mais pas la
peine d'emprisonnement les tribunaux
font ce qu'ils souhaitent le juge est
libre de de condamner comme il l'entend
et on voit bien que ils utilisent l'arme
d'amende et pas l'arme d'emprisonnement
et donc ce que nous vous proposons c'est
pas l'alordissement du de la peine
d'emprisonnement c'est bien la la le
montant de l'amende pour casser
justement ce que disait madame la
députée Youssoufa le modèle économique
puisque comme madame musfa a dit à juste
titre qu'on est payé entre 3000 et 5000
€ par enfant lorsqu'on fait cette fraude
à la paternité et quand on attrape
quelqu'un on l'attrape pas à chaque fois
qu'il fait une fraude la paternité
évidment il y a un modèle économique qui
est malheureusement celui d'une partie
de personne français ou régulier il y a
évidemment des Français qui font ce ces
frudes documentaires donc il s'agit pas
de distinguer les étrangers qui seraient
coupablebl des Français qui seraient
innocents il y a évidemment des
délincants Français qui font cela qui
qui qui vendent effectivement leur
assentiment pour cela on pense que
l'amende de 15000 € si les choses
continuent ainsi notamment à Mayotte
trouve que le modèle économique vaut la
chandelle donc à 75000 € sachant qu'on
va pas alourdir la peine de prison qui
n'est déjà pas appliqué nous pensons que
c'est de nature à contrarier fortement
ce modèle économique qui à Mayotte et en
effet le première source la première
source d'immigration irrégulière donc
c'est vraiment très important d'avoir
cette disposition je pense que c'est
raisonnable puisqu'on ne vient pas
alourdir la peine de prison mais bien
alourdir l'amende puisqu'il s'agit bien
d'un modèle économique qu'il faut casser
ce texte de loi contrairement à ce qu'on
peut entendre il vise notamment à lutter
contre l'écosystème irrégulier on va
rentrer dans les articles principaux de
ce texte de loi monsieur le Président
puisquon va terminer avec les articles
imaginé par le Sénat l'écosystème
irrégulier c'est quoi c'est le patron
voyou c'est le système
d'autoentrepreneur qui est mal organisé
c'est le marchand de sommeil c'est le
passeur qui utilise l'argent mais c'est
aussi les les faux documents que l'on
vend lorsque on II de de prêter sa
signature et et son patronyme alors
qu'il n'y a aucun lien aucun lien avec
ces personnes avouez et ce n'est pas un
seul cas moi je suis prêt à fournir en
séance tous les informations dont je
dispose au ministère de l'Intérieur il y
a des pères qui sont pères de centaines
d'enfants par an sur l'île de maotte et
donc c'estchip de maotte et c'est
acceptable donc je dis à madame Martin
ça méritait ni vos rires ni vos insultes
vous ne connaissez manifestement pas le
sujet et je suis très heureux que cette
conversation a pu démontrer votre
idéologie donc on va voter sur ces
amendements de suppression
c'est pas le sujet qui vote pour les
amendements de
suppression qui vote contre ils sont
rejetés pour l'article qui vote pour
article 1er m qui vote contre il est
adopté amendement de suppression de
l'article 1er n monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président le le
Sénat a
choisi de supprimer l'accès à toutes les
prestations sociales non contributives
ou quasiment
pour les personnes en situation
régulière exigeant que elles aient
résidé 5 ans avant de pouvoir en
bénéficier l'idée même d'ailleurs
d'avoir un délai de carence
pour bénéficier d'un certain nombre de
prestation sociale non contributive
n'est pas en soit une hérésie je veux le
rappeler le gouvernement de Michel
Rocard lorsqu'il crée le revenu minimum
d'insertion introduit un délai de
carence à 3 ans qui ensuite a été à 5
ans pour le RSA pour les la prestation
de compensation du handicap le délai est
aujourd'hui de 6 mois il y a un délai de
carrence pour le minimum vieillesse pour
laaspa il y a un délai de carrence de 9
mois mais ce que propose le Sénat ça
n'est pas équilibré c'est une
suppression absolue pour les allocations
familiales les APL le droit au logement
la prestation compensation handicap je
viens d'en parler condition serait porté
de de 9 mois à 5 ans et pour les
allocations personnalité autonomie il
nous semble que ce
dispositif par nature intrredurer des
trappes à probeté à précarité et surtout
et plus grave encore pour des personnes
en situation
régulière régulière viserait
essentiellement à multiplier les
obstacles au parcours d'intégration
raison pour laquelle je vous propose
cette suppression j'ai déposé un
amendement identique monsieur le
rapporteur je le défends monsieur cast
non monsieur naen vous êtes pas
signataire je crois qu'il y a pas de
défenseur de l'amendement
617 le 646 madame au
non monsieur
Fernandez merci euh monsieur le
Président cet article qui vise à
conditionner l'ouverture des droits à
certaines prestations sociales à 5
années de résidence stable et régulière
est un autre supplice que souhait
infliger les sénateur du groupe LR aux
étrangers et qui va les plonger dans la
plus grande précarité en les privant de
tout moyen de subsistant y compris pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
par ailleurs les familles en situation
régulière devront cotiser pour des
prestations sociales auxquell elles
n'auront pourtant pas droit pendant 5
ans les prestations visées sont celles à
destination des enfants des personnes
porteuses de handicap et les prestations
destinées à lutter contre le mal
logement l'adoption de cet article
serait proprement indigne honteux et
j'appelle à mesurer l'impact dramatique
d'une telle décision alors que tous les
rapports pointent une pauvreté
grandissante particulièrement des
enfants puisque un des enfants vivant en
France sont en situation de pauvreté et
des mères isolé seraient alors les
premières victimes de cette de
l'adoption de cet article donc que
pourrait apporter un tel article s'il
était vraiment mis en œuvre à part
l'assurance tragique d'une recru
d'esence encore plus forte de la
pauvreté nous appelons donc à supprimer
cet article monsieur
Valou oui comme ça vient d'être indiqué
à l'instant par notre collègue il s'agit
là d'un des points
du texte qui a été introduit par la
droite sénatoriale donc nous espérons
que nous allons retrouver un peu de
raison même si l'attitude de la majorité
jusque-l nous a semblé quand même plutôt
aller dans le sens du durcissement opéré
par le Sénat ici il s'agit d'une des
choses les plus inconséquentes et
indignes parce que quand on demande
ans de présence à des personnes sur le
territoire pour avoir le droit à des
aide alors qu'elles ont légitimement le
droit parce qu'elles ont cotisé
notamment on est dans une AB totale et
dans une procédure qui est
discriminatoire je précise par ailleurs
parce que certaines personnes et je
parle notamment du rassemblement
national mais pas seulement veulent
conditionner les aides sociales de
manière générale à la nationalité il y a
des aides auquelles on a droit parce qu'
aussi on paye des impôts parce que on va
payer ne serait-ce que des taxes et ça
c'est le cas de toutes les personnes
étrangères qui sont présentes sur notre
territoire qui soit parce qu'ells ont un
travail soit parce qu'elles sont en
situation régulière madame Fillon
oui merci le le fait de conditionner des
des prestations sociale à à 5 ans de
présence sur le territoire c'est à coup
sûr une très grande augmentation de la
pauvreté vous voyez comme moi je crois
sur vos territoires à quel point déjà
des gens qui étaient dans des situations
de pauvreté décrochent vers la grande
pauvreté combien aujourd'hui les les
associations de solidarité se retrouvent
submergé de dem
combien dans nos permanences nous avons
des personnes qui aujourd'hui parlent
d'avoir faim combien dans notre pays il
y a d'enfant aujourd'hui en situation de
pauvreté voilà ce que viendrait encore
un peu plus aggraver un article tel que
celui-là qui repose uniquement sur une
théorie absolument fumeuse et abjecte
celle de l'appel d'air ou du shopping
social qui crée beaucoup de fantasme
alors même qu'elle est totalement sans
fondement il faut absolument supprimer
cet article
madame
chassagol merci un amendement de
suppression donc également au regard du
caractère discriminatoire de cet article
dans l'accès aux prestations sociales
sur le prétexte de l'origine et du
statut administratif de la personne
surtout il risquerait de provoquer une
grande précarité pour des étrangers en
situation régulière et vulnérabl puisque
les prestations concernent les enfants
les personnes en situation de handicap
des familles monoparentales qui
travaillent ou des personnes qui ont des
difficultés pour payer leur loyer le
risque très clairement d'Auger les
situations de sans ABR qui ne sont
acceptables pour
personne monsieur
banant monsieur monsieur Mandon oui
monsieur le Président oui en quelques
mots puisque déjà beaucoup de choses ont
été dites qu'on peut relever c'est que
manifestement cette disposition
introduite par le Sénat ne répond
absolument pas aux objectifs et aux
priorités du projet de loi qui se veut
être un texte équilibré et non pas un
texte qui crée de la précarité ou des
difficultés sachant que nous traitons
d'un sujet ici déjà compliqué et nous
sommes de manière je vais dire très
pragmatique et attachés à des principes
donc évidemment nous appelons au rejet
de cette
disposition Monsieur R merci monsieur le
Président je vais ajouter ma ma voix à
celle de mes collègues qui réclamament
la suppression euh de cet article
fragiliser encore paupériser toujours
que que ce soit pour le logement pour
les prestations familiales ou même pour
les aides aux personnes en situation de
handicap certains parlementaires n'ont
aucune honte à poser des conditions qui
excluent des personnes en raison de leur
origine demander 5 ans de présence sur
le territoire pour ces prestations
sociales c'est appauvrir c'est indécent
cette fois on ne parle pas d'une baisse
de 5 € de mois par mois des aPL mais de
la disparition de cette aide pour de
nombreuses personnes dont au premier an
les étudiantes et les étudiants c'est
une mesure injuste et inhumaine pour les
étrangers extra communautaire c'est une
mesure contraire à l'égalité de
traitement entre toutes et tous c'est
une mesure brutale et xénophobe ne
laissons pas passer le programme de
l'extrême
droite monsieur le
rapporteur favorable évidemment à ces
amend de suppression qui vont dans le
sens du du
mien alors madame
Genevard merci monsieur le
président alors le sens du bien il y a
pas le camp du Bien et le camp du mal
monsieur le rapporteur général moi je
voudrais vous faire état d'une d'une
visite que nous avons faite au
Danemark pour étudier la façon dont les
Danois découragent l'immigration
irrégulière et le détournement du droit
d'asile et ce qui fonde l'attitude des
Danois en la matière c'est deux choses
ils sont attachés à deux choses d'abord
à l'unité culturelle le population et
deuxièmement au système de solidarité et
je rappelle que c'est un gouvernement
social-démocrate un gouvernement de
gauche ce n'est pas un gouvernement de
droite avec des écologist avec des
écolog je rappelle aussi pour notre
collègue qu'une prestation non
contributive c'est une prestation qui
n'est pas fondée sur une
cotisation bien et donc proposons 5 ans
en effet afin de pouvoir bénéficier de
la solidarité
nationale Monsieur
goufier Merci monsieur le Président euh
le groupe Renaissance comme je l'avais
indiqué lors de la discussion générale
votera pour ces amendements de
suppression qui viennent toucher aux
prestations social de manière
disproportionnée de manière injuste
venant plonger encore plus dans la
difficulté un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens un certain nombre
d'étrangers qui sont présents sur notre
territoire euh nous devions avoir un
amendement de suppression c'est moi qui
ai raté euh euh le le dépôt en le
plaçant à mauvais endroit mais nous
voterons bien pour ces amendements de de
suppression madame
Touria merci euh monsieur alors on voit
vraiment dans le texte la la vision
raciste puisque cet article fait la
différence entre les étrangers non
européens et les étrangers européens
donc pour le dire en terme plus clair
excusez-moi il y a pas de jeu de mot les
étrangers blancs et ceux qui ne viennent
pas d'Europe qui viennent donc de
l'autre côté de la Méditerranée et qui
sont donc un peu plus brosé donc oui ce
texte est raciste et inscrit dans la loi
l'inégalité alors que notre devise
commence par liberté
égalité monsieur Lucas non
mais non
je est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut
poursivreit monés viend nous parler d'un
est-ce que vous pouvez laisser parler
monsieur Lucas je vous remercie monsieur
le présid cette autorité nous venons
d'entendre de la part d'une collègue du
rassemblement national que liberté
égalité fraternité ça ne s'appliquait
qu'au citoyens français non madame les
valeurs de la République elles
s'appliquent sur le territoire de la
République de façon indistincte et elles
sont belles ces valeurs et je le disais
ce matin à l'occasion d'un autre débat
mais quand on se proclame universaliste
encore faut-il avoir le souci de
l'universel et moi je suis effaré par
cet acharnement cet acharnement obsène
contre les étrangers vous allez encore
dans la mesquinerie absolue pour aller
priver de quelques droits pour aller
priver de quelques euros sur des
dispositifs qui sont des dispositifs
essentiels y compris de votre propre
point de vue pour s'intégrer y compris
pour pouvoir élever ses enfant y compris
pour pouvoir chercher du travail pour
pouvoir survivre tout simplement mais
qu'est-ce qui justifie cet acharnement
je m'interroge et c'est là où on voit
aussi ce racisme d'atmosphère pardon
mais oui qui s'est emparé de nos débats
et de ce texte monsieur
Guitton oui merci Monsieur le le le
président donc sur cet article 1 N de on
parle on parle de donner à des personnes
qui viennent d'arriver sur le sol juste
parce qu'elles seraient sur le sol des
minimas sociaux des aides au logement
des allocations familiales pour les
étrangers selon l'OCDE ça coûte 20
milliards par an de donner les minimas
sociaux l'aide au logement lesoc
familiales à des étrangers dès la
première année de résidence nous au
rassemblement national évidemment nous
soutiendrons cette cet article et donc
nous voterons contre les amendements de
rejet parce que tout simplement ça ça va
contre nos idées ça va contre notre
programme mais on propose même d'aller
plus loin pour nous il faut vivre en
France depuis 5 ans mais il faut aussi
travailler en France depuis 5 ans pour
pouvoir bénéficier de l'aide des minimas
sociaux de l'aide au logement ou des
allocations familiales car nous voulons
une immigration uniquement de travail et
sélective on ne peut pas aller au-delà
et nous voulons évidemment
proposer la priorité nationale pour
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes et
l'argent des Français doit aider avant
tout nos compatriotes et peut-être au
bout de 5 ans de travail des étrangers
qui seront en situation légale sur le
territoire et qui respectent la porte
oui j'ai pas entendu le ministre
positionner sur ce sur cet article mais
je vais comme on n pas la possibilité
d'échanger avec lui c'est dommage
puisqu'il va nous donner sa version et
derrière on pourra pas rebondir monsieur
le ministre au Sénat vous avez donné un
avis de sagesse sur cet article et je
trouve monsieur le ministre que cet avis
de sagesse aurait dû être un avis
d'hostilité à cet amendement parce qu'il
est contraire au principal disposition
non seulement de notre droit mais aussi
aux garanties conventionnelles et donc
je vais voilà non seulement faire part
de ma stupeur quand j'ai relu les débats
au Sénat et que j'ai découvert votre
avis de sagesse mais aussi rappeler à
nos collègues républicains qui doivent
en théorie respectecter les valeurs de
la République ça a été rappelé par mon
collègue Lucas que il y a eu un certain
nombre de décisions également de la
République française et du Conseil
d'État qui considérait que ces délaiis
étaient évidemment disproportionnés
mettrait des gens dans une situation de
misère terrible et contribuerait au
renforce
de la pauvreté en
France monsieur le
rapporteur mais simplement je voulais
répondre à à Madame jeunevard moi je
n'ai pas prétendu que vous
appartiendriez au au camp du mal et moi
au camp du Bien je pense que c'est
relativement étranger à ma conception
politique j'ai j'ai même j'ai même
rappelé que en tant que tel l'existence
de délai de carence ciblé exista et
c'est un gouvernement socialiste qui l'a
mis en place pour le revenu minimum
d'assertion 3 ans je n pas prétendu que
il y avait le bien le mal ce que ce que
je je je dis en revanche de la position
ce que je dis en revanche mais le RMI il
y a un délai de carrence en 1988 de 3
ans qui est porté à 5 ans au moment du
RSA et je pourrais ajouter que sur
l'ASPA c'est 9 mois et pour la
prestation de compensation handicap
c'est 6 mois bon donc c'est pas c'est
pas au fond l'existance de d carence qui
est une forme de vigilance qui peut
éventuellement s'appliquer c'est le
caractère général et absolu de position
du Sénat qui introduit une volonté je je
le dis comme je pense de précarisation
des parcours d'intégration et c'est cela
qui me semblait relativement grave et
donc mériter de ma part un amendement de
suppression monsieur le
ministre bien alors Monsieur de la porte
moi je me trouve bien dur avec le
gouvernement de François Hollande parce
que je vous rappelle que c'est le PLFSS
voté non non mais je trouve bien dur
avec le gouvernement de François
Hollande C p FSS 2016 voté en décembre
2015 qui a consacré les critères stables
et réguliers pour bénéficier des
prestations de sécurité sociale qui ont
été inscrites dans la loi des mesures
qui étaient auparavant du domaine
réglementaire et on parle pas que du RMI
monsieur le rapporteur général on va
vous donner la revue de détail qui
existeit encore lorsque étient en
responsabilité puisque les allocations
familiales c'est 6 mois résidence stable
le RSA le RSA le RSA c'est 5 ans ah bah
bah bah oui bah oui bah oui bah oui bah
quand on est dans l'opposition on est
humaniste quand on est dans la majorité
on est pragmatique manifestement hein
donc c'est 5 ans ça fait non mais oui
donc faut arrêter les faut arrêter les
débats sur l'inumanité parce que quand
on est en responsabilité on fait pas de
leçon de morale voilà et si et si
Bernard casduv manuel Vass Jean-Marc
kraud et et vous-même non mais attendez
et vous-même lorsque vous étiez en
responsabilité avez imaginé 5 ans avant
de verser le RSA à des étrangers je le
dis pour Madame la député non
communautaire parce que c'est 3 ans pour
les étrangers communautaires si vous
fait la discrimination c'est que ça ser
à quelque chose et je vous rappelle que
c'est votre gouvernement qui a fait 10
ans à Mayotte 10 ans à Mayotte et si
vous avez imaginé 10 ans de versation de
prestation sociale comme le RSA à
Mayotte c'est bien parce que vous avez
considéré que ça pouvait être une
utilité pour la République et je vous
fais pas de procès en inhumanité c'est
pareil pour les APL je rappelle qu' a
une condition de 8 mois par an sur sur
le sol national on surass pasa je
rappelle que c'est une résidence de 10
ans pour que les étrangers touchent ce
minimum donc le fait même comme ve dit
le rapporteur général que l'on distingue
français européens et international
n'est pas scandaleux en soi la question
est de connaître les délais il me semble
que l'amendement du Sénat correspondait
à trois difficultés la première c'est
qu'en effet c'est un cavalier législatif
pur une nouvelle fois il ne faisait pas
partie du texte initial nous parlons de
prestation social ce n'est pas le sujet
du code des étranger que nous faisons
ici il est déjà assez compliqué comme ça
de rformer les C des étrangers que on n
pas besoin d'en rajouter de évidemment
que les délais imposés par le Sénat
n'avaient pas de cohérence voilà et je
pense que on a essayé de le dire au
sénateur mais prévoir de passer de 6
mois à 10 ans passer de 6 mois à 10 ans
à certain de prestation n'avait pas de
sens voilà et on leura dit dans le débat
et troisièmement évidemment que nous
sommes absolument opposés à ce que
lorsquil y a des prestations contributiv
on distingue pas les personnes selon
cestion contributives c'est pas le cas
du RSA c'est pas le cas de l'ASPA mais
c'est évidemment le cas de tout autre
prestation qui relèv de cotisation du
fruit de leur travail là les sénateurs
en effet je crois ne sont d'abord ce
serait pas institutionnel sans aucun
doute mais par ailleurs ne
correspondrait pas à ce qu'on souhaite
sans doute c'est la valeur travail je
terminerai par dire que nous sommes plus
pour le travail que pour les prestations
manière générale c'est pour ça que
j'invite le groupe les républicains de
voter le la restauration d'article 4 qui
prévoit de substituer l'ADA qui est une
prestation sociale au revenu du travail
puisquon peut pas à la fois défendre
c'est pour ça qu'on en discuta tout à
l'heure le fait qu'on doit donner moins
de prestation sociale pour que les gens
vivent du fruit de leur travail et leur
refuser de travailler quand ils pourrai
le faire quand ils pourrai le faire donc
il faudrait qu'on ait une cohérence dans
la discussion et je regrette que le
Sénat n'a pas été n'it pas été cohérent
donc je pense que on peut discuter des
prestation sociales pour les étrangers
comme pour les Français qu'il soient
communautaires ou étrangers ça a
tellement été vrai que ça a été fait par
tous les gouvernements qui l'ont
confirmé et surtout par le gouvernement
socialiste que vous souteniez à l'époque
on peut aussi considérer qu'il n'y a pas
il y a à distinguer le contributif non
contributif ce que fait malheureusement
pas le le Sénat et donc évidemment pour
toutes ces raisons et en premier lieu
parce que il y a pas eu de débat qui
relève en effet de de de je crois d'un
travail plus profond d'étude d'impact et
et d'accompagnement social sur les
territoires qu'on pe d'Illes distinguer
sur les endroits et notamment pour les
outres mes il faut évidemment renvoyer
ces discussions si elle a lieu dans un
autre
texte c'est pas dans le texte on va
passer au vote mais c'est un vote par
scrutin public qui m'a été demandé alors
je savez que ça vous je savis que ça
vous
manquait est-ce que tout le monde est
prêt
alors on va pouvoir on vote on vote sur
les amendements de suppression pour la
suppression de l'article 1er n donc ceux
qui voteront pour c'est pour la
suppression ceux qui votent contre c'est
contre madame
avadi pour Monsieur balanan pour
Monsieur bobbri contre Monsieur
bernalicis n'est pas là madame
bord monsieur
Boucard il est pas là Monsieur bouer
pour pour Madame
brocard pour Monsieur Castellani n'est
pas là euh Monsieur Madame
Chandler n'est pas là madame chassagol
pour pour Monsieur soti n'est pas là
Monsieur coulom pour pour madame de cots
pour pour Madame déjonkerer n'est pas là
madame
Diaz contre Monsieur Dumont n'est pas là
madame fossillon pour Monsieur fernandz
pour pour Madame
jeunevard contre Monsieur gilet cont
contre Monsieur goselin n'est pas là
Monsieur Goufi Valante pour pour Madame
gevnou pour pour Monsieur Guiton contre
Monsieur olliier pour Monsieur
housoussin contre madame jacqu et
Laforge pas là madame kerbidi pas là
madame caramand pas là Monsieur latombe
pour pour Monsieur Le Gendre pour pour
Monsieur léomand pas là madame
lebeec madame
lurau monsieur Lucas
pour pour Monsieur Mandon pour Monsieur
marcangéi pas là madame Martin pour
Monsieur
ménager pas là madame Ménard
contre Monsieur
mendz pour Madame Miller pas là Monsieur
madamechou
pour monsieur
nagelen abstention madame obono pas là
Monsieur Poget cont contre euh monsieur
pèlerin pour Monsieur
pont contre ah pour
euh monsieur porte pas là Monsieur
pouliia pour pour Madame poussier
vincebac pour Monsieur Pradal pour pour
Monsieur Pradier n'est pas là Monsieur
Rambo
contre Monsieur Remy reberot pas là
madame rol pour
pour Madame
riman pour Monsieur ran pardon
excusez-moi madame
Roulot contre madame Rousseau pour
Monsieur rudigz pour monsieur saintoule
n'est pas là Monsieur Solignac
pour monsieurberg pas là monsieur
contre Monsieur serv pas
Mad pas Madame
T pour Monsieur
Terlier pour Madame pas monsieur V pour
Monsieur
pour pas donc le vote est terminé j'ai
34 pour contre 13 contre les amendements
sont
adoptés
il supprime l'article 1er n il font
tomber tous les amendements suivants de
sorte que nous allons appeler ensuite
l'amendement numéro 190 de Madame
lechanteux merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur il s'agit pour cet amendement
de remplacer le mot intégration par le
mot assimilation en effet le terme
intégration est un terme bien trop
limité et insuffisant pour décrire le
processus d'entrée dans la communauté
nationale le groupe rassemblement
national propose donc d'utiliser à la
place le terme assimilation car il
véhicule une dimension essentielle
c'est-à-dire l'adhésion totale aux
valeurs fondamentales de notre pays et à
sa culture le terme intégration suggère
une incorporation partielle à la
communauté nationale sans nécessairement
viser une homogénéité culturelle en
revanche l'assimilation que nous
proposons implique un engagement
réciproque entre l'individu et la
communauté nationale elle va au-delà de
l'incorporation partielle et nécessite
une adhésion complète aux valeurs qui
fondent notre identité nationale la
cohésion de notre société exige le
partage de valeurs communes en optant
pour le terme assimilation nous
affirmons clairement notre volonté de
promouvoir une société unie par des
fondements culturels et des valeurs
partagé chers collègues je vous appelle
à voter cet amendement car il incarne la
défense de ce qui fait notre nation et
notre République je vous remercie
défavorable madame
Martin non mais simplement pour dire que
l'assimilation correspond à un modèle
qui est assez précis c'est-à-dire le
modèle qui vise à gommer toutes les
différences et à considérer de surcroix
qu'une
culture originalement considéré comme
française serait supérieure et que
d'aucun quel qu'il soit devrait devrait
s'y rallier ça n'a pas de sens ça
n'existe pas de sur croix ça ne corrond
correspond pas à l'histoire de France la
France et le peuple français s construit
par créolisation c'est-à-dire que à
chacune des arrivées quel qu'elle soit
et ça se joue à toutes les échelles de
groupes quel que soit leur taille et
bien chacun est venu en quelque sorte
apporter sa pierre à l'édifice et par sa
pierre à ladfice est venu transformer
euh une situation une situation disons
première et nous nous sommes convaincus
que c'est cette créolisation euh qui a
permis au peuple français d'être un
grand
peuple monsieur
ran merci président au titre de se
répéter par rapport au débat qui lieu ce
matin en commission j'aimerais juste
rappeler au collègues du rassemblement
national que l'assimilation n'a rien à
voir avec l'intégration d'accord
l'assimilation c'est l'effacement de
l'autre son histoire sa culture tout ce
qui le représente vous l'effaceer au
détriment d'une autre culture d'une
autre histoire ce que vous faites là
extrêmement grave vous ne pouvez pas
parler d'assim nation aujourd'hui en
France avec l'histoire que connaît ce
pays-là je répète encore je suis sur des
territoires d'autre mè nous avons subi
l'assimilation vous ne pouvez pas
demander à inscrire ça dans ce texte là
c'est ignob de votre part et vous ne
mesurez pas l'impact que ça sur tout des
peuples qui sont pas dans l'Hexagone et
même ceux qui sont dans l'Hexagone c'est
ignob ce que vous faites je répète mes
mots c'est ignob ce que vous faites
madame le chante on v merci simplement
je vous invite tout simplement à
consulter le mot dans le dictionnaire
comme ça vous comprendrez à quel point
vos mensonges sont honteux je vous
remercie alors on va voter qui vote pour
qui vote contre rejeté on passe à
l'article 1er enfin Madame chat non qui
défend l'amendement des
écologistes l'amendement des écologistes
qui le défend monsieur Lucas madame
Rousseau merci monsieur le le président
cet amendement de la présidente de
châelin vise à ne pas conditionner la
première délivrance d'une carte de
séjour pluriannuelle à la réussite d'un
examen de français euh d'abord un devoir
de réussciteer un examen ne permet pas
d'apprendre mieux le français c'est avec
un accompagnement des formations
linguistique de qualité que les
étrangers hophones s'approprieront
pleinement notre langue par ailleurs
nous partons du postulat main de fois
vérifier que les étrangers mettent déjà
tout en œuf pour apprendre le français
je vous le dis personne ne souhaite
souhaite ne pas être compris quand il va
au supermarché quand il prend les
transports quand il achète son titre de
transport avec la réduction tarifaire
que nous allons préserver j'espère
monsieur valallot rien
dire oui c'est
évidemment le même le même argument et
avoir un commentaire sur le mot
intégration mot assimilation au fond
c'est l'impensée de l'extrême droite la
relation entre le
particulier et mais quand même
commentaire et et l'universel et on sera
t du côté de céser plutôt que de celui
de Jean-Marie Le Pen
intéressantme intéressant monsieur ran
ou madame F madame fon
alors alors vous êtes dissipé il est 19h
là bientôt vous êtes dissipé c'est pas
encore l'heure de goûter donc allez-y
madame fossillon il fallait prendre le
goûter à la
pause la connaissance du du français
nous nous pensons et nous le répétons
c'est vraiment indispensable pour pour
s'intégrer et d'ailleurs beaucoup de
personnes venues de l'étranger tout au
long de leur parcours souhaitent pouvoir
continuer à apprendre le français parce
que les cours qui sont dispensés au
départ dans le cadre du contrat
d'intégration républicaine en réalité ne
suffisent pas à la connaissance de la
langue française et il manque
aujourd'hui beaucoup de moyens à des
associations à des centres sociaux pour
répondre à la demande de beaucoup de
gens qui souhaitent apprendre le
français j'ai un centre social à côté de
chez moi il y a 300 personnes sur la
liste d'attente pour continuer à
apprendre le français ils veulent
apprendre au cours de leur vie mais ce
qu'on pense c'est que c'est pas une
injonction ça suffit pas en fait ça ne
sert à rien l'injonction il y a une
volonté à apprendre en revanche
conditionner et donc trier les étranger
par ça ça n'a aucun sens en réalité
d'autant plus parce que en réalité ils
ont envie de pouvoir le faire il faut
créer les conditions pour qu'ils
puissent le faire tout au long de leur
vie sur le
territoire
alors monsieur le rapporteur oui merci
Monsieur le le président d'abord je
rappelle je l'ai déjà dit au cours de
nos précédent échanges quel est le
gouvernement qui en 2016 considère qu'il
faut faire de l'apprentissage du
français une des conditions de
l'intégration dans notre pays c'est le
le gouvernement de François Hollande
dire donc les mêmes qui aujourd'hui
reproche à cette majorité de vouloir
renforcer les parcours d'intégration par
la langue ont voté en 2016 quand ils
étaient députés une disposition dans le
contrat d'intégration républicaine qui
prévoit cette même disposition la
différence
c'est que nous voulons passer d'une
obligation de moyen à une obligation de
résultat mais attention
attention la disposition qui est
introduite ici à l'article 1er elle vise
la délivrance des cartes de séjour
pluriannuel je le répète parce que je
suis pas sûr que cela a été compris
c'est l'obligation de résultat pour la
délivrance de la carte de séjour
plurannuel et donc ça veut dire que
avant la délivrance de la carte de
séjour plurannuel la personne a été
inscrite dans le contrat d'inétion
d'intégration républicaine dans lequel
il y a là par contre une obligation de
moyens et le Sénat propose d'ailleurs de
renforcer la formation civique sur
l'histoire et la culture nous verrons
que il y a un amendement Renaissance qui
compte aller beaucoup plus loin sur les
principes et valeurs de la République
donc je ne comprend pas ce refus qui
devrait nous rassembler qui devrait nous
unir de faire de la langue le ciment
commun de la communauté et quelle que
soit la nationalité des uns et des
autres donc avis défavorable monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le Président alors je me
réjouis que l'on puisse enfin commencer
par un article du texte proposé par le
gouvernement puisque nous sommes à
l'article 1er c'est pas pour rien que
cet article premier et le premier celui
de la langue l'intégration par la langue
c'est la condition de pouvoir vivre
travailler vivre pleinement dans le pays
qui vous accueille alors cet article est
très important parce qu'il vise à
révolutionner d'une une part mais aussi
transformer l'essai d'autre part de ce
qu'on essayie de faire les gouverement
précédent et vous avez parfaitement
raison monsieur le rapporteur général
dans la loi cas neu il y avait
clairement écrit que et c'était aussi
son article 1er l'exigence de
connaissance de langue française était
importante elle était exigée en fixant
l'objectif de niveau A1 au bout d'un an
de résidence et vers le niveau A2 au
terme des 5 année suivant l'arrivée en
France simplement le gouvernement de
Monsieur casn et le Parlement à l'époque
n'avait pas prévu la vérification de cet
objectif qui d'imposer aux étrangers sur
le sol national et que prévoyons-nous
nous prévoyons que pour les titres en
effet pluriannuels c'està-dire les
titres qui permettent de rester
plusieurs années de suite sur le
territoire national je dis pour ceux qui
nous écoutent il puisse y avoir un
examen de français et cet examen de
français alors aujourd'hui le
législateur a souhaité que ce soit
inscrit dans la loi je rappelle que
l'avis du Conseil d'État qui d'ailleurs
a validé intégralement cette disposition
proposée par le gouvernement prévoit
expressément que ça doit être du niveau
réglementaire mais cet examen de
français il va permettre de conditionner
ou pas le titre pluriannuel et ça c'est
très important parce qu'aujourd'hui il y
a un/ers on l'a déjà dit d'étrangers qui
sont sur le sol national de façon
régulière et qui parlent très mal ou qui
comprennent très mal le français et donc
ainsi se répercutent des possibilités
évidemment de communautarisme des
difficultés d'exclusion des difficultés
aussi de chômage puisqu'on sait aussi
qu'il y a une surreprésentation du
chômage parmi les étrangers g régulière
du fait notamment de leur difficulté à
se faire comprendre ou ou à parler je
rappelle dans cette mesure vous n'avez
pas dit Monsieur rapporteur général que
ne sont pas concernés évidemment les
étudiants pour faire le débat tout à
l'heure ni même les saisonniers qui
viennent quelques mois par an parfois
pour travailler notamment dans le monde
agricole ils viennent évidemment toucher
en premier lieu tous ceux qui veulent
venir de façon pluriannuelle ça veut
dire 70000 personnes par an on a quand
même passé beaucoup de temps sur
regroupement familial pour 12000 à 14000
personnes là il s'agit de 70000
personnes par rend donc la première
immigration de notre pays qui se verrait
conditionner un examen de français et le
le le stock pardon de parler ainsi de
per nombre de personnes qui sont
concernées c'est 400000 et nous
prévoyons aussi que ces 400000 personnes
lors qu'ils vont renouveler leur titre
pluriannuel pour ce sera moins difficile
parce qu'ils auront passé évidemment
plusieurs années déjà sur le sol
national passe également cet examen de
français c'est-à-dire que d'ici la fin
du quinquena du président de la
République l'intégralité des étrangers
en situation régulière avec des titres
plus annuels auront passé cet examen de
français alors quels sont les moyens
parce que je peux comprendre la question
de Madame fossillon bien volontiers euh
je je veux faire marquer à Madame
fossillon d'abord que nous avons
augmenté de façon considérabl les moyens
pour l'intégration et les cours de
langue déjà puisque vous avez voté vous
le Parlement français la lopmie qui
prévoyait 25 % de crédit d'augmentation
d'intégration plus de 100 millions
d'euros 100 millions d'euros sur les 4
ans qui restent du quinen pour pouvoir
notamment faire face aux
exigenceintégration et que j'ai accepté
un amendement de Monsieur brossa euh qui
j'espère sera validé également à
l'Assemblée nationale qui prévoit la
gratuité totale des cours et pour tous
et euh je pense en effet que cet argent
en plus avec la gratuité de ses cours
permettra de pouvoir répondre à votre
question alors ensuite cet article 1 va
avec l'article 2 et on en parlera aussi
dans quelques instants c'est quoi
l'article 2 c'est pour ceux qui
embauchent des étrangers dans Primot
arrivant ils devront désormais laisser
dans le temps de travail le temps de
prendre ses cours parce que l'une des
difficultés madame la députée vous le
savez bien c'est que les étrangers qui
veulent évidemment apprendre le français
personne n'en fait ce ce grillf là et
c'est très difficile bien évidemment
aend une langue qu'on connaît pas ou
qu'on connaît très mal le font en dehors
de leurs Hees de cours dans des
conditions parfois de travail très
difficiles et qui ne leur donneent pas
la possibilité de pouvoir réussir
pleinement évidemment cet examen et et
donc on verra qu'il y a une cohérence
dans tout le de titre premier à la fois
de gratuité des cours à la fois de
grandes exigences vis-à-vis en effet des
étrangers et en même temps bah d'exigen
demandé au patron notamment avec de 1 %
intégration que l'on exige et en tout en
tout cas moi je veux souligner
l'importance de cet article premier dans
le changement très fort de nos exigences
vis-à-vis des étrangers qui veulent
venir dans notre pays qui nous permettra
de mieux maîtriser non seulement
l'immigration sur notre sol donner les
moyens à ceux qui sont acceptés de
pouvoir mieux s'en sortir si je dire
dans notre pays et surtout troisièmement
de pouvoir avoir et c'est très important
une capacité d'intégration qui n'est pas
simplement dans l'objectif mais et bien
sûr dans les
résultats monsieur di Philippo merci
monsieur monsieur le Président c'est
quand même incroyable effectivement de
voir à nouveau cet article remis en en
cause au nom de la soi-disant
stigmatisation des des des étrangers
encore une fois vous ne rendez pas
service aux immigrés on ne parle pas de
condition exigée pour une demande
d'asile ou pour un répicé ou pour une
première demande de titre de séjour on
parle d'une demande pluriannuelle qui
peut permettre de rester jusqu'à 10 ans
sur notre sur notre sol ça a été dit
très bien dit si vous voulez pouvoir
vous intégrer mais surtout si vous
voulez aussi que vos enfants à un moment
donné et une chance bien de réussir
comme les autres à l'école et de
s'intégrer la maîtrise de la langue
française est un fondement ensuite
puisque vous considérrez que le mot
d'assimilation toujours est un gros mot
qui renvoie à des termes racistes je
vous rappelle que soyez un peu légaliste
chers collègues de de la gauche ou de
l'extrême gauche il est présent dans le
Code civil article 2124 nul ne peut être
naturalisé s'il ne justifie de son
assimilation à la Communauté française
et il y a une circulaire du Conseil
d'État qui a précisé ce qui était
l'assimilation elle suppose une adhésion
aux règles de fonctionnement et aux
valeurs de tolérance de laïcité de
liberté et d'égalité de la société
française alors si vous trouvez que ça
c'est raciste je crois qu'on ne peut
plus aller beaucoup plus
loin monsieur
Valot simplement qu'il n'y ait pas de
confusion nous sommes absolument
convaincus que le français est un
vecteur d'intégration absolument
considérable là où nous exprimons plus
qu'un doute c'est dans l'obligation de
résultats l'étude d'impact dit qu'il y
aura entre 15000 à 20000 étrangers qui
pourrai ne pas réussir à atteindre ce
niveau et donc se se voir refuser la
carte de séjours pluannuel c'est 40 %
supplémentaire par ailleurs nous savons
la simade le précise que il y a des
territoires entiers dans lequels n'y a
pas de centre de formation où les délais
d'attente sont absolument considérables
et donc le risque c'est que plutôt que
ce soit un facteur d'intégration ce soit
un facteur de précarisation de ces
travailleurs dans séance je je
regarderai les uns et les autres avec un
peu DESP que nous avons fait comme
première langue avec beaucoup d'heures
entre la 6e et la terminale
d'enseignement et nous verrons si nous
sommes capables de répondre aux
questions qui sont posé à ceux auxquels
on réclame le niveau le niveau A2 je
suis sûr en tout cas moi je sais que
pour un certain nombre de langues que
j'ai étudié j'en serai bien
incapable mais on a besoin de moyens
vous avez évoqué la question des
réfugiés il faut 16 mois pour un
réfugier en général pour commencer
monsieur
Lucas merci président le président allô
à à tout dit moi je me demande si nos
compatriotes qui vivent à Marrakech
l'État marocain exige d'eux un niveau
d'arabe parfait ou en tout cas tel que
tel que vous voulez l'exiger mais c'est
vrai que là on nappelle pas ces gens-là
des immigrés on les appelle des
expatriés là aussi vous avez une
conception des frontières à géométrie
variable ou à géographie variable si si
je puis je puis dire je le redis mes
chers collègues euh oui la langue est un
facteur d'inclusion bien sûr c'est
pourquoi nous nous devons mettre les
moyens suffisants nécessaires et massifs
pour que chacune et chacun puisse le
parler et le comprendre correctement le
français mais connaissez-vous quelqu'un
c'est pour ça que la mesure elle est
stigmatisante et discriminante et
qu'elle vise à faire du tri je ne
connais personne qui veut ne pas être
compris là où il vit qui veut ne pas
être compris là où il élève ses enfants
là où il va faire ses courses là où il
accède au transport là où il accède à un
emploi personne donc on voit bien le
fond encore une fois le racisme
d'atmosphère qui préside à ce texte
encore dans cette article il
transparaît madame tour oui merci alors
moi je voudrais vous dire que j'étais
enseignante jusqu'à jusqu'à mon élection
ça n'est pas parce que on met un examen
que forcément on apprend mieux
l'apprentissage n'a rien à voir le fait
de mieux maîtriser la langue s'il vous
plaît je voudrais bien parler dans le
silence le le le fait le fait de
maîtriser la langue n'a rien à voir avec
un examen donc c'est pas parce que vous
allez mettre un examen que les gens vont
mieux maîtriser le français c'est
complètement absurde et en plus c'est
complètement hypocrite dans le même
temps où votre collègue monsieur
Darmanin votre collègue de l'éducation
nationale est en train de sacager
complètement l'enseignement du français
langue étrangère avec les up DEA qui ont
été territorialisés et qui sont
complètement complètement exent
complètement submergés par les demandes
donc quand quand vous nous aviez invité
je vous avais proposé de vous mettre en
rapport avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale parce que si vous voulez
vraiment faire en sorte que les
étrangers apprennent le français il faut
vraiment que vous travaillez avec votre
collègue du ministre de l'Éducation
nationsieur
ny merci monsieur le Président le le
français la la langue nationale est le
parfait vecteur
d'intégration et il
on a besoin d'avoir une obligation de de
résultat sur sur sur la langue vous
savez on croit profondément à
l'intégration par le travail à
l'émancipation par le travail la
problématique qu' y a quand vous avez
des étrangers qui ne maîtrise pas la
langue ils se ferment deux même à un
certain nombre de potentiel de potentiel
métier de potentiel travail et donc si
on le veut qu'il puisse s'intégrer si on
veut qu'il puisse participer à la commun
communauté nationale il est nécessaire
qu'il y ait une certaine connaissance
voire une maîtrise de cette langue et
celle-ci doit être finalisé par un un
résultat par le résultat d'un d'un test
sur cette bonne connaissance donc c cet
article là c'est la base même de ce que
doit être ce projet de loi et bien
entendu nous vterons contre ces
amendements de suppression madame bord
oui merci monsieur le Président alors je
partage tout à fait ce que vient de dire
le collègue nelen parce que
effectivement maîtriser la langue
française est tout à fait fondamental
pour les nouveaux arrivants et proposer
la suppression effectivement de de de de
cet article me paraît relever de
personnes qui n'ont jamais qui ne sont
jamais sortis de leur circonscription
aller à l'étranger aller à l'étranger
demander effectivement à séjourner
demander à séjourner en Colombie
Britannique ou en Ontario vous verrez le
niveau à la fois de langue qu'on vous
demande on vous demande également des
notions poussé
de culture du pays des notions poussées
d'histoire du pays et ça effectivement
quand vous maîtrisez ces paramètres vous
pouvez faire nation avec les personnes
qui sont issues effectivement de ce pays
mais demander exiger un niveau
minimum de français ne me paraît pas
effectivement permettre que notre pays
fasse nation avec les nouveaux
arrivants madame
gevennou madame Martin madame déà parl
simplement une intervention pour
apporter évidemment le soutien du groupe
Renaissance à cet article dont le
ministre a rappelé le caractère
essentiel pour le projet de loi il
s'agit comme ça a été rappelé de
permettre de faire en sorte que les
titres les cartes de séjour pluriannuel
qui sont donné donc pour des longs
séjours soient conditionné à un niveau
de français pourquoi c'est important
monsieur nagelan l'a dit l'intégration
par la langue l'intégration par la
langue elle est fondamentale elle permet
de travailler elle permet de d'accomplir
des formalités administratives elle
permet de faire société elle permet de
s'établir à long terme et quand monsieur
le ministre vous dites que un/ers des
des étrangers en situation régulière ne
maîtrise pas la langue et bien le fait
au fond de d'avoir cet examen c'est
aussi ça aussi a une vertu incitative
dès lors que les moyens sont mis en
parallèle et c'est bien ce que vous avez
expliqué monsieur le ministre avec
milliur mis sur les moyens
d'apprentissage de la langue merci merci
alors on va voter les amendements de
suppression qui alors pardon monsieur le
ministre vous vouliez réagir oui en de
en deux mots d'abord pour répondre
peut-être à Monsieur Lucas et à Monsieur
valallot qu'est-ce qu'il font si jamais
il ratent cet examen et bien il le
repasse il s'agit pas d'expulser les
étrangers puisqu'ils ont des titres vous
avez évoqué de savoir qu'est-ce qui se
passe bon ils ont des titres ils ont des
titres aujourd'hui de séjour d'un an il
n pas cet examen il comme d'autes pays
il le au bout d'un certain temps en
effet si quelqu'un ne prend pas ses
cours si quelquun ne passe pas l'examen
se pose la question du renouvellement du
titre mais c'est trois fois par exemple
en Allemagne donc c'est l'accès au titre
pluriannuel c'est pas l'accès au titre
tout court je pense que c'est quand même
pas quelque chose de très très compliqué
à comprendre deuxièmement monsieur Lucas
on demande pas qu'il parle un français
parfait et ni un niveau de LV1 ou de LV2
même si manifestement il vous a rien
resté de vos cours
précédents le niveau A2 vous le savez
très bien c'est pas un niveau très
important c'est le même niveau monsieur
Lucas je le dis non mais je le dis je le
dis parce que c'est même niveau que
deande alors attention l'Autriche le
Danemarc l'Allemagne les Pays-Bas la
Slovénie l'Italie Chypre République
tchèque Malte Lettonie Lituanie Portugal
Pays-Bas et Croatie VO donc c'est très
oui oui il y a beaucoup de vos amis
là-dedans et notamment je rappelle que
le gouvernement allemand est gouverné
également avec une coalition verte c'est
il faut donc faire attention à vos à vos
comparaisons pour dire qu'on est
vraiment très très inhumain et je
terminerai par dire que j'ai vraiment du
mal à comprendre le débat qui consiste à
dire qu'on veut que les étrangers
parlent français qu'on leur offre du
coup des des cours gratuits qu'on va
obliger les employeurs à leur offrir
cette possibilité parce que là où vous
avez raison c'est qu'il y a des endroits
où on a des que d'attente très
importants pour passer dans des
associations ou des lieux où on doit
prendre ses cours mais ce ce ce sujet
sera réglé en très grand partie par le
travail que nous faisons là qui consiste
désormais à obliger l'employeur il
faudra voter l'article 2 à donner P dans
son travail le temps pour prendre ses
cours donc on va changer complètement la
façon dont les choses vont vont
fonctionner pour l'intégration
objectivement je crois qu' devrait y
avoir une grande unanimité pour un grand
bon sens d'adopter cette disposition qui
va permettre et à l'état et aux
étrangers d'avoir une meilleure
immigration et mieux accueillir les
personnes donc cette fois on vote les
amendements de suppression qui vote pour
qui VE vot contre
rejeté les amendements suivants monsieur
Solignac
876 merci monsieur le Président par cet
amendement nous souhaitons attirer votre
attention sur la situation particulière
des femmes dont on sait que elles sont
davantage représenté parmi celles et
ceux qui sont victimes
d'analphabétisme ou de de manque de
qualification et donc à travers cet
amendement il s'agit de renforcer les
mesures d'intégration alur g en
soutenant l'accès à l'apprentissage de
la langue à l'information sur les droits
à la formation et à
l'emploi vous voulez défendre le suivant
monsieur
Solignac celui de monsieur Brun le
suivant de monsieur Brun qui est donc
l'amendement
874 et que je vais défendre bien
volontiers c'est l'amendement qui pose
des questions sur la la pertinence de la
formation qui est actuellement proposée
par l'OFI formation est essentiellement
écrite et donc pas forcément adaptée
parce que la dimension orale de
l'apprentissage de la langue doit être
développée en sachant qu'évidemment
c'est le premier facteur d'intégration
et c'est donc l'objet de de cet
amendement que de demander dans les mois
suivant la promulgation du du texte un
rapport au Parlement évaluant l'intérêt
que pourrait représenter une réforme des
méthodes d'apprentissage monsieur le
rapporteur vos avis oui merci je peux
évidemment pas acceptter le CL 874
puisque en réalité c'est un amendement
de suppression masqué n'est-ce pas chers
collègues il écrase totalement l'article
1er et le vote sur la suppression si si
il réécrit la totalité de l'article 1er
et sur le l'amendement 876 d'abord je je
constate des contradictions mon cher
collègue lorsque nous avons parler de
l'apprentissage du français pour les
femmes issues du regroupement familial
et que nous avons pointé la nécessité de
d'aller vers l'émancipation lorsque elle
pouvait être présente sur le territoire
national vous étiez défavorable là vous
souhaitez aborder ce sujet qui est déjà
prévu dans les contrats d'intégration
républicaine évidemment qu'il y a des
formations pour signaler souligner le
principe d'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes donc vous êtes satisfait de
ce point de vue
défavorable Monsieur
mendz Merci monsieur le Président non je
je voulais just dire à notre collègue
souign que son amendement paraissait
intéressant et intelligent sauf que
quand on a eu ce débat hier
malheureusement vous étiez contre
l'accompagnement des familles qui sont
souvent les femmes et les enfants à la
langue française pour arriver sur le
territoire pour le regoupement familial
là vous voulez faire une distinction
entre les hommes et les femmes alors que
le titre de séjour est bien à la
personne et il est pas donné à un homme
pour l'ensemble de la famille donc les
femmes ont les mêm droit que les hommes
et on a besoin d'accompagner
correctement ces formations et la
réalité c'est ce que je disais hier j'ai
une grand-mère qui a passé 50 ans en
France sans pouvoir parler le français
sans pouvoir aller chez le médecin pour
se soigner tout seul sans pouvoir
commander une baguette de pain tout
toute seule et la réalité de ce que nous
proposons là c'est de mieux intégrer ces
personnes pour leur permettre de rester
de façon durable sur notre territoire et
contester cet accompagnement par la
langue française c'est contester une
bonne intégration et je pense que ça va
à l'encontre de tout ce que vous nous
dites malheureusement depuis le début de
l'analyse de ce
texte donc je vais mettre au voix
successivement al non pardon monsieur
son vous voulez répondre je voudrais pas
qu'on qu'on travestisse ce que j'ai ce
que j'ai pu dire en essayant en essayant
de de dire que je suis en en
contradiction avec ce que j'ai pu voter
la veille je dis simplement qu'il y a
une inégalité incontestable euh
s'agissant de de des femmes et de la
maîtrise de de la langue chez elles qui
n'est malheureusement c'est comme ça et
je le regrette pas la même que que celle
des hommes y compris en matière de
qualification et que notre pays
sonorerait à prendre en considération
les difficultés qui sont les leure pour
adapter mieux encore les formations
qu'on leur propose je ne vois pas euh
disant cela ce qui qui justifie les les
récriminations que vous venez de me
faire alors Monsieur rapporteur vouz
répondre mais dans ces condition il faut
voter l'article 1er à l'évidence nous
souhaitons renforcer l'apprentissage du
français pour accéder au au au titre de
séjour plurannuel aux conditions
présenté par Monsieur le Ministre il y a
quelques instants les saisonniers les
étudiants qui n'ont pas vocation à
rester au-delà de leur titre de séjours
sur le territoire national précisément à
la fois le contrat d'intégration
républicaine dont les formations prévoit
déjà l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes et par conséquent je ne peux pas
accepter votre amendement qui est
redondant avec le droit existant là nous
sommes sur les premiers titres délivré
et ensuite l'effort supplémentaire avec
l'obligation de résultat mais mon cher
collègue l'obligation de résultat c'est
l'émancipation par définition donc je ne
peux être que défavorable avec vous et
je soulligne en effet vos
contradictions alors je me voie là
d'abord le 876 qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté le 874 pour contre rejeté
le 875 monsieur
Solignac son mon frère monsieur Vall
pardon euh le gouvernement remet 6 mois
suivant la promulgation du présent texte
un rapport au Parlement évaluant
l'intérêt que pourrait présenter l'accès
à la formation professionnelle des
primaux arrivants nous sommes convaincus
peut-être autant que vous que
l'intégration par le travail est
évidemment fondamentale et pour accéder
au travail rien ne vaut sans doute
l'accès à la formation professionnelle
au plutôt dans son arrivée dans un
parcours migratoire voilà c'est un
rapport ça ça ça mange pas de
pain monsieur le rapporteur
oui c'est un c'est un rapport un petit
rapport que vous auriez pu glisser
d'ailleurs à l'article 1er a il aurait
été fort intéressant de compléter le
rapport présenté par le Gouvernement sur
cet aspect au Parlement pour le débat
sur les objectifs chiffrés concernant la
politique migratoire et je note surtout
cet amendement il est il est faux parce
qu'il écrase totalement l'article 1er il
le supprimerait pour par conséquent
défavorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour
contre rejeté le 401 Madame
Dupont Madame
Dupont pardon monsieur le Président
alors il s'agit de l'amendement qui
concerne ah madame p
excusez-moi je je je j'arrive j'arrive
j'arrive il est important celui-ci de ma
collègue ah mince où je l'ai mis je
l'avais à
l'instant défendu Madame Dupont oui
défendu défendu monsieur rapporteur ah
je vais je vais je vais reprendre en
réponse favorable favorable du
rapporteuroui il est très bien il est
très bien je le mets au voix avec la vie
favorable du rapporteur qui vote pour oh
qui vote contre il est adopté euh
le 659 monsieur saintou ben oui c'est
c'est très bien
par Monsieur
sintoule
allez-y merci monsieur le Président
alors c'est un amendement de suppression
on vous demande on propose de supprimer
l'alinéa 2 qui a été ajouté au Sénat
puisqueen réalité C cet alinéa est
maximaliste soupçonneux et super
fettatoire maximaliste parce que
évidemment il entend imposer des des des
obligations qui n'existe pas pour les
parents autres que les parents d'enfants
les parents immigrés il est soupçonneux
parce que en gros il postule que les
étrangers ne sont pas capables de bien
élever leurs enfants c'est dans le
respect des lois tout simplement et il
est superféatoire parce qu'en réalité
définir ce qu'est une bonne éducation
c'est d'abord simplement s'assurer que
les enfants vont avoir de le de l'amour
première chose c'est la première chose
qui compte dans l'éducation mais surtout
que du point de vue civique ils seront
amenés à respecter les lois ce qu'on
attend de n'importe qui et il y a aucune
raison de pointer du doit les les
familles d'origine étrangère en
soupçonnant qu'elle ne serait pas
respectueuse des valeurs et des
principes de la République en réalité
tout un chacun est tenu pour d'être
respectueux des valeurs et des principes
de la République bon le fait est que
vous vous en abstenez régulièrement
puisque vous oublierz de ne pas
stigmatiser les étrangers ce qui est
pourtant un principe élémentaire de
l'universalisme r monsieur le rapporteur
mais il n'y a aucune forme de de
stigmatisation à considéré que il est
évidemment important que les les parents
participent à l'éducation enants et
notamment sur les valeurs et les
principes de la République donc
défavoraable évidemment mon cher
collègue monsieur gilet
oui monsieur le Président notre groupe
entend alors quand je dis notre groupe
là je cite la France insoumise notre
groupe entend supprimer la disposition
ajoutée qui impose à l'étranger en tant
que parent l'engagement à assurer à son
enfant une éducation respectueuse des
valeurs et des principes de la
République ainsi qu'à l'accompagner dans
sa démarche d'intégration notamment à
travers l'acquisition de la langue
française bah j'ai du mal à comprendre
là la France insoumise donc la France
insoumise vous êtes contre le fait que
les parents assurent à leur enfant une
éducation respectueuse des valeurs et
des principes de la République vous
voulez que finalement les parents
fassent quoi enfin je expliquez-nous ce
que vous voulez concrètement c'est
l'anarchie totale c'est un petit peu
comme sur c proposez que des choses qui
vont à l'encontre des valeurs de la
République on a l'impression que vous
voulez lutter contre ces valeurs oui
monsieur
saintthou bon je je crains que notre
collègue ne se fasse moins intelligent
qu'il n'est en réalité nous ne
souhaitons pas que les parents élèvent
mal les enfants nous souhaitons
simplement qu'il ne soit pas précisé que
les les étrangers aient une obligation
spécifique de le faire voyez-vous en
réalité tous les enfants qu'ils soi
d'origine étrangère ou pas ont le même
droit à une bonne éducation et donc
cette formulation cet alinéa est
stigmatisant par ailleurs il est flou du
point de vue juridique parce que vous
serez bien en peine de nous expliquer
dans quelle mesure une une éducation ne
respecterait pas les valeurs et
principes de la République autrement que
simplement en respectant les lois ou en
faisant respecter les lois après je peux
je peux vous demander d'expliciter à
partir de quand considérez-vous que les
lois les principes et valeurs de la
République ne sont pas respter bah
écoutez on peut se poser plein de
questions hein mais vous ne vous vous ne
serez vous n'arrive mais dans ces cas là
les exemples que vous me fournirez ils
tombent déjà sous le coup de la loi en
réalité et enfin Monsieur Boua merci
monsieur le Président c'est dommage que
Monsieur saintou ait pas étél localil
l'avait été il aurait célébré des
mariages et il sait que lorsqu'on Marie
lorsque l'on Marie des gens il y a
notamment un article du code civil qui
du code de la famille pardon qui doit
être prononcé par l'élu en charge de
faire le mariage et qui rappelle aux
parents enfin au futur mariés pardon
l'obligation qu'ils auront à donner une
éducation convenable à leurs enfants
lorsqu'ils en auront ou s'ils en ont
déjà donc ce n'est pas du tout une
mesure discriminatoire de le mettre dans
la loi de le mettre dans la loi ici bien
au contraire il est bon de rappeler que
chaque parent qu'il soit français ou
étranger mais dans l'espèce puisque nous
parlons d'immigration s'il est étranger
doit donner une éducation convenable et
conforme aux valeurs de la République à
ses enfants et puis le petit paragraphe
sur l'acquisition de la langue française
on est toutes et tous d'accord j'espère
pour dire encore que les débats de lundi
nous ont prouvé que non du côté de votre
camp que pour être intégrer et assimiler
à minima il faut pouvoir parler la
langue française allez on vote qui vote
pour qui V vot contre il est rejeté le
74 le 73 ne sont pas défendus le 200 qui
le défend madame
lechanteux merci monsieur le Président
le titre premier du projet de loi
propose d'assurer une meilleure
intégration des étrangers par le travail
et la langue nous proposons par cet
amendement de réhabiliter l'exigence
d'assimilation desè lors qu'il s'agit
d'accueillir en France des étrangers qui
désirent s'y installer dur
ou définitivement pendant pendant
longtemps a prévalu vis-à-vis des
étrangers une tradition d'assimilation
Fernand brodel écrivait assimilation
possible accepter c'est bien je crois le
critère des critères pour une
immigration réussie l'accueil des
étrangers supposait l'adoption par ceci
de la culture française
c'est cette
exigence pardon de la culture française
j'ai perdu mal
10 secondes très bien je conclus par il
convient donc de réaffirmer l'exigence
d'assimilation à la culture française
comme condition sinequanon pour être
admis à résider durablement sur le
territoire national je vous
rapporteur défavorable je mets au voix
qui votre pour contre rejeté madame
jeunevard le
802 merci monsieur le Président je
propose d'ajouter après le mot
intégration les mots et de réussite
scolaire il est question d'éducation de
responsabilité des parents dans la
mission parlementaire que je conduis en
ce moment avec Fabrice l viigoureux nous
avons
auditionné des spécialistes qui
attestent de l'importance du bain
linguistique des enfants pour leur
réussite scolaire songez que à leur
arrivé à l'école maternelle certains
enfants connaissent 400 mots quand
d'autres en connaissent 1400 ça
conditionne leur réussite scolaire c'est
la raison pour laquelle cet amendement
vise à intégrer l'objectif de réussite
scolaire dans la démarche linguistique
des
parents monsieur le rapporteur oui je je
bien sûr je pense que chacun partage
votre point de vue de la même façon que
chacun partage le le point de vue du
Sénat selon lequel les parents doivent
pouvoir participer à l'acquisition de la
langue française la la difficulté c'est
que là nous créerion une obligation pour
les parents de garantir de s'engager à
la réussite scolaire de leurs enfants je
je crains qu'on crée une situation
d'insécurité juridique assez lourde
véritablement et d'ailleurs par
cohérence je proposerai dans quelques
instants un amendement qui supprime la
mention de l'apprentissage du français
parce que c'est l'école républiaine qui
a cette fonction non je crois que
l'équilibre l'équilibre madame me semble
c'est d'être extrêmement exigeant à
l'égard de tout ressortissant étranger
sur les principes et valeurs de la
République mais à l'égard de tout
ressortissant de nationalité française
aussi raison pour laquelle ce dispositif
il me paraît important de le conserver
je l'ai dit il y a quelques instants
lorsque des amendements de suppression
ont été déposés en revanche sur la
réussite scolaire sur l'apprentissage du
français je crains que on charge
considérablement les engagements
juridiques que devrait prendre les
parents dans les situations qui peuvent
être parfois difficiles de précarité et
cela vaut pour des ressortissant de
nationalité étrangère comme pour des
ressortissant nationaux donc
défavorables pour cette raison Madame
jeunevard Monsieur
saintoule Merci monsieur le Président
j'ai l'impression que Madame jeunevard
découvre la sociologie elle en anonne
les éléments mais je suis très inquiet
en réalité vous voyez son paralogisme
elle nous explique que parce que les
enfants d'étrangers naissent ou
grandissent dans un milieu dans lequel
on ne possède pas forcément parfaitement
la langue française il faut le imposer
un objectif de réussite scolaire
supérieure mais c'est confondre les
moyens et les fins bien entendu on sait
tous que dans le cas particulier
notamment de de l'apprentissage de la
langue ce qu'on appelle le bain de
langue dans la petite enfance permet
d'avoir un nombre de un vocabulaire
beaucoup plus riche mais le fait de
d'inscrire un objectif de réussite
scolaire dans un texte ne changera
absolument rien à cet état de fait que
évidemment quand vous êtes vous
grandissez dans une famille où on n'a
pas le vocabulaire et bien on réussit un
peu moins ou c'est plus difficile donc
ici l'amendement et la défense
d'amendement inverse totalement les
moyens les faits les causes et ne
justifie pas qu'on puisse voter pour
Madame jeunevard il y a pas une
obligation de réussite scolaire il y a
un engagement à accompagner son enfant
dans la voie de l'intégration et de la
réussite scolaire accompagner l'enfant
tous les tous les les les spécialistes
de l'éducation vous disent que c'est un
déterminant fondamental que
l'appropriation de la langue du du du
pays dans lequel on vit de la réussite
de l'enfant c'est pour aider à la
réussite scolaire ça n'est pas pour
stigmatiser vous méconnaissez
complètement le sujet en réalité
monsieur le rapporteur alors madame
jeunevard il faut bien se comprendre je
veux dire je ne ni pas l'objectif que
vous fixez je trouve que l'écriture pose
un vrai problème d'insécurité juridique
ce que je vous propose c'est pour la
séance nous puissions travailler très
précisément ce point vous savez que
quand je m'engage à le faire c'est suivi
des faits et donc je vous propose qu'on
trouve une une formulation qui ne crée
pas l'insécurité juridique il me
semble ressortir de cet article qu'il a
été proposé par le
Sénat je mets l'amendement au voix
madame Genevard pardon oui contenu de
l'engagement de monsieur le rapporteur
général c'est son deuxème engagement
donc j'en prends j'en prends bonne note
je retire mon amendement en vue de la
séance qui est retiré de c'est pas le
1700 madame la rapporteur
bienvenue merci euh beaucoup mes chers
collègues donc je vais vous présenter
euh l'amendement qui vient en fait euh
supprimer à travers notamment
l'acquisition de de la langue française
et pourquoi c'est parce que au risque
excusez-moi hein de de vous rappeler une
une évidence c'est euh l'école les
institution de la République qui
accueille et accompagne les les enfants
qui arrivent sur le territoire pour
qu'ils puissent rapidement apprendre le
français et euh faire leur leur
scolarité donc si je suis favorable à
l'alinéa tel qu'il a été introduit lors
des débats au Sénat et au principe selon
lequel bien évidemment ce sont les
parents qui doivent accompagner leurs
enfants dans leur démarche de scolarité
par contre et ça a été indiqué par le
rapporteur général je ne souhaite pas
créer une insécurité juridique en
rendant finalement les parents
responsables de l'enseignement du
français à leurs enfants et donc c'est
pourquoi je vous propose de supprimer
cet ajout je vous remerci monsieur Lucas
oui il faut effectivement supprimer cet
ajout moi je j'étais effaré parce que
j'ai entendu de la part de Madame
jeunevar enfin c'est quand même le but
de tous les parents que leurs enfants
réussissent il y a sans doute des
parents indignes mais enfin on pas
obligé d'écrire dans la loi et de
d'avoir une espèce de suspicion
particulière à l'égard à l'égard des des
étrangers al c'est vrai tout le monde ne
peut pas avoir François Fillon comme
père pour trouver un un un stage de
collaborateur parlementairire mais enfin
quand même globalement globalement tous
les parents veulent que leurs enfants
réussissent et la stigmatisation que
vous faites des parents étrangers est
particulièrement indigne elle aussi
contribue à ce fameux racisme
l'atmosphère dont j'essaie de démontrer
depuis tout à l'heure qu'il est prignant
dans ce texte et dans vos
propos monsieur ch
vergeroui merci
beaucoup je crois je crois que c'est un
je crois que c'est un sujet important
dans le micro monsieurger parce qu'ici
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
bruit il est allumé merci monsieur le
président je crois que c'est un sujet
important pour lequel on peut se passer
des fait de manches de de de canniveaux
qui ne grandissent pas le le travail de
notre
commission cette précision par
l'apprentissage de la langue française
est important madame la rapporteur je
vous rejoins la langue française c'est
l'objet de l'école de la République
c'est l'objet de l'école de la
République pour
autant le rapport à l'apprentissage
d'une langue est aussi conditionné par
la volonté ou non de la rejeter et je le
dis d'un point de vue qui est
particulier et qui est celui qui
acceptera toujours que on ne renit pas
une autre langue qu'on parle plusieurs
langues et le cas échéant une langue qui
a un attachement familial personnel
important mais si la famille rejette
l'apprentissage de la langue l'école
seule ne peut pas faire le travail et
donc on a bien besoin que ce soit et
l'école et les familles qui appréhendent
l'apprentissage de la langue pour les
jeunes enfants et ça me semble important
dans ce cadre-là de laisser cette
précision inscrite monsieur
Vallot je voulais dire que dans les dans
les familles dont on parle ce sont bien
souvent les les enfants qui apprennent
aux parents à parler et que fréquentant
les bandes de l'écool revenant avec leur
cahier ils aident leurs parents à
apprendre à lire et à écrire et que que
si le nombre de mots entendus par un
enfant est différent selon le niveau
social et la maîtrise de la langue par
les parents c'est à la crèche c'est à
l'école de le compenser c'est d'ailleurs
des expérimentations qui sont nées je
crois à Lyon et à Grenoble du parler
bambin pour que le nombre de mots
entendus par un enfant même venant d'un
milieu socialement défavorisé
culturellement peut-être moins impliqué
et bien puisse être rattrapé en réalité
je crois que nous pouvons partager cet
objectif d'un nombre de mots plus plus
nombreux entendus entendus dans
l'enfance mais que c'est une politique
public et que le désir ardent de tout
parents venant en France et précisément
que ces enfants fréquentent l'école de
la République et s'intègre parfaitement
alors je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement de la rapporteur qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté alors
il fait tomber le 75 et le 76 à ma
connaissance n'est pas défendu par
contre le 1583 peut
l'être madame
gevnou c'est le 1585 monsieur le
Président 1583 madame guevnou alors si
c'est le 1583 il est retiré monsieur
Président il est retiré pardon
excusez-moi effectivement je l'avais
encore dans mon dossier pourtant le 1110
s également retiré mais iliche n pas
affiché pour vous et le 1585 vous pouvez
le faire alors madame gu oui merci
monsieur le Président cet amendement il
vise en fait à à renforcer la formation
civique en en fait en s'inspirant de ce
qu'on avait fait dans le cadre de la loi
confortant les principes de la
République en étant en explicitant
clairement ce que sont les valeurs de la
République c'est-à-dire la liberté
l'égalité l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes la fraternité la laïcité
l'État de droit les libertés
fondamentales et et de permettre en fait
ainsi d'avoir une formation civique
renforcée et en particulier sur ces sur
ces sujets et également
d'avoir et d' vooir également une
présentation de l'histoire des
principales caractéristiques Gé raphique
et la société française ce qui nous
semble important dans le casadre de cet
article madame la
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
alors temps pour des questions d'
excusez-moi c'est difficile à dire et je
suis un petit peu fatiguée je vous prie
de m'excuser intelligibilité j'ai réi à
le dire et de clarté de la loi mais
aussi à la fois pour le symbole je tiens
à vous dire que je suis favorable à cet
amendement puisqu'il vient expliciter
directement dans la loi à la fois le
contenu de la formation civique tout en
laissant au domaine réglementaire toute
la latitude nécessaire pour dispenser
ces enseignements c'est donc un avis
favorable madame
marttin merci de me donner la
parole cet amendement est
rendu fort compliqué par par plusieurs
aspects le premier c'est que bien
évidemment les programmes sont ce qu'ils
sont mais ils ne sont pas si mal faits
que ça donc il y a d'ors et déjà par
exemple du côté de l'histoire géo un
certain nombre de choses qui sont
effectivement
enseignées l'histoire et les principales
caractéristiques géographique de la
France les grandes étapes de la
construction européenne bon et le
deuxième élément s'il y a des choses qui
aujourd'hui évidemment ne le sont pas
par exemple les démarches d'accès à
l'emploi à la formation au service
public et cetera donc moi je me pose
deux questions la première c'est votre
vision des programmes et la seconde
évidemment c'est dans un contexte où on
manque cruellement d'enseignants pour
des raisons que vous connaissez vous les
faites fuir au vu de leurs conditions de
travail de rémunération et cetera mais
surtout il y a des compétences qu'ils
n'ont pas comme par exemple
l'explicitation des démarches d'accès à
l'emploi à la formation au serviceplique
au logement c'est quand même des sujets
qui sont assez précis monsieur vot
oui dire que je suis défavorable à cette
proposition il y a un conseil supérieur
des programmes qui a été créé qui a des
garanties d'indép ance pour
s'éviter en effet que il y ait au fond
une histoire officielle l'histoire
appartient aux historiens et ça nous
évite aussi les récits nationaux
fantasmés je crois que le Tour de France
par deux enfants n'est plus d'actualité
en terme de méthode et puis par ailleurs
on a un enseignement moral et civique
avec des enseignants qui sont
théoriquement formés même si on a pris
beaucoup de retard depuis 6 ans à la
pédagogie des valeurs de la République à
la pédagogie de la laïcité se posant la
question de savoir comment on enseigne
ces valeurs pour les faire partager pas
seulement un catéchisme mais des valeurs
rattacha aux coordonnées de sa propre
vie pour que l'on puisse les éprouver au
quotidien donc je crois que ça n'a pas
sa place dans un texte de
loi
donc il y a plus deinvenant c'est deux
monsieur goselin je suis désolé on passe
au vote qui vote
pour qui vote
contre alors attendez faut que je
recomte qui vote
pour qui vote
contre 20 contre 19 il est
adopté le
monsieur madame
ogool pardon merci monsieur le Président
euh cet amendement de mon collègue taché
vise à s'inspirer du rapport taché de
2018 qui proposait 72 proposition pour
favoriser l'intégration des immigrés
justement et donc quand on a quelques
bases travaillé c'est toujours mieux de
les appliquer d'autant que ce qu'il
propose vise à une meilleure efficacité
cé dans la pédagogie pour
l'apprentissage des langues ce qui est
je pense ce que nous
partageons madame la rapporteur
oui merci alors on on partage le le fait
que la
formation linguistique soit importante
le niveau aussi qui doit qui doit être
atteint effectivement c'est
important mais en fait si vous
voulez d'une manière générale et et vous
le verrez je présenterai des amendements
en ce sens il ne me semble pas
nécessaire d'inclure dans le décret ce
niveau et on va voir le débat de façon
plus large par la suite mais pour
indiquer les raisons pour lesquelles il
me semble et c'est ce que je vous
proposais que ça doit être fait par
décret mais sur le fond je partage votre
votre
proposition je le mets au vois qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est
rejeté le 1701 madame la
rapporteur merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président donc je crois qu'on peut tous
partager sur les bancs le fait que
l'accès à l'emploi c'est un des facteurs
clé pour une intégration qui soit pleine
et entière des étrangers primau
arrivants et la 4e journée de la
formation civique est consacré
d'ailleurs à cette thématique dans le
détail cette journée elle permet de
présenter le fonctionnement du marché du
travail ça a été évoqué d'ailleurs he
par madame Martin les structures
d'accompagnement les code de la vie au
travail les outils aussi de la formation
professionnelle donc pour
accélérer l'employabilité de ces
étrangers Primot arrivant des
expérimentations sont d'ailleurs en
cours afin de proposer des parcours de
formation à viser professionnels et
notamment dans les filières des des
métiers en tension et enfin les
signataires du cire sont tous tous
titulairire d'un titre les autorisants à
travailler et peuvent de droit et ça
certains ne le font pas mais je tiens
vraiment à le à le rappeler ils peuvent
s'inscrire à Pôle Emploi d'ailleurs près
de 15 % d'entre eux arrivent au titre de
l'immigration économique et ont déjà un
contrat de travail au moment de la
signature du cire donc la disposition
visant à conditionner l'accompagnement
professionnel des étrangers signataire
d'un sire et al leur suivi avec sérieux
et assiduité des formations et civique
et listique aurait pour conséquence de
retarder l'entrée en emploi de ces
publics c'est pourquoi je vous propose
de supprimer cet
alinéa je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté il
fait tomber les amendements 468 et
420 alors c'est pas celui-là pardon ça
c'est ça c'est le 1701 donc donc c'est
1698 pardon madame la rapporteur oui
merci monsieur le Président c'est c'est
un amendement qui supprime l'obligation
de passer l'examen directement en fin de
formation civique pour des raisons vous
le comprendrez hein opérationnelles mais
il maintient l'examen comme condition de
la délivrance des titres pluriannuels en
en effet hein la dgef nous a indiqué que
l'instauration d'un examen obligatoire
clôturant la formation civique en fait
poserait des difficultés pratiques dans
sa mise en œuvre et aurait pour
conséquence en fait de réduire le temps
passé à expliciter les contenus
obligatoires de la formation je vous
remercie je le mets au voix qui vote
pour le
rapporteur qui vote contre il est adopté
donc il fait effectivement tomber le 468
et le 420 madame la rapporteur le
1699 je vous remercie hein monsieur le
Président alors là c'est une correction
légistique puisqueen l'état de la
rédaction adoptée par le Sénat
l'attribution de la la CSP n'est rendu
possible que si l'étranger a bénéficié
de cours français gratuit dans son
département et ça ajoute à notre sens
une condition supplémentaire et je crois
ça n'était pas ce qui était poursuivi
comme objectif par nos collègues
sénateurs je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté le
1688 madame la
rapporteur alors je vous remercie
monsieur le président donc ça c'est un
en cohérence he avec ma position sur des
amendements de suppression c'est un un
amendement et je l'indiquis à l'instant
à Madame regol qui vous propose en fait
de renvoyer les niveaux de langue à un
décret en Conseil d'État c'est déjà le
cas dans notre droit pour les cartes de
résident et pour la naturalisation et
c'était aussi le cas du projet de loi
qui était déposé sur le bureau du du
Sénat alors le premier point c'est que
je sohaite éviter autant que possible
l'intrusion du domaine réglementaire
dans la loi vous le savez ça rend nos
lois plus fragiles en cas de changement
des normes réglementaires qui sont
référencé dans dans notre législation ça
c'est le premier point et le deuxième
c'est qu'en fait vous le savez on est à
la commission des lois le renvoi au
règlement en plus d'être pertinent en
l'espèce ça nous permet aussi d'être
plus souple et plus agile dans
l'évolution de de la loi et aussi
d'avoir une réglementation qui est plus
précise plus
adaptée j'entends he les les les
préoccupations des parlementaires et
c'est celles qui sont précisé dans les
amendements qui qui viendront donc
peut-être que le ministre souhaite nous
apporter des des éclairages par rapport
aux points qui sont évoqués madame
guevenous amendement
identique monsieur saintthuile le
sous-amendement merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur chers
collègues sur cette proposition
d'amendement de Madame jaquier Laforge
il nous a semblé intéressant pour le
groupe lot de fixer un principe simple
nous nous considérons que si tout ne
doit pas être dans la loi et tout et que
cela peut être renvoyé au décret il y a
des principe qu'il faut pouvoir fixer
nous considérons que la logique
d'intégration elle passe d'abord par la
capacité à construire des échanges et
que ça passe donc surtout et avant tout
par la pratique orale du français nous
le savons il y aura des discussions sur
la capacité à régulariser des
travailleurs généralement il s'agit des
métiers en tenstion qui sont des métiers
où c'est la pratique orale qui est usité
et de manière générale ce ce texte nous
semble intéressant à la condition qu'il
ne F pas les choses donc la proposition
que nous formulons là c'est un un
sous-amendement qui fixe la règle que
c'est à travers un engagement oral que
nous allons vérifier la capacité des
personnes requérantes à à pouvoir
s'intégrer c'est la condition de notre
point de vue d'une intégration réussie
si nous fixons la règle à l'écrit et
strictement à l'écrit je vais être
désagréable avec tout le monde euh par
moment sur notre territoire on serait un
peu surpris donc je vous invite à faire
en sorte qu'on soit pragmatique sur le
sujet je vous remci madame la rapporteur
votre avis sur le sous-amendement pardon
il y le 655 dans la DC mais il est pas
dans mon dossier alors le 655 qui le
défend pour la France
insoumise l'amendement
155 bon pas défendu madame la rapporteur
B non je l' appelé trois fois M t
allez-y
mais alors merci d'abord je voudrais
dire ça rien à voir avec l'amendement
que si on doit travailler ici jusqu'à
minuit il va falloir arrêter la
ventilation parce que moi là je me
prends la ventilation depuis tout à
l'heure dans les oreilles et c'est
vraiment très désagréable voilà alors
nous sommes contre la création d'un
niveau de langue obligatoire pour
l'obtention d'une première carte de
résident ou d'une carte pluriannuelle au
terme d'un d'une première année de
séjour bon les dispositions supprimées
prévoient la création d'un prérequis de
niveau de langue française pour
l'obtention d'une première carte de
résidence et d'une carte pluriannuelle
et donc je le redis euh si si on veut
vraiment favoriser l'apprentissage du
français il faut s'en donner les moyens
ce qui n'est pas le cas et donc dans
jusqu'à présent comme l'état est
défaillant ça repose sur le bénévolat et
sur les associations
donc je le redis aussi rapprochez-vous
du ministère de l'Éducation nationale et
faites en sorte que les l'apprentissage
du français déjà dans l'éducation
nationale soit effectif et bien
organisé
madame la rapporteur vos
avis après
aprèsationamendement oui alors en fait
effectivement c'est ce que je vous ai
indiqué de façon de façon
liminaire en fait alors sur le 655 parce
je suis désolé moi je l'ai pas je l'ai
pas dans l'ORD alors peutêtre commencer
par monsieurint paril l'a présenté en
premier monsieur le Président c'est ça
alors monsieurint moi je suis
effectivement
pasar
faitlez comprend tout à fait le fait que
ce soit nécessaire de prendre en compte
la question d'oralité puisque on a un
certain nombre de de personnes qui
viennent et qui sont effectivement
analphabète donc elles peuvent très très
bien maîtriser la dimension orale et
pouvoir s'intégrer très bien à la fois
de façon personnelle et à la fois dans
le milieu du du travail sauf que c'est
ce que j'ai indiqué de façon
préliminaire il me semble que ça ne doit
pas figurer dans le texte de la loi mais
je partage tout à fait euh votre
attention sur le sujet et je pense que
peut-être que le le ministre pourrait
préciser les choses à ce niveau-là et là
aussi indiquer de façon concrète comment
est-ce qu'il compte mettre en œuvre
c'est C à la fois les les les cours et
le contenu des cours et à la fois
l'évaluation les modes d'évaluation
parce qu'on sait très bien qu'une
personne qui est analphabète ne pourrait
pas valider son niveau de français qui
peut être de façon orale excellente
donc ce sera une demande une demande de
retrait chers collègues monsieur
monsieur le ministre pardon non pour
répondre en quelques mots à Madame la la
rapporteur comme je suis explicité lors
de notre première discussion autour de
la question de la langue voilà une
journée et demi j'ai proposé que je
soumettre à la commission des Lois du
Sénat et de l'Assemblée nationale comme
j'ai fait pour la lopmie les les textes
réglementaires qui vont encadrer la
façon dont on va pouvoir mettre en place
cette exigence de cours de français mais
aussi autour des examens des valeurs de
de la République je vous remercie de
renvoyer au texte réglementairire ça
paraît la fois plus souple pour les
prochains ministres l'intérieur mais
aussi pour respecter la différence entre
le domaine de la loi et du Règlement
mais il est évident que la moyenne des
pays européens que nous avons autour de
nous est autour de du niveau A2 celui
qui avait d'ailleurs défini les
séndateurs dans leur première version du
du texte donc je plutôt sur cela que
nous nous orientons mais je consulterai
évidemment les les les deux commissions
des lois sur la façon dont les choses se
se font je pense que il est très
important et pour répondre notamment
sous amendement de du député saintuile
avec les employeurs il faut bien penser
ce texte pas simplement article par
article mais dans son titre 1 cohérent
l'article 2 monsieur le député prévoit
notamment le fait que désormais on va
créer une sorte de 1 % intégration c'est
comme ça que que je l'appellerai ça vous
parle dans notre département commun qui
crée l'obligation pour les employeurs de
pouvoir laisser du temps à l'employé
pour pouvoir prendre ses cours de
français et pour pouvoir organiser le
temps et bien sûr l'organisation faite
par les préfectures et les associations
en lien avec l'augmentation très
important des crédits du ministère
d'intérieur sur l'intégration puisque
dans la lopmie vous avez voté
l'augmentation de 25 % des crédits
d'intégration 100 millions d'euros qui
sont consacrés à ces cours de de
français et à cette exigence de français
donc ce que je propose c'est que une
fois le texte adopté s'il était par
l'Assemblée nationale puis promulgué
après une CMP une fois qu'il y a un vote
global bien sûr du Parlement français de
revenir très vite vers vous avec que les
dispositions les textes réglementaires
vous les soumettre en consultation comme
j'ai pu le faire lors la lopm afin que
qu'on soit compris évidemment les
contraintes bien sûr du ministère de
l'Intérieur les moyens s'il faut en
rajouter les partenaires comme les
associations les préfectures et et bien
évidemment les les employeur quel qu'il
soit et pour pouvoir répondre à l'esprit
du
législateur Madame Dupont oui merci
monsieur le Président je je viens en
soutien de du sousamendement monsieur
saintuil puisque moi-même j'ai un
amendement dans le même esprit hein sur
cette nécessité d'un apprentissage et
d'un niveau de langue euh on partage
tous hein pour une bonne intégration
parler le français c'est essentiel mais
lorsqu'on conditionne un certain nombre
de décisions à un niveau de langue je
crois qu'il faut être prudent parce
qu'il y a des étrangers qui n'utilisent
pas l'alphabet latin ou encore qui sont
non scripteurs non lecteurs dans leur
propre langue et l'atteinte du niveau A2
est donc euh exigeant pour eux et je
pense que ils peuvent très bien se
débrouiller à l'oral et avoir un un
niveau tout à fait satisfaisant l'oral
mettre en difficulté à l'écrit or les
examens aujourd'hui qui sont proposés se
concentrent aussi sur ce niveau écrit
donc moi je pense que c'est important
que dans le dur de la loi on mentionne
justement notre attachement à un niveau
mais un niveau oral en
priorité non mais je oui bien sûr c'est
exigeant incontestablement ce texte de
loi vient rendre plus contraignant
l'accès alors on est bien d'accord pas
au territoire français mais au titre
pluriannuel je pense qu'il faut bien
comprendre cela les étrangers qui
n'auront pas réussi cet examen pourront
passer plusieurs examens et auront des
titres certes d'un an ou de 18 mois et
de pourouvoir acccéder à un titre
plannuel c'està-dire et en vocation au
groupement familial soyons aussi
cohérent avec les premiers articles du
texte de loi pour pouvoir s'installer
durablement moi j'entends la question de
l'oralité mais mais disons-le très
franchement ce n'est pas faire non plus
extrêmement à mon avis de donner toutes
ses chances pardon aux étrangers si on
naccepte que l'oral et sans une partie
de l'écrit parce que on sait tous que il
existe des difficultés extrêmement forte
pour ceux qui ne disent pas le français
vous avez étélu local je le suis je l'ai
été qui peut ne pas voir que dans les
immeubles dans les maisons des
territoires où il y a on le sait des
personnes étrangères plus nombreuses on
n'ouvre plus on n'ouvre pas les
courriers administratifs indépendamment
du fait qu'ils sont parfois mal écrits
et et abscond parce que justement on a
on a peur de ce corer on ne sait pas si
c'est une facture ou ou ou une lettre de
droit et dans le non recouvrement de ces
droits que vous dénoncez parfois à juste
titre il y a le fait que il y a une
différence profonde qui existe entre
ceux qui sont capables de décrypter un
minimum de français sur une lettre
administrative et ceux qui ne le font
pas et bien sûr que c'est difficile
d'apprendre le français c'est évidemment
une une charge et et un effort et
personne ne le sous-estime ici mais il
est évident que pour plein de raisons
qui tiennent me semble-t-il à la bonne
intégration au territoire national ça ne
me paraît pas insurmontable alors c'est
pas parce que c'est difficile et et je
pense que le sujet c'est celui des
moyens et celui des des moyens qu'on va
donner aux personnes pour réussir cet
examen qu'on doit pas l'exiger l'uralité
euh bien sûr on peut y insister j'ai
bien compris la demande des commissaires
au loi pour y insister j'y suis sensible
ne peut pas se faire sans un minimum euh
de lecture on va on sait bien que
l'analphabétisme lire le programme
télévisé accéder euh à des services
publics en mairie avoir un minimum de
relation avec son téléphone portable
c'est parce que c'est comme ça aussi que
les choses fonctionnent lorsqu'on est
dans une démarche administrative
désormais vous le savez bien c'est à mon
avis répondre à l'intégration que l'
souhaite pour étrangers qui s'inpr de
manière pluannuelle donc moi je ne
rejette pas le sousamendement monsieur
saintuil je lui dit qu'on peut le
travailler on peut mettre l'accent sur
l'oralité on va pas mettre l'accent que
sur l'oralité et la question des moyens
et l'engagement des moyens se pose mais
je je pense que ce ne serait pas non
plus une bonne chose que de refuser par
principe l'idée qu'il y ait un minimum
d'écrit et de compréhension de la
lecture donc je sais pas si vous
adopterez ou pas le sousamendement
satile s'il est adopté il faudra qu'on
le corrige pour que me semble-t-il on
comprenne de façon générale ce qu'on
essaie de faire collectivement s'il
n'est pas adopté je propose qu'on y
revienne en séance en y travaillant je
pense que ce serait une erreur de
refuser la lecture et l'écriture au
minimum j'ai C inscrits après on votera
Monsieur nelen Merci monsieur le
Président je viens je viens en soutien à
l'amendement collègue Benjamin
saintthuil on on est d'accord sur le
fait que pour une meilleure intégration
il est nécessaire d'avoir une part
d'écrit une part d'orale néanmoins je
pense qu'on peut tous être d'accord que
l'oral dans notre vie du quotidien est
beaucoup plus est beaucoup plus
important quand je parlais tout à
l'heure d'intégration par le travail
c'est principalement des métiers où
c'est c'est l'oral qui est mis en avant
dans des postes de serveur dans tous les
postes de service d'ailleurs et donc le
fait d'accentuer plus sur cette partie
orale nous paraît extrêmement important
deuxième point si on regarde aujourd'hui
soyons honnête le niveau qu'on peut voir
lors des change d'SMS ou sur les réseaux
sociaux ou autres quand on voit la
maîtrise écrite quelquefois on se dit
qu'il serait dommageable de demander à
un étranger une plus forte maîtrise de
l'écrit que on peut voir nous-même dans
notre vie de tous les jours d'où le fait
d'appuyer un peu plus en fin de compte
sur cette maîtrise orale qui est le but
de l'amendement que sur l'écrit sans
occulter complètement l'écrit bien
entendu
madame
oui je pense que c'est une question
extrêmement important que celle de la
place de l'oralité dans l'apprentissage
du français et notre souci bien sûr
c'est que en apprenant le français des
étrangers puissent mieux vivre avec nous
et mieux s'intégrer pour
autant nous ne pouvons pas à raison du
dispositif que nous retenons sans mettre
en avant comme le fait cet amendement
l'apprentissage de
l'oral mettre de
côté des étrangers qui sont vraiment
intégrés totalement et qui échouent
successivement chaque année l'exercice
écrit qui leur est proposé moi j'ai un
exemple d'un turc qui a qui vit depuis
40 ans en France qui est marié une femme
française qui a des enfants français et
qui manie l'oral parfaitement il a un
petit commerce il répare des machines à
coudre tout le monde vient le voir tout
le monde l'adore il ne peut pas obtenir
la naturalisation française et il
ressent une frustration extrêmement
importante
ir dès lors que l'oral non mais dès lors
que dès lors que l'oral il est métrisé
et que Madame
tourign al moi j'aimerais bien que tous
les tous les Françaises et tous les
Français passent l'examen pour voir qui
obtient le niveau A2 qu'on demande à des
étrangers c'est complètement aberrant et
ensuite monsieur monsieur le ministre je
vous repose la question puisque vous
parlez de moyens et de moyens et de
moyens euh pour bien apprendre le
français il faut avoir un enseignement
qui est spécialisé c'est l'enseignement
du français langue étrangère c'est pas
n'importe qui qui peut le faire c'est
une formation spéciale donc est-ce que
répondez à cette question s'il vous
plaît est-ce que vous vous êtes
rapproché de votre collègue de
l'éducation nationale pour faire en
sorte que des enseignants qualifiés et
spécialisé dans C dans cet enseignement
qui est très particulier puisse
intervenir dans l'apprentissage du
français auprès des étrangers parce que
faire peser ça sur des associations même
avec des gens qui sont de très bonne
volonté mais qui n'ont pas forcément
cette spécialisation c'est forcément
voué à l'échec madame gnou
oui merci monsieur le Président moi je
je partage l'opinion de Christophe nelen
quand il dit que au fond l'oralité
apprend plus de places dans nos journées
donc VO on on parle plus que qu'on que
l'on écrit c'est évident
mais en revanche on se trouve aussi
confronté et ce sera le cas d'étrangers
qui vont bénéficier de ces cartes de
cesjours pluriannuel donc ils sont là
pour un long séjour se trouvve confronté
à des formalités administratives se
trouve confronté à prendre un abonnement
d'électricité prendre signer un contrat
de travail bref ils sont ils se
retrouvent confrontés à l'écrit et au
fond ça moi moi j'entend enfin je pense
que c'est un point extrêmement important
de pouvoir faire en sorte que ce niveau
aussi décrit il soit incitatif alors pas
un niveau d'exigence on demande pas
avoir une thèse en lettre classique hein
c'est ça reste le niveau à 2 donc
c'est-à-dire un niveau atteignable mais
je pense que c'est important d'avoir ce
niveau d'exigence c'est pour ça que moi
je soutiens au fond la demande du du
ministre de retravailler cet amendement
en vu de la séance Monsieur
sintuil Merci monsieur le Président je
veux réagir au au propos du ministre
pour le remercier de ses propos et pour
dire clairement les choses moi je
considère que si on fixe pas une règle
privilégiante l'oral l'obstacle de
l'écrit va se s'opposer à beaucoup et
donc si vous avez envie de réécrire
quelque chose qui dit qu'à la fin de
l'obtention du titre plurriannuel il
faut vérifier la capacité écrite des
gens qui ont obtenu le titre on peut
toujours en discuter mais je pense que
fixer la règle que c'est l'oral qui
prime pour obtenir le titre plurannuel
c'est une des conditions de la réussite
on demande pas à un cuistau on demande
pas à quelqu'un qui bosse dans le
bâtiment d'avoir une maîtrise de l'écrit
monsieur le ministre je vous donne
crédit que on a besoin l'écrit pour
s'intégrer de manière définitive mais ça
peut être à la fin de l'obtention du
titre plurannuel pour l'obtenir au
départ je pense que c'est l'oralité qui
doit primer et que s'il ne faut pas tout
faire apparaître dans le texte de loi
cette précision est utile avant de
renvoyer l'usage global au décret je
vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
général oui merci Monsieur le le
président sujet extrêmement important et
donc nos débats
sont absolument nécessaire moi je
voudrais simplement euh dire quelques
mots pour les mettre à votre réflexion
il y a un certain nombre de
nationalités qui appartiennent à des
pays francophones pour lesquel au fond
la question de l'oralité ne sera pas une
difficulté particulière il y a l'inverse
des nationalités pour lesquelles
l'oralité sera plus difficile que que
l'écrit je mets ça à votre réflexion je
ne veux pas je ne veux pas noter des
nationalités en particulier mais
j'imagine que pour un ressortissant
chinois qui souhaiterait venir en France
il sera être plus facile d'obtenir des
résultats satisfaisants à l'éclique à
l'oral et à l'inverse un ressortissant
d'un pays d'un pays francophone comme un
Sénégalais par exemple venant en France
pourra avoir plus de facilité à l'oral
qu'à l'écrit parce que au quotidien il
emploie ça lui arrive la frue française
mais c'est un élément je je crois que
l'oralité peut dans certains cas devenir
un élément de discrimination c'est ce
que je veux dire inversé j'attire juste
votre attention sur ce point par
ailleurs il est très important que un
travailleur en France qui qui a un titre
de séjour qui prétend avoir une carte de
séjour pluré annuelle puisse par exemple
vérifier des notices de sécurité dans le
travail et donc les lire lui-même et là
l'oralité sera sans doute utile mais
surtout la capacité de connaissance de
l'écrit c'est un point également que je
soumets à votre réflexion mais je
comprends en tout cas pour ma part avec
notre corrapporteur votre préoccupation
je je vous propose par conséquent si
vous l'acceptez de sous-amender votre
sous-amendement ce qui devient relatif
de façon à ce que nous puisss mettre
privilég le terme privilégié mais ça ne
résoudra pas toutes les questions que
j'ai soulevé dans mon
intervention qu'est-ce qui quel est le
sousamendement que vous déposez monsieur
rapporteur général je sousamende le
sousamend moi je voulais innover un
petit peu pour alors attendez qu qu
quelle quelle disposition de
l'amendement de la rapporteur vous
proposez de
changer
il bien réécrivons un sous-amendement
alors donnez-moi le sa le sainthuile
attendez privilégié alors le ministre le
ministre monsieur ministre vousz la
parole que que nul ne se méprenne moi je
propose enfin si le rapporteur général
est d'accord que que on le prenne et on
le modifiera en séance mais pour bien
montrer qu'il sujet monsieur le député
saintu juste peut-être
remarquer et je fais pas ça par face ici
mais pour la compréhension générale de
ce que veut faire le gouvernement
j'entends bien que pour devenir maçon
pour devenir restaur enfin serveur ou
cuisinier on n pas besoin de savoir
écrire mais moi je je ça m'intéresse pas
de faire un texte pour les entrepreneurs
dans Maçonnerie et pour les
restaurateurs mais tu émidemment
respectable mais moi j'essaie pour avec
vous de faire un texte pour l'intérêt
général de la République et l'intérêt
général de la République c'est pas
simplement répondre aux interrogations
du patronat qui est tout à fait encore
une fois compréhensible c'est faire que
l'étranger que nous allons accueillir
sur notre sol puisse vivre sa vie
d'homme et de femme de pouvoir lire son
contrat de travail au minimum de pouvoir
comprendre la convocation qu'il recevra
de pouvoir lire le carnet d'école de son
enfant de pouvoir répondre à un SMS
envoyé par un collègue donc j'entends
que la question de l'orale peut servir
quand on a une vision je pas pas se
procè à vous utilitariste euh de
l'étranger ce n'est pas la façon dont le
gouvernement à mon avis doit proposer de
légiférer ça doit servir aussi à ça mais
pas qu'à ça ça va servir aussi la vie du
citoyen je mets des guillemets
évidemment qui va nous rejoindre et qui
peut-être deviendra français aprèsdemain
donc je pense que ce qui est important
c'est pas simplement regarder l'utilité
pourquoi il est venu mais comment il
peut se débrouiller ensuite dans la vie
de tous les jours parce que ça me paraît
aussi important donc je propose qu'on
moi je donne un avis favorable sous
amendement vous avez compris que c'est
un amis de un avis de discussion et on
trouvera avec vous ou avec le rapport
teur général ou la rapporteur les moyens
de de trouver un compromis je l'espère
alors je comprends que
le le le sous-amendement de Monsieur
saintthuil reçoit de fait un avis
favorable en tout cas sous réserve de
retravailler je le mets au voix qui vote
pour l'amendement de Monsieur saintthuil
le sousamendement pardon il est enfin
pardon contre il est adopté ça me
paraiss évident et l'amendement de la
rapporteur et Madame gevnou ainsi
sous-amendé qui vote
pour qui vote contre
il est adopté alors il fait tomber la
quasittalité des amendements qui suivent
à l'exception de l'amendement 990 de
Madame
yousoufa allez-y madame
yousoufa pardon merci président alors il
s'agit par cet amendement d'introduire
une nouvelle exigence spécifique
concernant la maîtrise du français pour
les candidats souhaitant obtenir une
carte de séjour pluriannuelle pour motif
familial les professionnels euh
c'est-à-dire que le niveau de compétence
linguistique soit aligné sur celui exigé
pour les cartes de séjour résidents nous
estimons en effet qu'à Mayotte comme
ailleurs dans le pays c'est mieux de
parler français pour travailler et
s'intégrer je vous
remercie madame la rapporteur euh oui
alors en fait mon avis sera un avis de
de cohérence hein par rapport à ce qu'on
vient de à ce qu'on vient de voter parce
que effectivement je je préfère qu'on
s'en tienne au niveau de français du
régime de droit commun pour l'ensemble
des cartes de séjour plurannuel c'est ce
qu'on vient juste de voter donc par
mesure de cohérence donc ce sera soit
une demande de retrait soit défavorable
je vous
remercie je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté je
vais mettre au voix l'article 1er qui
vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté et je
vous propose qu'on en arrête là pour cet
après-midi et on reprendra 21h 30 au
même
endroit